[Music]
O hey everybody what's going on it's
November 1st and we're all having the
Halloween hangover it's always so
depressing like when it's the day after
Halloween I hate it yeah me and Jen had
a bad day
today it was a day as they say
man drove a 100 miles today I mean it
could have been a lot worse so let's not
go that far but it's just kind of like
it did kind of it it did pretty much
suck out loud went down to the VA just
had to give some blood for a
test had no problem rode down there on
my [__]
xb12 and then what the hell and then um
sorry the neighbors are being really
yeah the Neighbors being [__] they're
playing so much [__] [__] hold on I
got to make sure something's up yeah one
second we've had and it's not even the
next door neighbor I think it's the
house two houses down and they have just
been
blaring music and it's shitty music well
you know it wouldn't make it better if
it was good music because it's still
loud and it's really annoying and it's
like my office is right on the front of
the house like right over the garage so
when people like if anybody just like
drives by the house it's kind of loud
but this it's like rattling the [__]
walls and it's been doing that for like
an hour and I'm just kind of like I'm
about to go over there and burn that
motherfucker's house down or something I
kind of feel like because you can't call
the cops about a noise complaint because
it's too early like that only you can
only do that like past 10 p.m. I think
and it's only
7:30 so there's really not a lot of
recourse over just going over there and
like beating his ass or breaking his
[__] or something like that and then
probably I'd get in trouble you know
what I mean but
yeah it's real [__] annoying real
[__] annoying wanted to make sure
everything's all right I was working on
a bike earlier today yeah and I kind of
was afraid that I let the air compressor
on down in there oh yeah yeah cuz that
cuz that makes a real loud it wasn't
though cuz like I said I'm right over
the garage so anything that happens in
the garage or outside is like super loud
in here but yeah so this is what
happened um you you tell mad that
[__] so loud I know that's what
I was just saying [__] it's like it's so
obnoxious I'm going to I'm trying to
ignore it but it's really hard yeah I
don't know if you guys can hear it but
it's really really loud it's rattling
the whole house yeah it's like rattl in
the walls fixing a call the cops on a
dude but uh I'd imagine everybody else
is and he's Rich he's got a big old
[__] house an enclosed pool he's got
a whole bunch of [__] monster trucks
he's a big dude big white dude I don't
know what he
does he might he annoys people for a
living yeah he might be a sports figure
or something I don't know he's got a lot
of money but he's down there playing the
shittiest mixture of [__] country and
rap it's it's pitiful and it's like
autotune yeah some sometimes it's in the
same song too where it's half country
and half rap it's just crappy as [__]
he's got terrible Taste of music like I
said even if it was good it would still
be super annoying so I rode out of the
VA no problems got back on the bike to
come back and the [__] is making
it wouldn't start
and I said man that's bad battery
connection because it was showing signs
of having a bad battery connection but I
didn't didn't have time to go in there
and clean it usually the symptoms kind
of takes a while for him to get bad for
the bike one
start so I had to call Jen and Jen came
I couldn't tell her what tools to bring
she wouldn't know what to look for she'
never be like I just yeah I'd just be
digging around for ages she came and got
me said to go back to the house got my
tools came back adjusted the [__] went
to go turn the bike on couldn't find the
[__] key yeah
went all the way back to the house key
was sitting on the steps what happened
was is as I was leaving I went and
grabbed the [__] uh car key and
accidentally pulled the motorcycle key
out of my pocket and it fell on the
ground so then I went down there tried
to turn the bike on wouldn't
start again we jumped it and started it
rode it back I get it here I'm [__]
pissed battery had been totally drained
so I was thinking maybe bad Stater or
something I'm checking cleaning
terminals I don't know what the problem
is but the battery isn't dead it's not
totally killed it's not sulfonated it it
is taking a
charge but
it I don't know if it was just dirty
Terminals and it wasn't recharging that
well or if it was uh if it's a bad
Stater I got to go in there and cuz
sometimes my Stater readings man they
they look okay they look like [__]
you know 14 volts sometimes they look
like 11 and a half volts and you got to
have at least 12 so I don't [__] know
if I got to do another Stater man I hate
doing that in a [__] Harley-Davidson
State style motor you got to
[__] take the [__] drive sprockets
off but what we neglected to mention is
that the VA Clinic is 22 minutes yeah
from our house so we had to drive 100
miles today so yeah so basically cuz we
had to drive back and forth what five
times yeah because yeah we got back and
then like we could he couldn't find the
key and we couldn't figure out what
happened to it do another trip had to do
another trip so we were like it's got to
be at the house it's like you know where
else could it be cuz we thought maybe it
just fell out in the car or something
like that but it wasn't in there so we
had to come all the way back to the
house and it was on the stairs and it
was just kind of like H man it was just
like so that took like most of the
afternoon yeah I I don't remember what
time it was when you called me but it's
just like it took like most of the
afternoon so yeah that was that was kind
of a thing but you know at least we got
it all sorted out but yeah so uh
hopefully everyone had a good Halloween
last night we were kinded a little low
key we didn't really have that many
trick-or-treaters I mean there were
there were a lot of people walking
around the neighborhood I I saw like
when you looked out the windows and
stuff but it's just kind of like how
many did we have cuz you kind of went
down and not many once they actually
came yeah how many times they knocked or
how many kids how many kids cuz they
they tended to come there weren't that
many like about seven or eight yeah
there weren't that many like um each
time you know there weren't that many
like knocks on the door but there were
like there was a bunch of them like at
one time I guess is what it was but
honestly like all I did was like sit
around watching Joe Bob's Halloween with
the some leftover candy we got a lot of
candy left is what we're saying because
we didn't we never know like how many
and I think that's everybody has that
you never know how many cu some some
years it's like hardly any people and
then some years you don't have enough
candy and there's like a bajillion so we
were like well we got so we got like
several bags and we ended up not having
that many so we have a lot of candy left
over but there's nothing wrong with that
yeah there's nothing wrong with that and
I even got a bag of like some white
chocolate candy cuz I'm like I'm keeping
this just for me I'm not giving this to
the damn kids unless we absolutely had
to but we didn't so I still have it they
were showing some [__] videos from
how that he's back at it yeah they were
showing some videos from [__]
Halloween the one that's going around
right now it's like three adults and
about six little kids and there's some
kind of Eastern European they're not
speaking
English they're they're Caucasian but I
don't know what they are it sounds like
some kind of Slavic language they come
up on the house doing trick-or treating
and somebody has a bowl it's in a
wealthy neighborhood okay it's you can
tell it's by the porch they got a whole
bowl out there a full-on candy
bars they [__] take them all all of
them yeah that's going around now they
they're almost fighting each other for
them and they're they're they're yelling
in some kind of ceric language I don't
know like you know you can buy those at
every store in America right and then
and they're all the same family and they
act like they're just getting ready to
kill each other over the [__] and I'm
like they really like candy bars you
guys come on man come on man that [__]
is [__] embarrassing it is yeah but
they I guess they come
here you know what I mean they can't
handle high they can't handle a high
trust Society where you just just take
one they were full-size candy bars yeah
you know just take one candy bar for
every kid you know what I mean no it
took the whole [__] I would never
have the [__] audacity yeah it was
several cases yeah some people do and
that's just [__] floor me and I
wasn't raised like I wasn't raised in a
family like my family were real chill
they they weren't like oh beat your ass
if you're bad or anything it was nothing
like that I didn't I never got spanked I
never got like you know my parents were
real permissive but it's just kind of
like I just have this very very deeply
set moral code I'm just like that's just
not the right thing to do no it's if I
take them then other people can't have
any have one yeah but you know that's
that's they were there for just they
were all about themselves I'd have
jumped out and instantly punished
[__] you know I mean put those
down I'd have been [__] slapping people
be grabing little kids and [__] holding
kids hostages with [__] knives that
is not how you C down that is not how
you Halloween yeah put the candy down or
she loses her
hand step away from the child like yeah
I'd go straight bang on
them if I'm just trusting you I I can't
trust you all right I'm want my pound of
Flesh that's what I mean
yeah it's free candy but it's it's one
yeah there R don't get greedy Jesus
Christ it's free but it's for everybody
yeah that's what I mean it's like duh
that doesn't seem like that hard to
figure out mhm so you know what I mean
it's just like don't get in there with
that kind of [__] but that's but sadly
like a lot of people are kind of like
they're getting shamed though well
that's good that video is getting
[__] do you think they'll learn
anything probably not they probably even
have internet like I said well you know
just to get like current what what about
this jackass neighbor here who's
blasting his [__] music all night do
you think like he would be he's capable
of being shamed I doubt it no like if
you went over there and said hey bro can
you turn it down he'd probably like
punch you I can do what I want it's my
house that's probably what he'd say yeah
cuz there's a lot of people like that
they're very entitled I can do whatever
I want never gave that [__]
money yeah they should have given it to
me instead a genuine nice person yeah
just saying but yeah like even even like
the Halloween like where people couldn't
be home and they're just like they left
a bowl like out on the porch it's like
hey please you know honor System only
take one I would only take one you any
full siiz candy bars yeah full like I
don't need more than that anyway you're
going all around they had a camera on it
though they didn't think of that they
did they guess I guess up in Bulgaria
stand or wherever they came from they
didn't [__] have that cameras you got
him on camera good yeah that's probably
like a good idea another another [__]
evidently one of the one of the
neighbors saw it and they came from
across the street and put a bunch of
candy in that bowl yeah bunch of their
candy a see not everyone's horrible
there are good people out there the
thing about it is that I think most
people are like are pretty okay people
but it's like you don't hear about them
because it's not as egregious or
exciting as hearing about the [__]
not saying that there aren't a lot of
[__] because there are there are way
more [__] than there should be but
you know High Desert said I live in the
middle of the desert hence the name I
guess so never get kids thank goodness
so I watched when evil lurks thanks for
the recommendation oh you're very
welcome yeah I want I think more people
need to see that and like I said watch
the director's other movies to terrified
because that's also [__] great I
don't know if that's still on shutter it
was for a while trying to get me to put
wigs on already I mean you don't have
like a straight up Richard Simmons wig
yeah but Richard Simmons is a very very
still is a pretty popular um Halloween
costume I guess it's like pretty easy to
do like all you need is kind of like a
white boy afro wig yeah like a you know
kind of a tank top although he always
had those swarovsky crystals on him but
like you know what I mean like that was
kind of his thing not really and those
like little stripey shorts yeah and
everybody would instantly know who you
are which is crazy because he's such a
cultural icon still even though he's
like you know he's in his 70s now but
it's just crazy that people still know
who that is yeah we're going to talk
about today we're going to talk about
the [__] Richard sens this was yeah
this was kind of an interesting yeah and
there are some Mysteries behind Richard
Simmons we're going to talk about I had
not heard about this and I forgive
forgive me if I can't quite remember I
thought it was Victor uh Victor Garcia
that recommended this but maybe not like
was it you Zach I thought it was Victor
but I could be totally wrong cuz I I
forget stuff [__] like that all the time
but I don't write it down but I had not
heard I don't really keep up with um
celebrity news or I just don't have time
so I don't keep up with any of that like
you know celebrities are around us I
only have a vague you know recollection
of who they are um I know who Richard
Simmons is obviously because that's kind
of more from our era so I knew that was
but I had no idea that he had
essentially fallen off the grid kind of
and back in
2017 there was a six episode podcast
called missing Richard Simmons which was
like really popular and I listened to
all of it today um where a friend of his
was like trying to find out where he was
and what happened to him and why he
disappeared and all this other kind of
stuff and there was also I think it was
in 2022 so last year TMZ did a show
about it too and that's on Hulu if you
want to watch that CU I watched that
earlier today too but it's here's the
thing I kind of feel like maybe probably
there's nothing Sinister about it but
it's just weird I mean the whole
situation is kind of weird is just all
I'm saying cuz like I said I didn't know
anything about this but when I started
looking into it I'm like that is kind of
strange like just like considering what
like how famous he was how visible he
was um and then for him to just like
kind of essentially vanish off the face
of the Earth like I said they're pretty
sure they know where he is but they
don't really know
like why the whole thing happened and
like what's going on behind it so it's
just kind of like I don't know it's like
just a really interesting story yeah on
the surface when you talk about Richard
Simmons I was thinking this couldna be a
boring show but I don't think so there's
weird [__] about Richard Simmons well
he's an interesting person I always
thought of him as an interesting person
and uh oh Sebastian said terrifier with
the clown no this is a movie it's called
terrified it's came out in 2017 it's
Argentinian it's the same guy that did
when evil LS and it's great it's more
like a paranormal coming back from the
dead like haunting Poltergeist type
movie and it's super creepy and it's
great so it might still be on shter not
sure another thing about Simmons is that
it wasn't just him it was the era in
which he was
operating daytime television 80s and 90s
yeah and it was just a that was just a
generic [__] time it makes me think
of dead malls and D Dam bell videos and
[__] it was the daytime talk show scene
was just dumb as [__] man it it but
there was something it was basically
kind of like the opiates of the masses
anybody who is like unemployed or
stay-at-home mom they were watching that
[__] or like retired retired people or
they would also replay a lot of it late
at night so when you were coming home if
you worked midnights you came home late
after midnight you could watch it you
know before television went off or which
it used to back in the old yeah which is
funny if any people are like younger now
like what do you mean TV went off yeah
it went off after a certain time yeah
and you only had like four or five
channels unless you had cable and then
you'd have a whole bunch more it was
just snow but there was just more [__]
on the cables really cable is they had
more channels but that didn't mean it
was any good it was it was either snow
or infomercials yeah lots whole channels
of nothing but
infomercials and they'll put you to
sleep man they got to [__] lull you
to sleep and there something kind of
comforting about them yeah then you
had you had special channels you could
buy that had softcore porn on them and
if you didn't pay for them they just
look a bunch of wavy lines and when
you're a kid you try to look at them
wavy lines and every then every now and
then you'd see a Teddy every every Gen X
person remember especially the boys
obviously remember having to like see
the unscrambled like Playboy Channel or
something at is got a nipple try to look
at it sideways real quick you know
right all I remember that yeah I
remember that cuz you go up to like to
the higher channels like when they added
all the channels cuz when we when I was
a kid we only had four yeah like the
three networks PBS and then they added
Fox 35 so that was woo five channels but
then like in the early 80s we had I
think we had 47 channels and that blew
our [__] minds even though most of
them didn't have anything good on them
so television this goes all the way back
probably to the 50s if not the early
60s you had a t type of daytime
television that was U Fitness
oriented he had ones with had jackola
and [__] I remember jackae was still
doing this [__] when I was a little kid
I remember him and Jack was the [__] man
he ended up dying like at 96 years old
yeah he was in his 90s yeah and he still
looked good well he was on those juicer
infom he had that juicer yeah
now he got mad props everybody was like
impressed with with with uh with Lan
with Jack because he was breaking
records well into his 40s and 50s
swimming AC swimming across [__]
English Channel or whatever towing a
boat in his mouth you know [__] on a
rope and [__] he just all kinds of crazy
[__] he did do it now he wasn't natural
all right he was juicing but he just
didn't juice that much he just did it
mostly for Health and
Longevity uh
so in the fitness scene you know people
people would would like watch this [__]
early in the morning maybe do exercises
with them I think most people just
watched them do the exercise and they
felt like they did something it's like
I'm just going to sit on the couch and
eat a bag of La potato chips watch them
watch them like do my hands like this
I'm working out yeah watching them work
out I think that was a lot of it a lot
of it was them was guys like Lane just
talking to the audience and I think it
was kind of like Bob Ross in the
painting I think it would just kind of
like be amsr to him kind of lull him
it's hilarious to me that Bob Ross we
did a show about him too but um but that
he is so still such an icon yeah you
know what I mean just because he's so
chill and people will just watch it like
and relax it's like it's kind of nice so
they had a lot of Fitness ones some of
them were females some of them were like
hot females doing stuff they even had
some for cable I think it was called
jazzer size which was damn near [__]
porn I don't remember jazzer size being
particularly porny but that was like a
long time ago that I watched it maybe
maybe it was more porny toward like if
you were a teen if you were if you were
a guy Yeah well yeah but if you're a
teenage boy like everything is porn you
know what I mean porn was porn was not
available to us you know what I mean as
readily as nowadays yeah so you kids
today you got it so easy no the camera
angles and the they were like dancing in
unison and weird like disco type music
and [__] it's like here over look at her
they actually look like something of a
[__]
out look like something out of damn
Logan's Run you know what I mean where
they have the slow motion orgy or
something you know they were doing you
know when they in the dance club it kind
of looked like that um crazy camera
angles and [__] you know skinny
skinny Coke girl cokehead looking girls
[__] dancing in those leg warmers and
[__] God I remember leg I had some when
I was 10 I had some when I was 10 years
old yeah some gray ones so you had that
and then eventually they came came up
with
the Richard Simmons
concept which I think was kind of like
the Prototype of fat acceptance well the
interest kind well it's I kind of want
this was in one thing that I kind of
found like I you know I was around for
Richard Simmons being around because
like I said he was hard to avoid he was
like ubiquitous during the 80s and 90s
so I kind of but I didn't know a lot
about like his origins or like you know
the early part of his career cuz that
was like early 70s and I was still like
a really little
kid but that was one of the things that
I found most interesting is that I mean
he's pretty much a
self-made guy I mean he I don't even
know if he came up with a concept the
same way that you would come up with it
nowadays but you have to remember that
he was actually kind of a Pioneer in the
sense that all of the fitness [__] back
then like in the early 70s I'm talking
about like all the gyms and everything
like that were kind and you know and all
the fitness kind of um you they didn't
really have Fitness videos then but you
know what I'm saying like Fitness shows
and stuff that was all kind of catered
toward people who were already fit who
were already goodlook and already in
shape and were just trying to like
maintain or or at least like they wanted
to show like people that were in shape
so he was kind of the first person to
come out and be like um it doesn't
matter what you look like it doesn't how
old you are how much you weigh or
anything like that like anybody can do
this so he made everything like really
easy and really fun so people would want
to do it and then he would like
encourage them to eat right and he did
like a cooking show and stuff like that
so and he was like really um accepting
and he didn't shame anybody he didn't
and that really resonated with people
because a lot of people that were really
because and I think that happened
because it it was his own experience I
mean he was very obese from childhood
and so when he lost all that weight and
I'm want to get into that too because he
kind of did uh some inadvisable things
like to do that but then you know he
kind of became on a mission I want to
say like reading about Richard Simmons
like yeah it's in a lot of ways like
people kind of see him as like a joke or
a punchline or anything like that
because he's so over the top and he's
just like so eccentric and everything
like that but he just seems like a
genuinely really good person yeah and he
really really
genuinely wanted to help people and the
fact that he put so much of himself out
there
um is really maybe kind of ties into the
reason why he
disappeared uh at long last which like I
said we'll get into after a while but he
just I mean he would do [__]
for he would do [__] like he taught his
class I didn't even know this he had a
gym in Beverly Hills it's called
slimmons it was there for like it's it
was closed in in 2016 which we'll get
into in a bit but it was there for 40
years he taught classes there every
[__] week it was 12 bucks it was
always 12 bucks you just showed up paid
12 bucks and you worked out with Richard
Simmons and he had like all these
regulars that went there and they
[__] loved him yeah it was just like
this whole scene and everything like
that and he would do and he didn't have
to do that he was already a
multi-millionaire by that point yeah if
you don't know who we're talking about
if you're too young Richard Simmons was
kind of like a short
guy with curly hair real overthe
toop
energy um to me I'd call him like
visibly gay yeah um he's never come out
and said but came out but he's you know
I would probably put him up there with
like [__] Rip Taylor and he seems
more of a loner really which like I said
we'll get into that in a little bit to
he was some guys would call a [__] hag
girls loved him loved him especially fat
girls cuz he was he was into the fat
acceptance and he could he could he
could he could Vibe with them because he
was there and well he knew what they
were going through and knowing about
Fitness and everything a lot of what
Simmons had to offer was psychological
yeah oh big time that was more it was
more psychological Than Physical
now we had another show called bu
bullshido about all the [__] that
happened in martial arts scen and in the
movies and every and all the different
disciplines of martial arts not only
Oriental martial arts but Western
martial arts a lot of it is [__]
okay it's just a product to
sell it's even worse in the diet and
fitness industry even because the
Market's even
bigger almost
everything you will ever
hear in the mainstream market about diet
is a lie everything you hear about fi uh
physical training is a lie everything
that they show you in the results are
always
deceptive um there's just certain rules
that have to happen in order to become
very physically attuned especially after
the age of
30 when the way you look to look really
fit lean and muscular you have to have
have a very aggressive hormonal profile
most people will not have that profile
outside their
teens starts to taper off for men in
their late 20s okay if you want to be
physical after your late 20s man you
have to use anabolic steroids or you
have to use uh combined with
testosterone and the dudes that do this
then go on to become fitness trainers
and sell all these diet and fitness
programs to the normies and they never
mention right well yeah they're trying
to make money off their protein shakes
or whatever right they will openly lie
oh yeah you do my program you'll look
like me in four years five years no you
won't no you will not no you will not no
you will look like him in four or five
years if you were doing the same stacks
of steroids he's doing yeah but they
can't come they can't sell you that
though no one will [__] buy the
program because people are very ad
adverse to injecting themselves with
anything
and steroids have been a [__] uh have
had entire black propaganda campaigns
against them just based on what
teenagers do in high school and uh what
certain pro pro wrestlers happened what
happened to them and all those are
isolated cases and yeah those guys die
but you got to look at the damn [__]
autopsy reports to find out why and then
when you find out the levels of levels
of anabolic abuses those guys are doing
of course they died you know what I mean
some of those dudes taking 6,000 to
9,000 migr of [__] some kind of
anabolics a week I that's a [__] ton and
really would end up killing them was
just all that weight because the human
heart is not built to drive that much
muscle the heart can get strong and
powerful with the steroids but you can't
[__] get make those valves any
stronger those cartilage valves would be
struggling and flexing and wearing out
then that D die of heart failure because
he just got too [__] big and the you
you could there's a weakness is going to
appear somewhere and th those heart
valves can't get any stronger than than
the way they come from the factory
they're not muscles they're just they're
like pieces of plastic they don't
change
so in a
way Richard
Simmons kind of had a more truthful
approach to Fitness and I think people
responded to that because he was honest
he didn't look super ripped he didn't he
just looked like a regular guy yeah and
he was saying you know you can lose
weight if you get up off the couch and
just do these exercises and eat and he
encouraged like healthy eating as well
you know what I mean so he had like a
whole he did cookbooks and he would say
things like you could look like me but
you looked at him and he was very
average well that's what I mean that's
more honest yeah a lot more Hest you're
not telling you that you can look like
[__] the D the Taio dude like that
somebody mentioned earlier you're not
going to look like Arnold yeah you're
not going to look like Arnold all right
Arnold [__] I mean unless you go on
steroids or and spend hours and hours a
day in the gym and like weigh everything
you eat and [__] like that I still run
into I still run into these Bros modern
Bros from the modern era that can't
believe that Arnold Schwarzenegger did
steroids and I just I just what the [__]
are you talking about of course you
obviously you look at him at by age 19
he's just [__] shredded he's [__]
stacked he's Way Beyond human potential
he must have been eating anavar pills
and doing te eating anavar pills like
[__] candy you know he was big
yeah he had good genetics genetic you
can't just take those steroids and get
that big but he
could he had the genetics well that's
what I and that's what I mean and I and
I think that's another thing that people
again responded to because Richard
Simmons like I said just looked like a
regular guy and he wasn't telling you
yeah you're going to be all ripped and
jacked and [__] like that which you know
and and you still see it you still see
it in Fitness commercials and like [__]
for like yeah it's oh you know and the
implication even even if they don't say
it outright you know it's like oh the
implication take this protein shake and
like use this exercise machine and
you'll look like this no you probably
won't yeah and you will not buy Jack
Lan's juicer and look like Jack Lan from
drinking out of that juicer [__] you
crazy just lay on the couch and Dr why
am I not looking like Jaca this is not
working out the way go back and look at
pictures of jacan starting off in the
[__] 50s all right jackan was a
[__] beast man that dude he had a
very good classic physique he was he
didn't look like a like a golden era
bodybuilder or anything he just looked
like a a really good gymnast is what he
looked like that's not really that's not
natural he was doing tests he had good
genetics he was doing test and probably
doing things like anavar or oral little
steroid pills probably doing that but
there's no telling he might have been do
a little bit more I mean nalone would
have been available in his in his time
and that would have kept him looking
good and strong up until he died uh
which was in his 90s don't don't ever
let anybody tell you that steroids kill
you
no abuse of them will kill you yeah but
if you but abuse of pretty much anything
of anything will kill you but you can in
the second half of life you can take
stuff that'll kind of bolster you and
kind of rebuild build you back up you
know to replace the hormones you've lost
and but no [__] uh so Simmons his
approach was realistic expectations yeah
and he just being healthy losing weight
and he was and he was really genuinely
he really genuinely cared about these
people he would call up people he'd
never met like every week and like make
sure they were doing okay and like give
them a pep talk and all this other kind
of [__] and it was just you know and
that was what people needed it did work
now now Simmons target
market was usually
depressed very overweight females okay
yeah that was a large part of his
audience yeah that was his not all of it
but a lot of it was yeah and to his
credit that's a easy one to deal deal
with
because that's more diet than exercise
and and a lot of the diet is coming from
emotional problems depression as his did
as well which like I said that I think
that's why he could relate which like I
said we'll get into like why he was so
good at empathizing with other people
with those problems CU he had had them
as well to be female or even male
depending on the age but let's just say
you're you know a female in your 30s and
40s and to be very very overweight you
almost have to work at that you got to
eat a lot of food to maintain that
weight just cutting the food in half
you'll lose
weight now there's going to be limits to
that too you're eventually going to have
to start getting into better diets and
more exercise and you can lose a good a
good healthy amount of weight and get
down to a
reasonable size without any equipment or
anything you don't have to go to the gym
or the weight room or anything just
mostly just diet and just walking can
take a lot of that off now if you any of
you women hit that or in
that that
zone there's problems sometimes because
once you're beyond you know 30s you're
in your 40s the hormones you need for
the body's response to diet and exercise
are not really there so you usually have
to add something to get then we're
talking about anabolic steroids you have
to add that to get the mitochondria in
your cells running to burn fat but the
problem is is a lot of these overweight
women are not healthy enough to take
steroids there's a risk so you have to
start very slowly and increase the work
slowly and then you're doing the diet
and you're trying to clear the body out
of all those lipids and all those fats
then once you're down to a reasonable
weight then you can start accelerating
the work and accelerating the the
hormones to get real results but then
you're if you're talking about real
dramatic change you're G to have a lot
of loose skin so if you want to look
like [__] Bridget BAU you're going to
have to remove a lot of skin probably so
but that's not
what Simmons was Pro promising he was
talking about obese women living a
normal life being more average size yeah
he just wanted them to be healthier
right yeah and to like feel okay in
their bodies which like I said that's a
very realistic goal and I think that
people really responded to that because
he wasn't giving them unrealistic
expectations and Simmons acknowledges if
you I remember watching this show even
when I was a kid and I realizes yeah
it's not so much what they're do is what
they're thinking is [__] them up okay
yeah and he could relate because you had
gone through the same exact he he's he's
more targeting the problem and that's
their emotional problems right it's not
so much the exercise if you get rid of
the emotional problems then the Eating
Disorders then just with normal life and
getting up and run you'll lose a lot of
weight and be a lot healthier that's
really what he was doing so I I give him
that credit yeah yeah and like I said he
did and does presumably cuz he is still
alive as far as anyone knows but um he
does genuinely seem to care about other
people maybe to the detriment of his own
mental health I think but he is probably
and it's so weird that he became so
famous because he's such what they would
call like maybe in new Agy kind of terms
an empath
meaning that he seems to feel very
deeply what other people feel like and
that it it does not seem put on in any
way shape or form um but the problem
with that is that if you feel so much
for other people it starts to weigh on
you because he would get thousands and
thousands of letters like ever for you
know decades yeah from people and he
would call every single one of those
people and write back to everyone and he
felt like a personal connection to every
single one of those people and it's like
he was personally invested in all of
these people he's like a fat priest that
he didn't even well you know what's
weird is that he actually a lot of
shamanism and [__] well you know what he
was um he actually I saw like an
interview with him from a long time ago
and he was actually in seminary for um I
know that for almost two years like he
was thinking about being a priest he
knew what he was doing so um he never
came across as like super religious I
think he converted to Catholicism like
dad was a Methodist and I think his mom
was Jewish but um but he converted to
Catholicism later and he was thinking
about becoming a priest okay um but and
he was kind of making a joke about it
where he was saying I can't remember who
he was um who the interview was with but
he was saying that it's like yeah I was
thinking about becoming a priest cuz
like man you put that casso on and it's
like nobody can tell how fat you are you
know what I mean and it's like you can
get all the way you wanted it doesn't
matter but um but you know because he
was very very heavy but it just seems
like he's just one of those people and
like I said it's so weird that he became
so famous that all of his energy was
directed outward like toward other
people so I kind of feel like maybe what
had to do perhaps with his disappearance
we'll get into some of the theories and
stuff later but because some of them
were kind of weird but I think maybe
what contributed to it was that he just
couldn't um take it anymore which which
like I
said for 40 years maybe more than 40
years all he did was help other people
yeah listen to other people's problems
call other people he would call he would
make cuz all his friends and his
publicist and everything like that said
he would spend hours and hours on the
phone every single day calling all of
these people and like to like how's it
going like and he would just cry with
them and like you know spend hours on
the phone with them and it's just like
he did he had never met these people or
only met them one time and so he gave so
much of himself to other people that I
don't know if he had anything left for
himself because it's weird that he was
so outwardly he's very loud and
eccentric and ab bullant and he's just
like all this other enthusiastic all the
time but I think to a large extent that
was an act that's entirely for other
people I think more of a depressive type
yeah most people that know him said that
he's very he's a loner he doesn't hang
out with other people he doesn't party
he doesn't he just goes and holes up in
his house and he's like super quiet and
like super reserved but he's putting on
a thing for like other people I'm not
saying that he's putting on like caring
about other people CU I don't think
that's the case but all of the
enthusiasm and all of that kind of crazy
like the crazy outfits he would always
wear and just making everybody laugh at
everything it was like fat church he
compared himself to a court jester and
he said that's kind of what he felt like
he was just trying to make everybody
happy yeah we put I remember as a kid
you know as a kid while he was he put on
a show but it was also kind of like fat
Church it had a lot of it had yeah it it
it did have um what I call it kind of a
almost kind of a a a Baptist Revival oh
yeah big time Big Time like a spiritual
rev because he's trying to tap into the
uh to to feelings that these women are
having and trying to overcome these
boundaries he's getting to confess
what's wrong with them and stuff and how
to confront it and he would confess his
own [__] too and I think that's why
everybody felt comfortable doing because
he was very open about his struggles and
about his feelings and everything like
that so I think that made other people
feel more comfortable talking about
their [__] up [__] with him because
they knew that he had gone through the
same thing he was very open about it but
like I said and we've talked about this
with a lot of this happens with a lot of
like comedians for example like Robin
Williams is the um guy that Springs to
mind first a lot of
comedians are very
um other focused so it's like their
whole Focus is on making other people
happy making other people laugh um but
they themselves are usually very very
not all of them but a lot of them are
very very depressed or have a lot of
problems yeah um and that's kind of it's
a little bit of a defense mechanism yeah
but again it's it's kind of the same
thing that he had where he just just
felt like he wanted to help everybody in
the world um but didn't really but then
it just kind of like took everything out
of him you know what I mean which I get
that I mean that's got to be really
draining yeah you know but you know
look I'm jacked all right I wasn't
always um there were times where me and
Jen put on a lot of weight because we
like to [__] eat well love to cook
well Tom's a really good cook and I
[__] love to eat I'm going to blame
you I'm not blaming you I'm just saying
and if I if I'm so your food so Del I'm
not if I'm not all that busy and I I'll
just start going down certain Pathways
you know what I mean where I like well
I'm going to start thinking about food
and I'm think about cooking food making
this and that and if I'm not watching it
I'll go down in that direction and my
new discipline will be well I'm gonna
make all this food and I'm gonna eat
this
food I think some of the people who
become
very um obese kind of have a similar
thing where they're eating is almost a
discipline to them yeah it's like a
mission but you got to really watch it
because that's self-destructive it is
yeah overeating will kill you yeah as
much as drinking a lot or drugs or
anything like that maybe quicker yeah
for me I'm kind of replacing boredom
with this other people they might be
trying to cover up some kind of a pain
or depression or something like that so
they're going to try but boredom is
another Comm they're going to try to eat
it away right in the same way that a sex
addict might try to [__] it away right
you know what I mean like so you got to
face what what the deal is my my advice
is to pick up another discipline to get
your mind off of food yeah because and
you'll drop weight without even thinking
about it because me and you I kind of
feel like we're some like I said we love
food um we you know if anybody that's a
regular here on this show like it
usually devolves into talking about food
at some point but um then we had like a
little food show for a little while but
you know Tom is an excellent excellent
cook and everything he makes is like
delicious so it's really easy like he
makes this big pot of butter chicken or
something like that it's really easy to
eat like three bowls of the [__] just
like sitting there cuz so good and you
don't want to stop eating it yeah lat
around like we just had a damn ory we
had a ory with a bunch of Indians and
the chickens and [__] and [__] get
the curry and we're like eat some more
of that for real and then next thing you
know a couple months later we keep doing
that we're [__] fat again they're
like oh we got to get rid of this I
after like a few months after I moved in
with you I think I had gained like 30
lbs
probably probably maybe it was you
looked real thin maybe it took longer
than that it was longer than that you
looked real thin so you look like we
could get away with it we both kind of
gained weight we didn't really notice so
it was too late well I mean yeah I mean
when we when we moved in together I was
I would say underweight yeah a bit um so
I I kind of thought I could get away
with you know I I I think at one point I
was down to 118 lbs which it is too thin
for me I looked kind of ill um but I
wasn't starving starving but I wasn't
really eating all that much but yeah
when we moved in together Tom's like
well you're too thin you probably to
like gain some weight which I did but we
went a little too far with it going to
say I know a lot of people that were
just very obese and they had to bypass
surgery and everything they lost a lot
of weight and then they you now you look
at them You' never know that they were
ever overweight okay
um I probably wouldn't have gotten the
bypass surgery but there that's what
some people actually need they need that
they need that to get it off it's a lot
better than being obese because you can
die all right well they'll only do it if
you're over a certain weight or certain
body mass they don't they won't do it
just for anybody my advice is get get
that weight off you and then but don't
go too crazy because I I'll kind of get
into because I didn't do anything as
Extreme as Richard Simmons did but I did
go slightly extreme at least to get the
weight off and it didn't luckily it
didn't really have any super longterm
effects but it did have some effects
going see here's the thing with a lot of
women try to starve fat off of them
which that works but they it also
consumes muscle yeah doing that a better
way to do it and then some of them will
say well I'll just run and do and do
aerobics aerobics isn't really that
effective in in changing body
composition it's slow you gotta it takes
a long time to get you have to do a lot
of it yeah and it's what you want is
something more concentrated it's called
weightlifting
weightlifting burns more fat builds more
muscle
and it's a lot faster because the work
is concentrated only in a few minutes
and then you sit around and heal up and
then you go do it again three days later
yeah and you change from one body part
to the next when you're going through
this and you can actually control how
something will be shaped now it won't
really work after 30 unless
you're on gear okay you'll get some
response but it'll start topping off
because your body's not making the
androgens it needs to actually respond
to the stimulus that you're doing some
guys have really [__] tried to do it
and tried to bend the rules of the
universe you will get some results
without
gear but there will be nothing compared
to the results you had if you were on it
so yeah and I mean the thing about it is
weightlifting I kind of hate it but it's
better than having to like run miles I
guess CU on a bicycle for hour I really
hate running I don't mind bicycling but
I really hate running the thing is
though you can be on that Bic SCH for an
hour it doesn't do that much yeah
doesn't do that much I mean that's kind
of the sh the body's response to I
didn't really respond like I I lost
weight which like maybe I'll get into
this too because it's kind of like
related to the topic but I lost a lot of
weight
by well I was doing aerobics and light
weightlifting um but I was also in a
severe calorie restriction not like
starving or anorexic or anything but
pretty severe um under a thousand
calories and it worked yeah um but I had
some side effects uh I my already low
blood pressure I've always had really
low blood pressure went like super low
so I was pretty much fainting like all
the time and I and I developed a uh
heart arhythmia so that wasn't good
that's some weight loss yeah which yeah
which kind of still bothers me every now
and then but not as much as it us to get
that if you lose a bunch of weight she
lost nearly 100 pounds cuz I lost almost
100 lb in four or five months yeah I saw
it happen this is before we were
together I saw sh had all of a sudden
she showed up she was a skinny chick and
I was like I couldn't believe it was her
well a lot of people that had no me
before like didn't recognize me yeah
they didn't know who she was and a few
months later we were going out yeah yeah
so if you did that to get me it
worked it worked even though resed it
was a factor it was a factor I resisted
it I know you resisted for a long time
resisted but I eventually knew I
eventually that I I was like I'm gonna
get this [__] get this
[__] I was in it for the long
haul yeah well and I won yeah she knew I
was hopefully you won too yeah we both
did no I wouldn't I wouldn't have done
it if I thought that you weren't
interested no you work I knew you were
look man look all the [__] [__] that
I see on this show and everything
[__] all the stories I've told and
everything I was with some fine [__]
women Jenny still Takes the Cake overall
Jenny was the overall winner she was the
best one go me yeah she was the best
one she was closest to the closest to
like a good friend and like you know
trustworthy and but no yeah yeah you're
you're the [__] it would have never went
down the way that it did if if that
wasn't the way it CU I am by far your
longest relationship by far Yeah by far
quite player I was just a player I was
used to I was I was in a Serial monogamy
I was trying to [__] them all one at a
time yeah he was doing like some Pokemon
[__] he's just like got to collect them
I don't want to that want you have a
reputation like even when I first met
you people
warned but no you weren't I would not
consider your tally your body count um
that I do not consider that unreasonable
at all there was some quantity but it
was really quality they were all good
yeah and like I said if you you kind of
gave me a ballpark figure and I'm just
like that's not I mean you know for for
your age yeah like for as long as you've
been dating that's not
unreasonable at all it's not like super
I got married once the first time you
know I was late 20s and that just that
just tends to happen you know as long as
you but then after that really there
wasn't much even even kind of before
that I was the kind of guy where I would
really wouldn't have gained a whole lot
from getting married but I still got
married to you it took 13 years but I
still got married yeah it took a while
yeah we got married recently but we were
together 13 years before I got married
we were married kind of during that
anyway yeah well like I said we got
together I think in well I knew you I
think I Met You in 2009 or 2010 we
didn't actually get together as a couple
till probably I think it was like mid
2011 or something and it was so weird
like how organic because we had just
been hanging out yeah he was dating
other people I was dating other people
but we kept hanging out we'd stay over
each other's houses we come business
ideas we come up with all this [__] and
we just like kept hanging out all the
time yeah and then finally um I think we
were at isn't this funny we I think we
were at venue 13 one night when it was
still at the place that was the Chinese
restaurant later yeah and you introduced
me to somebody yeah as your girlfriend
yeah and after they left I looked at you
and said
oh is is this a thing now or I was like
yeah you're my girlfriend okay and I was
like oh all right that was like how we
there was no big talk or anything yeah I
think like I was just like oh oh all
right well [__] we had been together for
we've been hanging out for like 2 or 3
months yeah it had been a while it had
been a while more than maybe two and we
six months we moved in together in
2012 I think it was I remember we were I
and then just like funny how you
remember that like almost two months ago
we got married finally it it's funny how
you remember that I remember that thing
of v13 what what I remember was like
later I think that's must have been
later we were at uh we were at uh uh
downtown over there at Orange a what's
the name of the place [__] indepent
which is or bar we were at I bar and
[__] we were standing up there and we
were getting drinks and [__] and I think
we made out real quick and then [__]
uh lee was like you guys together and
they're like yeah they were like well
finally yeah that that I think that was
like right around the same time yeah the
same time and I was like yeah well
because you kept well we kept hanging
out and everybody's like are you guys a
thing or are you guys a couple or what
and Tom came no no we're just no we're
friends we're friends were friends but
then finally he was just kind of I was
like what about time we were already
[__] though yeah off and on off and
on yeah yeah cuz I feel like we started
[__] like
in prior to 2011 no we but just like a
couple of times a couple times real
early yeah like it just kind of happened
like when like you know we went home
together one time still married yeah but
we were you were separated we were
separated yeah we had a we had like a
one night thing there yeah and then like
maybe and then like a couple weeks later
maybe one or two yeah yeah yeah and then
Tom kept being like man we we shouldn't
really do this it's like and then all
sudden you got skinny as [__] yeah cuz
now I hooked up with her when she was
still heavy yeah well you still pretty
you were still kind of heavy slightly
but yeah I was in the middle you were
like maybe halfway through right yeah
but um Mr 88 said good choice Tom well
gee thank you very much um I'm teaching
my sons that a deep friendship is the
number one thing to look for in a girl
is the best foundation for a lifelong
relationship yeah
a romantic attraction that's good but
that that that yeah and I think that's a
good component to have it's good but
that's not you can't be built on that no
that can't be the only thing it's too
volatile and that doesn't mean enough
just because you want to [__] the [__]
out of it that doesn't really mean much
there's a lot more than that you got to
like that person and you guys got to
have you got to [__] having common
goals has a lot to do with it yeah
that's the same thing that's a big one
because you going to have to be with
this person every day and like work out
problems with this person and like you
know weather life's shittiness with this
person so it's just kind of like you
better like this person and trust this
person me and Jan's common goal was to
take over the local go and we did it
kind of yeah well we did well we took
over all the all the promotions the
promotion stuff and [__] we got real
well known and it was just a and it was
more of a social thing we loved our
local goth scene and wanted to be
players in who where the clubs will be
what will be played What DJ is going to
be big uh how things will be
promoted um I was kind of we were kind
of on the side involved with the
creation of mannequins we got invited to
manage that I had to step down I'm not a
[__] manager for that but uh you'd be
there all the time yeah I'd be the way
that it went now I don't know if you'd
want to manage it at this stage yeah but
we had some well we have some uh bad
done well who I don't remember like I
don't know how long you've been
listening to the show but I don't um I
haven't seen your comments in the chat
before so welcome um was asking us are
those alcoholic drinks absolutely
absolutely absolutely um this is
actually this is my first one of the
night this is just vodka and lemonade
yeah uh I don't know what you've got
Vodka lemonade with a little bit of the
juice I probably need another one now
that I'm thinking about it and then uh
bad dwell said I like people who drink a
lot well we definitely do we drink some
not a lot yeah it's well is it a lot not
by Irish standards no not by British
standards Maybe by American Standards we
probably do drink a lot we we probably
drink yeah two or three nights a week I
imagine we usually drink on this live
stream yeah and sometimes Saturday
nights too and sometimes we go out
Friday night or Saturday night okay so
this got nothing to do with [__] Rich
Simmons we gotta get I know but we well
we were talking about weight loss so
that's kind of related uh Jen lost a lot
of weight uh through through starvation
and the results were good but it was
very fast and she was already in her 30s
at that time yeah it was late 30s and
she actually looked like she got a
little too SK too thin I did because
there were certain areas so I could ride
around the belly and stuff like that
where the skin was loose yeah um wasn't
terrible but you know it didn't look
like a girl like a girl in her 30s or or
that was always
trim so she gained a little more back
and looked a lot better actually when
she gained a little bit more said at my
lightest I got down to 1118 and I
thought I was starting to look she looks
best at 130 right like right around I my
ideal weight is usually like
135 um is usually where I now that was
her old body composition but now that
I've started like lifting weights she
gain weight so now I have like more
muscle so I'm heavier than that but yeah
she's going to gain weight but she's
going to it all going to be shape yeah
and she's losing a lot of fat and she's
putting on muscle she's lifting weights
at at her age it's not natural okay
she's got assistance she's it's
nandrolone yeah and nandrolone is great
for women cuz most people probably know
but if there's new people here I am 51
years old that's right nelon is great
post menopausal yeah Melone is great for
menopausal women as hormone
replacement one of the byproducts of it
is increased collagen synthesis so what
that does is the skin tone gets a lot
better because you don't have the
collagen for skin to snap back so you
can lose weight reshape shape and you
you don't have to worry about loose skin
the game is totally different when
you're on gear it does make a huge
difference huge difference you work out
it you get results right away body it
changed my whole like my legs look
completely different yeah just in in a
month like my calves and my thighs and
everything like that look completely
different and I I lift weights but not a
lot you know what I mean two three time
two to three times a week yeah something
like that and it's not like super super
heavy or anything like that just a bunch
of different ones and it's about an hour
it takes her and um we haven't released
any new videos you know if we do an
adult video and which is another thing
that we do um and and uh we haven't
really we haven't shot anything we
should probably do we're going to soon
she looks totally different she looks
she was cute before you know uh but she
looks totally she looks very athletic
now so I can't she'll walk into the room
and I'm like God damn Jen look every
single time I walk into the room like
with my jammies or something if I have
like some kind of like like just like
underwear jammies or something he'll be
like God damn look look like a Marvel
Superhero yeah and I absolutely did not
look like that no I think I looked okay
in those videos but not like I look a
lot better now I feeling you had you
kind of had the um what do they call it
um
um he had the like the Woody look kind
of the uh
um what's what's the U kind of like a
mil look right she kind of had right
um perfect ass fat ass white girl but
she didn't have fat ass she just had a
meaty look to her now yeah now she's
looking very kind of like uh athletic
cougar she's becoming a cougar
yeah
oh so bad dwell did not know that he
said wait what
5151 yes I was born in
1972 yeah 1972 and I'm 54 and Tom is 54
yeah I just turned 51 at the end of
September yeah but hormone replacement
is
effective got to research I will note
too though in all fairness that I do
have young looking jeans yeah her mom
looks young yeah and my mom is in her
70s yeah her mom looks like like Pia
Zadora yeah if you know who Pia Zadora
was all the younger people like who the
[__] is that p i a that that's what
happens when when you get old Zadora you
say you make references and the
youngsters have no idea she was kind of
a one hit wonder model but she was uh
had big she was cute had big cheeks she
kind of looked like yeah my mom kind of
looks like that a lot of people told her
that yeah like padora like when she was
growing up like I said my mom's in her
7s now she had me when she was uh 18 so
um yeah and she doesn't look like an old
lady she looks like she's in her
absolutely does not she looks like a
cute woman in her 50s she was still
getting hit on by like yeah uh College
age dudes like when she was in her
50s so and I do as well sometimes yeah
like if we go to mannequins like if we
go somewhere where it's kind of
dark like I'll get college HD I'm like I
could be your mom bro they know you're
older they just don't know how old you
how old that's true no year
older that doesn't stop him it no it it
doesn't seem to does
it no I've seen who who hits on her it
would be guys that would think she would
be
attainable um you know what I mean they
don't and the thing is is they would
know I think they know that she's with
somebody but they still try which you
know okay I I salute them and if you're
cool with it if you're cool I tolerate
it if you're [__] I come out [__]
swinging like now if you're an [__] I
want the first swing cuz I will
absolutely B old [__] grabbed
her on the ass and I was on that
[__] just had him by the [__]
throat was [__] sanging and [__] yeah
I didn't even have a chance I didn't
have a chance to react to that cuz he
like came up on me from behind I was
just like out on the dance floor dancing
and just like some Rando like just
[__] grabbed and I was like what the
[__] and like stink on
[__] him by theoat I just saw him run
over there he ran from I was like well I
guess he's taking care of it yeah had
him by the throat like that my [__]
fingers were touching and crushing his
[__] right through this [__] wind
pipe did you touch my wife like
that he ran
off don't just touch random people just
that's Pro tip you know I mean most
people know that but and I was on Trend
man he's lucky I didn't try to rape
him well yeah that's the thing violence
sex merged into one thing if I hate you
then you're going to get to
dick it's like literally was like the
Goblin from [__] Spider-Man Jen saw
it yeah it it was a ride I'm going to
say that don't do Trend it was a ride
Yeah Yeah from from one Jim bro here
yeah don't don't [__] with it please
don't do Tren if you want Trend like
effects just stack replace you might end
up like killing people or getting
arrested or something if you're going to
put yeah yeah had I stayed on it's not a
great I was on it for five months yeah
by month five I was criminal
basically um
the the which is two months longer than
you're supposed to be on it but by month
end of month three I'm like no [__] we
come off train what are you talking
about this shit's great oh my God it's
so awesome fck we talking about
meanwhile everyone around you is like
you were acting like a crazy person not
[__] great you're crazy awes I'm just
like yeah no yeah but um if you gim Bros
are listening uh and I got now I got
some out there in the stack if you want
Trend now just replace it with NPP or
nandrolone phenol propri I mean there's
other stuff like that real close that
will have the same effects but without
all the bad all the bad side effect side
effects people are mistaken those people
are mistaken those bad side effects for
Effectiveness wow this shit's strong no
it's not strong it just has really bad
side effects it's just that one like
you've taken pretty much everything yeah
there is to take um and that was the
only one where I noticed like a drastic
yeah uh change
were like I said was afraid were
going I was like I never had violence
towards women it was
always I didn't really know that though
you're trying to be real protective of
women and you're real [__] aggressive
towards men um it was just you add
something right out of the animal
kingdom it was bizarre I basically was
was a werewolf and it was just like
started wear and werewolf stuff after
that cuz yeah it was a werewolf it was
like a thing that he went through well
yeah and it's just kind of like
um I mean it it was just like minor [__]
like somebody was like blocked our
driveway for 5 seconds and he's just
like I'm going
TR like he's trying to kill I'm just
like can we not yeah he's going to move
in a second it's really fine you know
what I mean it's like please don't get
arrested this all Fitness we're talking
about Fitness level stuff uh but yeah um
just replace Tren with NPP in the stack
you want to run it with test uh NP
nalone fenel propriate at at a molecular
level it's almost identical to Tren but
it doesn't have those bad side effects
it's approved for human use Tren is not
approved for human use that's
veterinarian yeah it when they first
released it they said yeah this is for
humans but then they saw those side
effects and they pulled it not so much
and then now they only give it to cattle
basically they give it to cattle before
Slaughter so they don't lose weight on
the train ride because it gives you kind
of like murder rage yeah sort of I don't
know what it does to them cows they're
probably like that [__] cheating on me
cuz that's a big thing that bit Yeah
Yeah like I saidis like you guys that
are regulars here I knew she wasn't
cheating on me but I felt like she was
he kept like getting really like you
still love me you get real simply simpy
as [__] you're not cheating on me I'm
like checking right I'm like when the
[__] would I cheat on you I work at home
yeah I was with her all time I never
leave and I'm with her all the time it's
just you think the invisible man is
coming in here just like I don't go
anywhere it's just crazy [__] I don't go
anywhere it's
just I'm just I'm here in my I'm like
I'm right down the hall but it only does
that like month four yeah month four it
starts doing it just F so all the
stories you hear about it on the
internet yes they're true don't [__]
with it they're absolutely true do not
[__] with it any we went through it we
went through it we came out stronger
though I feel yeah they got some dudes
that thrive on that some I know a guy
but the thing is is that that same dude
that thrives on it does gay porn he's a
straight dude that he he claims to be
straight does gay BDSM porn on twinks
and [__] and he gets jacked up on Trend
to do it first and and well at least he
has like an outlet yeah that he like you
know a
non-destructive and he's making money
out of it makes you very aggressive
towards
men especially weaker men real
aggressive yeah like I said so he does
Trend to do that you can't you just like
somebody on Trend like if when Tom was
on Trend if somebody just like looked at
him the wrong way like he for real like
glanced at somebody in another car that
was laughing at something that had
nothing to do with him and he was going
to like tear the dude's head off are you
laughing at me and he's just like yeah I
was just laughing at something that was
on like the [__] podcast on my radio
or something it's like [__] calm down
you know what I mean it was that kind of
[__] um bad done well said I have
jealousy problems yeah I mean you know I
kind of feel like that's kind of natural
it said uh use make me laugh a hearty
healing laugh oh who bad
well okay so Simmons back to
Simmons U even though Simmons was not he
was not a hyper performance trainer not
by any means no he was a uh he was I I I
gave him seal of approval uh even back
then and I give him to seal approval now
every knowing what I know because he was
helping women with the m he was helping
obese women with the mind the mind is
really the first step and he was trying
to get them to confront trauma confront
the reasons why they're trying to drown
their sorrows in
food you get rid of that way will come
off you yeah he was like a the like not
a licensed therapist but he was and one
woman um I was watching like a
documentary about him and there was one
woman on there that was a big fan of his
and worked with his for a long time and
she lost more than 100 PBS like um while
she was uh you know going to his classes
and everything like that and she said he
would call me every single week and see
how I was doing and like ask about my
kids and my husband and all this other
kind of stuff like he remember
like the details about everybody's
family that he would call so um she was
like I think the main thing that um that
made him appeal to people was that she's
like particularly women I guess was that
he made you feel accepted he made you
feel loved and just like he made you
feel seen like you talked to him and he
actually looked in your face and he
listened to you and he remember
remembered [__] that you told him like
and he would call you every week and be
like hey how you doing and it's like and
he would like give you a pep talk about
it and he remembered all the [__] about
you so it's like that's something that a
lot of these women sadly I feel like
didn't have in their lives they didn't
feel like anyone accepted them they felt
like you know they felt ugly or like I
said or unloved or unaccepted like
people didn't like them or whatever so
the fact that somebody was just so um
compassionate toward them and was just
not judging them in any way and was
actually listening to them and listening
to their problems and could relate to
their problems I think that was a big
part of his appeal because a lot of
these women like I said were you know
depressed um and they didn't have anyone
to talk to they didn't have anyone who
loved them they didn't have anyone who
listened to them and he did like he was
there for them and he was always there
for them so I feel like that was where
cuz honestly I could not find like all
the [__] that I watched about him and
all the [__] that I read about him I
could not find a single [__] on
this green earth that had anything bad
to say about him nobody nobody yeah um
it's he's kind of like Mr Rogers in that
regard or Bob Ross in that regard like
he just seems like one of those
universally loved people which is really
unusual I mean you know everybody's
going to have some [__]
somewhere that hates them even if it's
for a [__] reason but I really there
really didn't seem to be anybody that
disliked him at all they they just said
that he was just the the he had like the
biggest heart he was just like the most
empathetic like he was always like on
and he was always so joyful and
everything like that and like everyone
was really into that and you know it so
I think that's why when he you know
disappeared or he just like you know
kind of vanished from the public eye I
think that's why a lot of people were
really alarmed because he had been so
visible in people's lives um he was
always there he was always very public
and the fact that he just disapp because
he didn't just disappear from public
like oh like oh I'm not doing public
appearances or anything like that
anymore he disappeared completely he
didn't email people anymore he didn't
call anyone anymore he didn't talk to
his friends or his family really that
much anymore so it kind of seemed like
he just vanished off the face of the
Earth and everyone was understandably
concerned because he had been so
involved in people's lives for such a
long time you know what I mean there's
people up in there asking me questions
at asking you questions what do we see
um I forgot
now one of them
was okay Danny is talking about KY
muscle said Tren will give you a heart
attack um kie musle wouldn't listen to
that dude he had heart problems but that
didn't have anything to do with with
Tren chemically Tren is just a 19 Nor
testosterone they're all real similar
the only difference is is where the
carbon molecules where the carbon atoms
are on the
molecule
uh he was he had heart problems because
I think he he was he was taking a lot of
stuff and it was a lot of different
stuff and he was an older guy and he put
on a lot of weight very
quickly a lot of upper body weight he
had huge arms Khali was an Entertainer
though I liked Khali he was funny guy
and I think he's a nice guy uh he's this
little short black dude with huge
arms uh I think a lot of it had to do
with his age his cholesterol level he
would do whole [__] mukbang videos
where he's eating huge bowls of [__]
pasta and [__] because to gain the kind
of weight he wanted to gain you have to
eat a lot that's one of my problems I'm
not a huge
eater some of these dudes when they're
going on cycle [__] they're eating a
lot I mean an unhealthy amount because
you that mass has to come from somewhere
you know one of the most anabolic agents
you could ever [__] come in contact
with is
food so I think khi got got his heart
attack really from food so he came off
that's probably more food than anyone
person should be eating uh he was from
the hood and I don't think he ate real
well in his early early days before he's
making up for it well now I can afford
good food so lot of it which I get that
he might have had stuff built up in his
arteries you you really don't know
what's happening to a dude until you see
the autopsy reports and a lot of times
you see the autops if they die you see
the autopsy you go oh [__] and a lot of
it has nothing to do with like oh it was
he had a a heart defect he didn't know
about it you know uh and was pushing
himself too hard with all that muscle or
oh he died of dehydration because he
took a handful of [__] diuretics so
he could look shredded as [__] at the
club and started drinking a bunch of
alcohol when he started passing out they
started treating him for a heart attack
the ambulance treated him for a heart
attack and killed him that's there's a
lot of [__] that could happen I mean
that happens more often than you may
think yeah the general the general rules
that I go by I'm a smaller frame guy I'm
only
56 I don't want to be any more than 200
pounds and I do not want to be less than
10% body fat maybe 10 is good enough
when you start getting into that 5% body
fat [__] there's nowhere in your body to
store any fluid you dehydrate real fast
and that's dangerous you know you look
great but there's a weakness to that
being that lean you know um big time
yeah and you got to take a lot of stuff
to maintain 5% body fat at my age it's
just not worth it and I'm not a model
you know I'm not stepping on the [__]
stage and Olympia and [__] you know so
I'd be happy with 10% I'm we're we're
just occasionally having sex on live
stream yeah yeah and I'm at about 15%
now so 10 would be fine I'd have a real
good six-pack at 10 okay uh there was
somebody else said add some stuff in
there uh Cas Lee asked was Tom in the
military yes he was in the Army yeah it
was in the 101st Airborne Division it
was in the first 327 Recon I was in the
first in the 506 Airborne up on K up on
the DMZ in Korea when the 506 was a part
of the second ID it's now back in 101st
and then uh I did some private security
I worked for some private security
companies after that that uh and more in
a training where I was training foreign
troops and
cops that's all I can say about
that top secret yeah not really top
secret just no I know I'm just teasing
sensitive yeah Danny ring said wasn't
there a rumor that his housekeeper was
holding him hostage at his house doing
some kind of voodoo on him I don't know
if it was necessarily Voodoo but there
was like a rumor that um his housekeeper
was holding him there with like black
magic of some kind yeah that was that
was a that was one of the ones the
things I wanted to talk about Allison
said didn't Richard Simmons C cry on the
show I kind of remember that happening C
all time yeah he cried all well like I
said and they and people that went to
his class cuz like I said he taught that
[__] class at
slimmons um which was his gym for like
years and I think it was either once a
week or three times a week I can't
remember like I saw like different um
sites said different things so he would
be there and he would actually teach the
classes and everybody said the classes
there cuz there were all these regulars
that went there and they interviewed a
bunch of them like on documentaries and
stuff that would go and they said you
never knew what to expect like Richard
Simmons would always show up in some
crazy [__] outfit like cuz he always
had like a different you know nutty
outfit like for whatever and he's just
like and he'd always do like super crazy
[__] like um yeah he'd like always make
the dudes take their shirts off and like
it's just all kind of stuff that he
would do and it's like and then you
would do like your fun little you know
aerobics or whatever and then like like
at the end that almost they said it's
almost be like a therapy session where
he would kind of like talk about his
problems and stuff and then he would
kind of cry and then everybody would
talk about their problems and they would
kind of cry and stuff like that and like
I said people really liked that it was
almost kind of like therapy but for like
$12 a class you know what I mean plus
you were getting aerobics too so it was
kind of like win-win so I could see how
people would go there every week cuz you
know if that's your thing then he had
like a lot of people go and it was it
went for more than 40 years I think he
opened it in I want to say 19 74 and it
didn't close until 2016 and that was
like two years after he disappeared so
Larry Brown said love you guys we love
you too
um Ty said y'all should make a 13 o00
shirt that says the podcast that will
get you rocked
up we probably should and then I should
put I'm trying to think of like some the
best way to put something that looks
like an erection but not like an
erection you know what I
mean I try to like I'm trying to answer
everybody's questions but I get like
real behind because like because Tom
will talk for a while and I'm just like
oh my God that question and that
question and then it kind of like
Scrolls down but I'm trying to like keep
track of everything you know what I mean
but um but yeah so it's just kind of
like I don't know I didn't know like I
said I knew about Richard Simmons just
because he was around at the time he was
always on TV he was on like every
[__] talk show like his whole videos
and everything somebody asked like a
long time ago how he made his money
and I will say that his first video the
first sweat into the oldies video and I
think he made a [__] ton of those but
the first one that he made made gross
$200 million and that's not just like
but that's how much he grossed from that
$200 million and that was just one video
it was a massive massive success might
still be the bestselling Fitness video
not real
sure but um but yeah so he made $200
million just off of that one video and
he made a [__] ton of videos and he also
did cookbooks um he had a talk show he
was on other TV shows and he also made
millions and millions of dollars from
this kind of um and he sold these on
infomercials I kind of remember these
infomercials but he um it was kind of a
thing where it was like this card or
like a set it was a card or a set of
cards I can't remember that you put in
your wallet and it was kind of like it
was for portion control like food
portion control so it's like it it was
like okay well here's this card for you
know this food or this amount of you
know calories or whatever and you would
move it to the other side of your wallet
like when you ate that so you'd know
like when all the cards are on this side
of your wallet then you're done eating
for the day you know what I mean so it's
kind of like and I feel like Weight
Watchers kind of does that similar thing
like that now with their point system um
where it's like you know you can pretty
much eat what you want but when your
points are used up for the day then
that's the you can't eat anymore which
is probably a good way because then you
can kind of eat what you want just
you're like well I'm going to have this
massive piece of cake but that's all you
can eat that day you know what I mean so
you're not denying yourself anything
you're just kind of like making
compromises I really really want this
big [__] piece of cheesecake but I
know that it's the only thing I can eat
today I can't eat again till tomorrow
well Beast people have you have all have
something in common it's impulse
control and you have to ask yourself why
are they having the impulse control
there's usually some kind of underlying
Psych olcal or emotional problem they
like something so they do it again yeah
they like this they do it again and
again and again they think of something
they want that so they take it they
can't keep their mind away from what
they like it's why my advice was is pick
up some kind of a hobby there's a total
discipline T discipline that just takes
over everything it'll take your mind off
of it take your mind off everything
right I mean you got to yeah when I'm
into motorcycles or [__] I'll forget to
eat I got well I do that too if I get
like really into what I'm doing like
like oh I'm writing a story or whatever
it is that I'm doing if I get super into
it yeah I'll forget to eat too yeah but
we kind of forgot to eat partially today
we didn't eat much today because we're
[__] with the damn motorcycle I only
reminded you today cuz I'm like I'm kind
of starving look like when we just
stopped at Wendy's when the yeah when
the show's over I'm get us some more to
eat okay but yeah that's literally all
I've eaten today was I had a chicken
sandwich at wenty and a couple of french
fries but um yeah that was like that was
a a really long time ago yeah I had that
Wendy's double burger that's it that's
all I had yeah I just cuz I don't
usually eat breakfast I just a cup of
coffee yeah um and that's pretty much it
and like I said I don't think like I had
a cup of coffee at like 8:00 this
morning and then we didn't eat at
Wendy's until 2 or 3:00 something like
that so so we haven't eaten since then
but yeah you know you you just kind of
forget to eat after a while which
normally I wouldn't have because like I
said I love to eat and I was very heavy
I wasn't a heavy kid I was a real skinny
kid um but as soon as I went through
puberty I started gaining weight like
very very quickly um so by the time I
was in my 20s I was I think in my early
20s I was probably over 200 lb yeah I
never saw you that heavy no you didn't
yeah um cuz I gained CU I lost a bunch
of weight in my 20s um but then kind of
slowly it kind of crept back on but um
yeah y'all wouldn't know that Jenny was
a fat girl one time yeah I was I was way
overweight yeah like I don't know if I'd
call myself OB
beast but I was pretty hefty pretty
hefty and that started right after I
went through puberty so like right after
like 12 or 13 years old I started
getting like gaining weight like when
rapid when I first saw Jen she was
married she was cute cute and chubby
yeah cute and chubby
um I flirted with you a little bit you
did yeah yeah but she wasn't somebody
that I had take home at that time but
then I got got to know her over time and
she got divorced and she lost weight she
she looked real good then all of a
sudden she got skinny that was about
it I don't know just the way it was you
know even though you don't like well you
made more I don't really like skinny
girls but but you you um you just made a
bigger impression you know I don't know
I guess yeah well people started to like
notice me more CU I kind of feel like
prior to that I'd always been kind of a
Wallflower because when you grow up and
this is kind of tied into the Richard
Simmons story too cuz I can kind of
relate I didn't have anything as Extreme
as what he had going on when he was a
kid but when you're younger and you're
heavy or you have something else that
make people bully you or pick on you
that um sadly kind of sticks with you
forever and it's like really really hard
to get over it in my case um I didn't
start gaining weight until I was a
little bit older and I did get made fun
of because of that but when I was a
little kid I used to get bullied for
being
uh shy quiet bookish and also poor um so
so I got bullied quite a lot too and
like I said that kind of sticks with you
for the rest of your life which is kind
of shitty like you try to get over it
but yeah it's funny because like uh I
never see the way Jetty kind of hug up
by early stuff from early I never saw
her that way so she never well you
didn't meet me no until know until later
never had that per
you it's it's alien for me to hear that
I'm like that's weird you know what I
mean fing cuz it was almost like that
happened to somebody else from my point
of view you know right because that's
not that's not the you that's not the
Gen I know that's that was for something
from a long well and it's kind of shitty
too because I always kind of feel even
when I was a little kid I was like you
know I'm kind of a cool person it's like
and I couldn't understand like why other
people couldn't see that like they
couldn't see past yeah I got secondhand
clothes on that I had to get like hand
me down from my cousin or from the
thrift store yeah I'm really quiet oh
man middle school and high school kids
are cruel they are they're terrible yeah
they're psychos so so that doesn't
really matter I know but it's just like
but it does kind of stick with you like
as much as you don't want it to because
it doesn't matter anymore like where the
[__] are those people now but it still
kind of like [__] with you though cuz
it kind of because th those are years
where you're really um you know where
your brain is still forming so you still
have a thing got wired in there right so
like so now still even though I know I
don't look like that anymore I know I
don't you know and I kind of feel like
I'm a cool person but it's just kind of
like it still [__] with you you're just
like well I'm not good enough or they
they don't want to talk to me or you
it's something and it's just like and I
know that that's stupid but I can't it's
really hard to like get over that you
know what I'm saying so I understand you
know somebody like Richard Simmons who
started getting heavy when he was young
when he was like four or five years old
and just got made fun of like
mercilessly because he was you know you
know pretty a fat kid yeah um and he was
just constantly bullied that sticks with
you forever like you can't really
because that's your formative years yeah
that's when your thoughts are formed
that's when your personality is formed
you got to be able to change it and it's
really really hard I mean you can um but
a lot of times you probably need like
you know therapy or something like that
because it's really same J same it's
really really hard to get over that like
I kind of feel like I maybe have but
it's still it still [__] with you it's
still in the back of your mind like all
the time that's weird I know I well you
didn't have that no so it's like so it's
hard for you to you know I really
cared I kind of well I felt like thing
is is that people didn't mistreat me so
that's what I mean so it's like so you
didn't have that experience so you don't
understand like how how bad it [__]
with you like still even though you
don't want it to like this many years
later but it's still kind of does [__]
with you and Tammy said yeah she knows
what I'm talking about and she's you
know she's uh you know a little bit
older than I am too so it's like you
know I'm not saying that I give a [__]
about those people and it's like their
opinions don't matter and stuff but
because it's so
ingrained in you it's like really hard
to like get past you
know Tammy said my own grandmother
called me antisocial because I was so
shy as a kid yeah it's just like people
have a real problem and I don't I guess
it's better now than it used to be but
people used to have a real problem with
people that were shy like they didn't
want to talk a lot or just wanted to
read or something like that they thought
there was something the matter with you
yeah like people so I always kind of
like my whole entire childhood I kind of
felt like something was the matter with
me because somebody people always acted
like something was the matter with me
because I didn't want to be like super
social or I just wanted to like sit and
read or something like that I was like
what's wrong with that I'm having a good
time like I don't understand why
everybody wanted to [__] with me like
that so so now I constantly just feel
like well there's something that matter
with me like I'm doing something wrong I
still have that and that's it's [__]
up you know what I mean [__]
up uh Larry said yeah I was bullied in
my teen years [__] sucks it really does
it really does and like I said not you
know not having a lot of money to and I
went to a high school and a Junior High
in a high school where the kids were
kind of like more upper middle class and
um so they absolutely knew like all the
brands that were popular and all that
kind of stuff so if you were not wearing
that [__] oh they would absolutely like
tear the [__] out of you it's funny they
knew they knew you got your shoes at
Kmart yeah you know what I mean and they
would not let you forget that [__] you
know what I mean so funny yeah not great
so it's yeah it's not fun okay see you
around Cas leave see you later all right
yeah you can always watch it like
recorded but yeah so here was another
thing I didn't know and this is kind of
related because you uh you talk about
being chubby yeah um I was never really
chubby uh but Jim was chubby when Jen
was chubby when I saw her she wasn't fat
she was chubby but she she was cute
there are a lot of girls out there that
are chubby that carry weight that I
still follow them on Instagram Instagram
models some of them I would say were fat
that I like them has to do with some
women can carry weight better than
others and it's it's
genetics if the weight all goes to the
tits in the ass it looks good all right
but that's not what happens to a lot of
girls what happens unforunately what
happens to a lot of girls is it goes
right to the midu yeah so it doesn't
look as good just genetics has a lot to
do with it yeah that's another thing but
no they're a lot they're they're a whole
porn star chicks their whole thing is
just uh to have that short hourglass
shape big butt the brothers know all
about it man they've got that [__] down
there with science they they taught it
to to
me I'm I'm the one that picked it up I
was like okay yeah I will say when I was
in high school the only dudes that were
into me were black guys probably black
guys yeah or yeah you closer to what
they liked or Latin guy the thing is
that you know I I kind of like this I
like the same I like the same white
girls that black guys like too he does
yeah Tom likes thick yeah I like thick
thick or muscular yeah or a mixture of
the two I like to have some mask there I
mean honestly like I said you have a
pretty broad range like just considering
like all the porn you look at and all
the Instagram cuz I know all about that
stuff yeah so cuz he's he's like hey at
yeah look at this [__] but um but yeah
the only thing that he doesn't like is
real skinny girls or girls that are flat
that don't have any boobs or don't have
any like a big ass he likes a big ass
and big thighs and stuff even though
I've dated even though I dated flat my
uh
yeah they were still cool yeah and I
just didn't prefer it right
whereas like I said I I don't really
have a type as far as I'm just like well
but I don't have a type because I don't
know you so so I don't know how that's
no dudes have types I know they do but
and some women have types too I I just
personally I don't I got about four or
five of them if somebody asked me yeah I
would have no idea what to say yeah I
would have no idea what to say like I
guess I have things that I like I don't
know like if somebody asked me like
physically what I like it probably was
mostly girls yeah um
but I don't know I guess there's some
[__] but it's not really I don't know
it's it's not a make or break like I
said if I don't know you then you can't
be attractive if I don't really know you
you know what I'm saying women have
different criteria they're not as visual
they're not as they're not as you know
like you can appreciate things
aesthetically but I'm like I don't know
that [__] it's like he might be
a total douche most women reject
everything that anything that's average
pretty much the average guy they're not
interested in that's why I was
encouraging you Brothers you got to
can't be average if you're in the
breeding age where you're worried about
getting married and having girlfriends
and [__] like that you have to be above
average and you have to be striking in
some way and there's a bunch of
different ways to do it but you can't be
just some average Schmo I mean yeah you
have to kind of like stand out some like
not in a bad way like don't stand out by
I'm going to be like the world's biggest
[__] or whatever yeah I'm going to
wear this crazy tie everybody will go
why you have that no you're just going
to look like a yeah don't do don't do
that kind of crap that's stupid but it's
just like I mean have a personality or
have some actual genuine interesting
interests or something know how to dress
know how to [__] keep yourself fit
how to dress yeah be funny yeah I don't
know something a crew status yeah
something like I said it doesn't have to
be money it doesn't have to be any of
that stuff helps though that help I mean
money well money helps with everybody
yeah um you know everybody needs money
you got to have money to date I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying that as
a person even if you have money if
you're a boring ass [__] are
just going to put up with your ass just
for money no one's going to actually if
you're a real player like I was you
didn't go on dates I didn't date that's
for Chumps I hung out with cool chicks
that's what I did then we went out and
did [__] together that's how I met her
well date that's like a job interview
man [__]
that and I think that that's kind of a
better way to go about it yeah like I
said I've always been a big advocate of
just whether it's online or in the real
world it doesn't
like just associate with people that
like the same [__] as you yeah and
eventually you'll find somebody that's
because you know you need to have
somebody that's like has some [__] in
common dudes that ski dudes that climb
mountains they you know they all get
laid Surfer Dudes get laid come on just
get something where their women are
there just go yeah that's what I mean
just find like an interest like I said
whatever it is whether it's like a
particular video game or whether it's
whatever it or horror movies like I'm
into but it's just kind of like some
country [__] you know where the
dam Harley-Davidson you get late just go
to the [__] biker rallies yeah you
know hang out in places where other
people that are into the same [__] as
you hang out it's going to be a certain
kind of woman but eventually you'll find
somebody that is in the same kind of
[__] as you and and like I said that
will work out better than just oh here's
this hot random person that isn't into
the same [__] as me but they're hot you
know what I mean which is I guess that's
more of a dude thing I wouldn't really I
wouldn't just bang somebody that was
that was hot and wasn't into the same
[__] as me
I can't hang out with people that are
like not into the same [__] as me I have
a hard time some some women can some
yeah some yeah and I'm not saying I'm
not generalizing I'm just saying me
personally um if I don't and I and I'm
not saying that I haven't just like
randomly like you know gone home with a
dude that I met at a bar because I have
but the person was into the same [__]
like we had like a discussion like at
the club like before Oh you like that
you like that like if we hadn't done
that I wouldn't be able to like have sex
I've had them that had nothing to do
with me at all just they just go Starry
Eyed on you just on your looks well like
I said i' be goth out like a
[__] and she's a jock yeah and
she's just [__] all about it but see
I think I think in general not everybody
in general I think dudes have an easier
time doing that chicks have to be more
like
into your personality yeah not just how
you look yeah like it it helps but um
but you have to be kind of a cool person
too yeah we're talking about dating we
got to get back to [__] we got you
know what I mean you know we always
[__] do this before we go go back to
the show uh if you're listening to the
show recorded please uh send us a a
super thanks every now and then we get
one and of course super chats are open
and uh [__] if y'all are enjoying the
show you can uh uh show your
appreciation by sending Jenna Super Chat
for all her hard work that's what I'm
guilting you out I'm guilting y'all out
I'm passing the [__] collection plate
around [__] Church oh okay let's go
back in there I'm gonna go back and
get so one thing that I learned that I
thought was kind of Ang like I said I
knew who Richard Simmons was it was
impossible not to if you GRE up in the
80s and 90s because he was [__]
everywhere but I didn't realize one that
he's from New Orleans which I thought
was kind of cool that's where he was
born his real name is actually not
Richard Simmons it's Milton Teague
Simmons um but he took the name Richard
I think when he was a kid like his
nickname was Dicky so it kind of has
something to do with that but he also
had like kind of a rich uncle that
helped him out uh whose name was Richard
so he kind of named himself like in
honor of that guy now his parents inter
well I don't know I I guess this kind of
tracks but his parents were a little bit
Showbiz um his dad was like an MC type
of type of person and his mom was
actually a fan dancer in the sense that
I guess she was one of those people that
would kind of do the burlesque dances
like with the feathers and everything
like yeah like I think she went and did
like other stuff later on but um but
that was kind of how she came up now the
weird thing about this is that both of
his parents and I've seen photos of his
parents with him and his brother because
he has an older brother named
Lenny um his parents are real thin and
he said they were thin pretty much their
whole lives and they lived until quite
old age I think they both died when they
were about 87 years
old um
but he grew up in the South I also grew
up in the South and one thing about
growing up in the
south is
that a lot of
Southerners show affection through food
especially from that
generation so I mean I kind of had the
same problem which probably contributed
to my uh weight gain as well when I was
younger my grandmother um who I spent a
lot of time at her house uh she was
always she was thin my whole life but
she was very much you know why aren't
you eating what's the matter with you
are you sick you know what I mean so
it's a very very southern thing now
Richard Simmons parents like I said who
were both thin they had reportedly three
refrigerators in their house and this is
at a time when this was well it's still
unusual nowadays but I kind of feel like
it was even more unusual back then
because Richard Simmons was born in like
the late
1940s so they had three refrigerators in
their house
and story was that his mom was very into
you know it was New Orleans which is one
of the best food cities in the United
States food is a religion big time yeah
and so that's what I was saying so it's
like from a very young age you know he's
just like you know they got some like
[__] A2 going they got like some
[__] oyster po p boys going piso yeah
like yeah all that kind of stuff and
it's just like and you know Richard
Simmons he's a little kid he's like I'm
going to eat it [__] all and I can't
blame him cuz that [__] is delicious oh
man man he came he's from New Orleans
yeah he's from New Orleans that explains
a lot of it well yeah and a lot of
people have said that too jum whole
bowls of jumble ey it's just so good
like I said you can't stop eating it you
can't stop eating it yeah um Louisiana
food [__] is uh actually spread all
throughout all the whole South my my mom
and my my mom my grandmother and my uh
Dad when in Mississippi half the [__]
was caging that they were
mhm we call it cinjun but actually if if
you actually trace it back it's Paul
Pome was the one that did the recipes he
was reinterpreted in cinjun food uh we
don't really know exactly what the old C
it's just inspired by rumors of and and
and what what family traditions said it
was that they were making because a lot
of it wasn't written down or didn't
survive [__] cages are crazy the old
especially old school cages they eat
road kill they go out there this is
fresh enough this is fresh eat me don't
was it yes that armadillo will cook it
you know they [__] but that was I
think guys mostly [__]
50s don't eat armadilla they don't do
anymore they eatting armadilla I mean AR
armadilla are cute and everything
armadilla on the half shell we call it
Diller on the half shell I wouldn't eat
them though they're scavengers nasty
they're scavengers yeah they're nasty
[__] carry lepy and [__] it's like
eating the maggots yeah probably not a
great idea but they eat it anyway they
provide a valuable service to the
ecosystem
but I would not eat them just I saw one
run out of a [__] ass of a deer on
the middle of the road saw the dead deer
moving I was like what the [__] the
[__] zie [__] Diller [__] pops
out of its ass [__] runs across that
was the good stuff yeah armadillos are
super cute yeah dealer but I would not
eat one yeah so probably not a great
idea yeah so he's coming from a place
that is very food Centric that's what I
was saying in the South um that's kind
of like the way they express affection
and back in the day food was especially
back
then yeah and back in the day even in
the
80s the food was inexpensive and very
plentiful yeah it was nothing to for me
to sit down and eat like a dozen huge
[__] oysters deep fried with [__]
lemon
butter and probably that was end up
being about a half a stick of butter on
top of [__] oh for sure yeah 12 huge
[__] oysters and it didn't cost that
much yeah because it was all caught
right there it was another era yeah
Southerners are [__] fat man by 30 a
lot a lot of Southern are fat
Southerners and everything deep fried
well especially back then yeah
Southerners and Mexicans fat fat as a
[__] when get cuz the diets we
were eating well like I said southern
food is good and it's deep fried Mexican
food is also good it's super good it's
super good All That Corn I can see corn
tortillas don't blame Richard Simmons
for getting fat like growing up in New
Orleans I'd be like yeah it'd probably
be super fat too by the time I was 5
years old because that shit's delicious
same thing with like you know Mexico
yeah and they have like kind of an
obesity problem too but it's just like
the food is so good you can't blame them
I mean southern girls had a always in
the old school southern girls had a good
reputation here in the United States to
being gorgeous they were gorgeous
growing up here [__] in the
80s some of my cousins we call them
cousins but anybody a friend of the
family is a cousin here doesn't mean
you're really related close enough just
[__] gorgeous a lot of it had to do
with the diet
[__] you'd be a [__] 13-y old boy
and you look at some [__] 14y old
[__] girl 15y old girl and she just
[__] stacked you know what I mean but
you know they're eating a high fat diet
and yeah I had to wear a bra in fifth
grade yeah [__] puberty comes on
early for him it was a it it is
religious area but people don't
understand how sexually charged the
South was the South was not
prudish no man Skinny Dip in at [__]
12 13 and [__] you know boys and
girls and trying to set the woods on
fire just all kinds of [__] it's more
like God my brother used to do that
something yeah he said our backyard on
fire like one on yeah yeah it was like
Huckleberry Finn times he was always on
fire go just go watch white lightning or
something from [__] white lightning
and white
lightning
old we reviewed those I think we we went
through like a Bert Reynolds kind B
Reynolds Southern exploitation films
that's what it was like exploitation is
what they what's it called exploitation
exploitation sou exploitation whatever
but those were those movies were made by
the south for the South they're accurate
yeah they're very played on Drive-In
like down here yeah and we grew up
arching that [__] yeah I mean yeah
[__] funny it was it was another era
but it was uh it was it was quite cool
so yeah so that's where Simmons is
coming from and it was Food Heaven
that's what I mean if IID grown up in
New Orleans yeah I'd probably like weigh
[__] even poor people ate well oh
yeah [__] cuz uh even as a little kid
a lot of the older people were still
doing basically [__] subsistance
farming behind their house was just
[__] rows of [__] corn and okra
and [__] pumpkins and [__]
watermelons grown out there and they're
[__] they're like sharecroppers
growing their own food and eating off of
it they're real good at it so there's
free food F green fried green tomatoes
fried
okra uh they'd have chicken coup back
out there just eating
[__] free eggs and every now and then
[__] letting some of the eggs hatch
so you could kill the chickens they just
they were always like that they survived
the depression doing
that so yeah the South had lower incomes
but they had a very high quality of
living because they ate
well they grow food as far as like
calories yeah calories lots and lots of
calories yeah so they we got to eat up
all this food and it and like I said
there is a perception in the South that
if you weren't eating a lot and if you
weren't kind of chubby then there was
something wrong with you and neighbors
bring food to each other yeah deep just
all of a sudden you [__] hear the
doorbell ringing and somebody goes here
take this and it's just a bunch of food
we can't eat all okay all right yeah we
can't eat all this but that's your
friends you know them you know
they still take care of my dad like that
and um my dad lives in heidleberg
Mississippi it's a little bitt town you
can Google it used to be a German town
now he's the last white man and it's a
black
Mayberry and U all the black wom would
take care of him [__] bring him food
and [__] [__] turkey necks and all
this [__] that's his favorite we all
call it soul food we just call it
southern food but um yeah they all take
care of each other so there's a lot of
misconceptions the way the south is even
about racial stuff well like I said the
Deep South [__] in the deep deep
south white people and black people got
along pretty much because they were they
were both food is very much the um I'm
going to say like the the coin of the
land yeah that's kind of like you want
to make friends with somebody you bring
them some [__] you bring them a big
[__] cast and roll or some [__] you
know what I mean that was very and it
was the same thing like my grandmother
she was originally from Tennessee but
moved to Florida in the late
1950s and um man everybody would go to
her house she had every Thanksgiving she
had every Christmas she had everything
and there would just be like food
everywhere and if you came to her house
and a lot but you know if you're a
family member you just showed up at the
house you didn't even knock you just
walked in yeah and it's like she the
first thing she would say it was just
like hey we got like all this stuff in
the fridge you want some you know that'
be like the first thing is like to offer
you food yeah cuz we got all this food
in the fridge like you want some so yeah
so I see I see his problem the Deep
South is a recipe for for obesity it
really is is yeah and and it's a recipe
for obesity and [__] uh diabetes and
if it's and and if it's somebody which I
kind of feel like and I don't know I
don't know if Richard Simmons ever said
this outright he very well may have but
in one interview that I saw with him he
seemed to
imply and I'm you know please forgive me
if I'm you know reading into it but he
seemed to imply that
he got something from food that he was
not getting from his parents and like I
said that might be just me reading into
something that he said but he seemed to
because I I kind of feel like that is
something that people that chronically
overeat I mean that's usually something
they're trying to fill a hole they're
trying to fill a void and it's usually
love they don't have and and he even
said outright um and this was an example
that he used he said you know I got a D
in chemistry I think was the class that
he was talking about like at school and
he's like and I came home and my parents
like yelled at me he's like but the
cookies stayed calm yeah so he's just
like food was like his friend yeah like
it didn't judge him it didn't and like I
get that and I've heard that like from a
lot of people that have like you know
Eating Disorders or like overeating and
stuff like that it's like food doesn't
judge you it's always there for you
gratification it's comforting instant
gratification right and so if you're not
getting like affection or you're not
getting like you know the emotional [__]
that need especially when you're growing
up then that's very appealing so it's
like I don't really blame anybody for
falling into that because that's very
easy thing to fall into you know uh you
know and it is true and I think I had a
little I don't think it I mine was quite
as extreme because like I said I didn't
really get heavy until I you know was a
little bit older like a
teenager um but how long did you stay
heavy though 10 years maybe I started
getting heavy when I was about
12 and then I was got real heavy like
all through my teenage years into my
early 20s then I got
married and my ex-husband was super
skinny and he was also really into
fitness he was like a runner and he was
into karate and all this other stuff he
was from Wales yeah yeah yeah so um so I
started exercising then because he made
me um and we and we would play soccer
and stuff like that like on the weekend
he just liked you or he liked he liked
heavy girls that or what happened no he
just liked
like he didn't really but yeah so it's
like I don't think he had a preference
one way or the other but he just liked
me as a person so um so so you missed
out that's some pretty formative years
there they were kind of cut out you
weren't a hot girl during those times no
those are the those are the hot girl
years yeah I didn't have until your 30
actually her hot girl years were with me
actually but uh cuz Jenny was [__]
hot at the club yeah once she got
straight
yeah yeah it's okay though you just well
you know better loming late better late
than never better late than never yeah
and that's what I kind of f yeah now
you're a killer cougar
man you got better as you went well not
really better more appealing to the MK
well I mean I kind of always feel like
feel better though cuz you wear you can
wear all kinds of cool [__] now you look
good and I always kind of feel like well
it's kind of better than just like
peeking when you're a teenager and then
like
slowly you know getting getting old
older and fatter like as you get older
like you know what I mean it's just like
so I guess it's better than that yeah
but yeah I was what was that yeah what
the [__] was that noise sound like Bells
didn't it it did wow that was creepy
weird it sound like some ghost [__] oh
my God it was like went over here yeah
it came from there well that's well Tom
was saying earlier today because he was
so frustrated about all the [__] that
happen with the bike and stuff go back
to the beginning of the show if you
don't know what we're talking about but
um he's like watch some polter guy [__]
happen because he was like super
frustrated [__] super because we had
to keep driving back and forth and it
was like like I said it was like every
time was running into some kind of
problem yeah it and there was stuff that
I couldn't control and I was just I was
getting ready to cry man I was just like
and I was like yeah I'm in touch with
that frustrated you know I I get what
you're thinking yeah I get like that
sometimes especially like and I get like
that for the same reason like if my
computers are doing [__] that I don't
want or something like that like
anything having to do with technology is
like really frustrating for me it felt
like poch gu stuff would happen yeah
probably we'll see if the Xbox turns on
tonight or the television it probably
will Xbox has been turning on yeah yeah
the TV doesn't turn on but the Xbox does
cuz it makes a noise it goes like when
it turns on yeah and it'll do that like
in the middle of the night and I be and
that's that's that's one of the telltale
signs of it it'll do it to different
it'll turn on not only that thing other
things over the years it'll turn on
other televisions
and it'll turn on just a an electronic
thing it'll just turn stuff
on it's weird Zach says $5 says it's a
weird notification sound on Tom's tablet
he forgot he turned on I've never heard
that before came from up there yeah it
was really weird and Mr Mr 88 said this
has been the most sidetracked episode
ever I don't know sidetracked is a
[__] I don't know if I'd go that
far no we've done some crazy [__] we
yeah we've gone like way sidetracked
like so much so that like the next day I
was like did we even talk about the to
there is a mystery
about this dude all right but let me a
pee before like get into that okay well
[__] then
then I'll talk about something
else I can't talk about it when you're
not here she's gonna come back and we're
gonna finish the Richard
Simmons we're when she comes back we'll
talk about the Richard Simmons let me
see what the's see what
the Larry's drinking Twisted Tea okay
Twisted Tea that that had alcohol in it
I
think Allison Wonderland leftover scare
from yesterday I'm not sure what you're
referring
to yeah Mr 88 says it's the most
sidetracked
ever yeah it
is it's your old landlord keep it tabs
through the hidden cameras
[Laughter]
yeah okay now Tammy says that she was
talking about it's not free it's it uh
it's a lot of hard work she must be
talking about growing food it's true I
grow some out here
you got to pay a lot of money I'm using
uh grow bags now that way I can bring
them indoors because that last [__]
winter was so bad it killed a bunch of
[__] so I want to be able to drag each
[__] plant indoors inside the air
conditioning in case the [__] freeze
comes it could have saved a bunch of
[__] but it's a lot of work and I'm
trying to
learn uh trying I'm trying to learn it
um although I'm getting pretty good
yields in eggplant get a lot of eggplant
make B Gish got eggplant we have so much
eggplant you guys oh yeah the problem
with it is uh it all comes ready at once
and a lot of times you're not you don't
have other things to complete a dish for
that so I'm learning to jar a lot of it
yeah cuz we made like a lot of eggplant
lasagna which is delicious I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying we've
made a lot of that and
Baba so I think we still have some
babaan frozen actually don't we or or
did we eat the rest of it no it's eaten
okay we ate the rest of it the other
night okay so we're back to uh we're
back to Richard Simmons we're start the
Mysteries after [__] two hours
probably no it's only been an hour I
think no it's two hours two hours okay
yeah 159 okay so yeah so like I said
when he was a little kid um he seemed to
you know like a lot of people do that
overeat do like kind of get emotional
attachment to food what another thing he
said too was that between he said
between his house he grew up in the
French Quarter actually okay yeah and um
know the place as well yeah yeah cuz
like I said us you used to spend a lot
of time there yeah down Decor street so
between his house and I think his school
or whatever it was he said there were
like five shops or like five restaurants
and he would stop at every single one
like get something to eat like get a
candy bar or something and then he would
hide all the rappers like when he got
home like so his parents wouldn't know
how much he was eating so he was already
hiding it like when he was like pretty
little and he also like his first job
when he was like a and he was still like
a kid was he worked at a place in New
Orleans that sold uh prolin oh yeah I
love them so which like I saiden made
them in a long time and I've seen like a
lot of people are said like well you
work in a you're a kid and you work in a
place that sells prings yeah you're
going to get you're going to get
fat that shit's delicious you know what
prings isin I was like I'd have gotten
fat too they're kind of like these
little candies some people might say
it's a cookie but there's no cookie in
it you take wax paper and and you put
down uh uh I think it's uh
pecans and you pour over it kind of
something like caramel it's sugar damn
near pure sugar and butter so good oh
there and um and it goes over the it
goes over the the pecans and becomes
kind of like a turtle prob people call
it a turtle which is like caramel
covered in chocolate but it has
chocolate over it but this is but
proling is not like that they're not
called pralin all right that's that's PR
pralin all right that's a [__] Yankee
pronunciation
pralin prowlin are like
[__]
sugary candy and it just kind of melts
in your mouth they're not hard they're
not chewy they just they're almost kind
of like divinity but it's
sugary you can crumble them up put them
in ice cream that's where pings and
creamed Ice Cream came from they're real
good which is also Del sugar man oh my
God
hypoglycemia okay most of southern foods
like that yeah it's so it's so good
though all your Southern it's just sweet
tea is a gallon of tea with two cups of
sugar pretty much maybe three or more
maybe three okay [__] same thing with
uh
[__] we like our we like our sugar
and our fat lot of sugar you know yeah
that's just and it's and it's again like
it's kind of hard to get over that
because the shit's delicious yeah it it
gets right to your pleasure centers so I
think that's why it's kind of so that's
why so many people that live in the
south are overweight yeah in the defense
of sugar though sugar cane sugar is a
lot better for you than corn syrup it is
yeah uh and it it just doesn't put the
fat on you that corn syrup
will and most people are getting fat
from corn syrup because if you actually
look at the ingredients and all those
fing sodas that you're drinking is corn
syrup there's corn syrup and all those
[__] cereals and [__] [__] and
everything you know some kind of corn
syrup is a
sweetener it's like something you'd feed
to a cow man F to put weight on it well
yeah that's what they do right can
they're make burgers out of the cow so
they want them to like fatten up as
quickly as possible so yeah they give it
corn Kandy sugar doesn't have that
effect on you just drink Mexican
Coca-Cola or throwback it tastes better
anyway I it tastes a lot better I'm not
into like Coke or so I don't really like
sodas all that much so real sugar can
sodas Are Better Man
Superior I go to the Mexican shop just
to get a Mexican Coca-Cola every now and
then they've started selling them in
some grocery stores I no they call it
throwback yeah throwback they got a lot
of different kind of throw cane sugar in
it and some I think some of the publ I
was in a or maybe it wasn't Publix I
think it was wind Dixie that actually
had Mexican Coke like on the Shelf next
to the regular Coke so some so some uh
grocery stores do have that Mexican
Coca-Cola is the same recipe I remember
back when I was a kid in the 70s it it
was like that so it's like going back in
time back when Coca-Cola was really
good yeah came in a glass bottle like I
said I'm not I'm not really into soda
like you like soda but I don't like I'll
drink like we were at Wendy's today I
just got ginger ale I'll drink ginger
ale or root beer or something like but
normally I mostly what I drink I drink
booze obviously but water and coffee and
that's about it yeah I I don't really
drink any soda I don't seek it out I
just I'm not really into it never have
been I don't know why um Allison yeah
you spelled it right it's p r p r a l i
n s and you can find real recipes for
Louisiana prolin yeah yeah they're
really good yeah like I said so I can
see like working in a prolan shop yeah
as a
kid yeah I mean and especially if the
shop was just kind of like hey as long
as you do your job you can eat as much
as you want and be like well well thank
you very much just pure Su I will if you
don't mind and that's probably what
happened so like I said I can't really
blame him growing up in New Orleans
growing up and you know and his parents
I guess they didn't really think much
about it because they were both thin
like I said I've seen photos of them
like with uh Richard and his brother
Lenny when they were children and their
parents are both thin and he said that
the his parents were both thin their
whole lives so they didn't really have
to worry about it so I guess they didn't
really think about it they're just like
yeah we're just going to eat all this
food you eat the lemon pound
cake lemon icing cake oh yeah yeah yeah
that's Mississippi as [__] that and
cocoons we made that a lot to oh yeah
cocoons yeah yeah we made cocoons
cocoons are little white cookies they're
shaped like a little cocoon a little
Crysis they call cocoons man they're
[__] good all that shit's good it's
kind of like a buttery cookie with
powdered sugar on the outside of it with
little
uh nuts in there they were see how I
said that all of these shows like
devolve into talking about food well how
about
um well buttery and it's all kind I
think in our cookbook too we talked
about hay stacks yeah did we put cocoons
in the in the in the uh I don't remember
if we did I know we put Hy Stacks in
there but I don't remember if we put
cocoons in there got I got a cookbook
that has all this in it you can if
you're looking for a cookbook uh cuz
Hast Stacks are super easy like you can
just and you can pretty much you can put
pretzels in there if you want I prefer
not to cuz really like pretzels but um
you can find other Stu like I used to
use always used to um put Frosted Flakes
in there yeah pretzels are okay but it's
like I kind of like um ones that are
kind of more like I like Maple Lea
flavored ones because you can use like
kind of whatever you can use chocolate
if you want or you can use white
chocolate or caramel there's a lot of
other things you can use no prings are
not thin shrimp
no no that's prawns prawns yeah that's a
completely different thing Prine is a
Prine is like a c it's almost like a
candied cand pecan is kind of what it is
shaped like a cookie but it's it's a
candied pecan
yeah it's like a Patty kind candy yeah
is what it is doesn't have anything to
do with
shrimp doesn't have anything to do with
SH but yeah so this is the uh the kind
of world that he grew up in I guess so
he started getting chubby I saw a
picture of him with his family when he
was probably when it looked like he was
still like kind of a toddler like he
looked like three or four years old and
he was like chubby but not noticeably
chubby you know what I mean just like
the same kind of chubby as a kid that
ages is sometimes but apparently um by
the time he was a teenager like 15 years
old he was already
pushing 200
lb um because he would just eat and eat
and he said uh and he's been very open
about this that like I said said you
know food didn't judge him food didn't
complain food didn't yell at him um it
was always there it was always
comforting it was it could be relied
upon um so he just kept on eating it you
know what I mean because it made him
feel
better and uh because of this he was
pretty relentlessly bullied he also said
the first Halloween party he ever went
to when he was a teenager he dressed as
a
couch because was so overweight CES says
this episode CES is a really cute black
metal chick from [__] Australia she's
in this episode's making me want to get
fat sound that's what well that's my
problem yeah is that so like I said I
get it yeah because people that're just
kind because food is [__] delicious
like in a lot especially [__] you cook
is like super delicious s you have all
the ingredients you can you can find the
recipes and make them in Australia look
up cocoons Southern cocoons all right
yeah they little
pralines PR yeah you could probably the
Louisiana [__] prow leads you'll find
them like I said yeah they're [__]
really good I mean you asked me right
now I want a piece of key pie or I want
like a [__] donut ABS I was thinking
about the the lemon pound cake with the
[__] lemon icing that your grandma
used to make it into round bunt cake
[__] thing yeah we used to make that
heavy it's like pure [__] lemony and
it's almost kind of like it's [__]
heavy it's so moist yeah and then she
take just uh lemon juice and icing sugar
to make the icing and pour that on the
top of it man it was addictive you
couldn't eat just one piece you'd eat
one piece and then you get guilty go I
gota eat another piece like I said you
couldn't leave that [__] with me I half
the [__]
cake before he even looked so you know
this is why I chubbed out when I was a
teenager e to get fat this shit's
delicious yeah and I get it I still
struggle with that nowadays like luckily
luckily nowadays I feel like because I
lost so much weight at some point like
my stomach kind of shrank so now I
physically can't eat that much food at
once or I will throw up
so so it's a lot easier nowadays so I'm
just like oh my God this so good but
like now I feel sick and I don't want to
eat anymore so it's like that's probably
good because it stops me from overeating
but yeah so he's almost 200 lb like as a
teenag like he's 15 years old so when he
gets a little bit older um he thought
about becoming a priest like I said he
did actually go to Seminary for I think
he said a year and nine months so it was
a while um but then I guess he decided
it wasn't for him he he remained like I
said he converted to Catholicism I think
I mentioned that earlier even though his
dad was Methodist his mom was Jewish but
um but he
seemed kind of religious like through
the rest of his life just in a kind of a
generic happy clappy kind of way
like he wasn't like super hardcore about
it it didn't seem like but he did kind
of um I think he maybe thought about
going to art school or something like
that because he did kind of want to go
into entertainment or like be an actor
or something now here's something that I
didn't know when he was real heavy um
cuz he did get up to I think his Peak
weight was 268 pounds I don't know how
tall he is actually but he was he said
he was pretty obese he's not very tall I
think he's probably 5' six probably so I
didn't realize this but he was in a
couple of films in the late 60s early
70s he was in satian the the [__]
felini movie I know like as one of the
as one of the freaks quote unquote um
and he was also in a movie called The
Clowns from 1970 like playing like freak
Show characters because he was like the
fat man you know what I mean which like
I said somebody nowadays this is kind of
sad with somebody nowadays that weighed
268 PBS um you would not get a gig as
the fat person in a circus freak Show
nowadays with that because you would
just be like regular you know you'd have
to be like [__] 700 lbs like for it
to even be yeah to even move the needle
well we saw a British movie remember
that British horror fli they had the fat
woman up there we're looking at like
yeah that's not unusual fat though it's
like yeah that's not really a fat woman
well like I said sometimes you look back
at like old school pictures of like
freak shows and it's like here's the fat
woman I'm like she's not really that fat
yeah not by today's standards me and J
are researching [__] getting a damn
female sex doll to make videos with for
a poor [__] right and [__] they're
all Chinese vendors and all a lot of the
figures that I'm looking at like yeah
that would be pretty good one you know
you know it labeled as fatwoman
Caucasian and they like what fat I'm
like Hey fat woman I'm a fat woman who
you talking about you're like she's not
fat regular you look at what and she's
not fat she just look regular you
exactly what I'm talking about she just
she's regular yeah real real curvy they
called her fatom was that was fat but
when you look at what they're what what
what they're buying in China they're
[__] like Pixies you know well yeah
there's skeletons I mean they have
smaller frames there I get that like I
said that's kind of an issue when you
buy clothes from there too because it's
just like all the clothes are like real
small so you have to like kind of
buy you have to buy like a size or two
bigger than you would normally wear at
least cuz they're very they're very
small and I and I don't consider myself
I I kind of consider I'm like an average
size person you know what I mean I'm not
thin but I'm not fat either you're
medium build I'm medium build yeah um
and usually and usually medium [__] fits
me yeah sometimes small [__] fits me it
depends on what it is large is too big
but it's just kind of like usually the
female medium frame doesn't look good
when it gets too light it has to have
muscular muscle and fat on it then it it
looks better so I was saying you know
Jenny didn't look that good at
118 she
I don't really have the frame for a
skinny person yeah you got to have real
narrow shers I look a little
weird I'm more of a mediumsized person
like I said so I I I found that my ideal
weight was about 135
pounds Jens good bu well yeah but
depending on muscle cuz I didn't really
have a lot of muscle at that point but
that was kind of what I looked look good
[__] jacked yeah yeah with some fat
on
it yeah so that so that's kind of how
big he was back then at the time like I
said you know nowadays it probably
wouldn't even move the needle 268 pounds
that doesn't I mean yeah that's obese
but man we see people walking around in
the mall 300 no problem that are like
easily 300 lb and like no nobody BS an
ey so you know uh but it's kind of
changed since that since that time so he
decided as many people did in the early
1970s that he wanted to be in Show
Business Like I said because he'd been
in Italy and he'd been in a couple of
like like I said he' been in felen
movies and stuff like that so he's like
well I'm you know I'm going to move to
Hollywood like a lot of people did so we
moved to Hollywood and again as many
people do when they move to Hollywood uh
when they're kind of looking for work
and [__] like that they work in
restaurants so his job was he worked as
a matro d at a place called Derek's
which was a restaurant in Beverly Hills
and he was actually some people I saw a
documentary where like a some people
that used to go because that was kind of
um a restaurant that was frequented by a
lot of celebrities at the time like
Orson Wells used to go there and Lucille
Ball and people like that so he kind of
got noticed cuz even then he was kind of
um his personality was like Larger than
Life you know what I mean so so a lot of
people kind of like noticed him now at
this point he
decided okay so he decided he was going
to lose all this weight cuz like I said
said he was very heavy now Pro well not
probably definitely
unwisely he decided I'm going to do it
through
starvation to his credit it did
work he ate at least according to him
nothing but water and lettuce for two
and a half months yeah that's not
nutrition there's no nutrition there now
he lost about 150 pounds yeah during
that time but
um there were some adverse effects like
he ended up having to go to a doctor and
they're like look you're GNA die yeah
you know what I mean cuz that's not
great that's just
water yeah I mean lettuce started that
damn [__] I know I hear started that
damn [__] stereo up again like I said
I a driveby on that house I told him
earlier I said are we gonna have to burn
that house down or what yeah burn that
house down or just go dve by that house
just like beat his ass or break his
speakers or something he's a pretty big
dude
do you think you could take him do you
think we could both take him not hand to
hand but I got all kinds of equipment
he's got other ways of dealing he' never
even see it coming he never see it
coming he would he would just shut he
would just all of a sudden realize he's
in heaven he wouldn't know what
happened thank you Jeffy art I don't
understand why some people have a hard
time just being quiet why is that hard
drunk he's drunk so are we yeah he's but
you can't hear me two houses down and
he's Rich that's the thing this is not
the ghetto this is a [__] great
neighborhood that's what I mean he's got
Manion over there with [__] monster
trucks we don't live in a trailer he's
got an enclosed [__] swimming pool in
the back it's it's it's a Florida Palace
two
stories so like I said it's there's some
entitlement issues yeah it' make a great
porn scene you know you could shoot porn
over there look it' look totally awesome
we could shoot porn in our house if if
we had better Furniture yeah but uh or
more furniture we don't really have we
don't have a Furniture we're very
minimalists we're still trying to build
our kingdom up
so we don't have a lot of furniture but
yeah so it's just and look now he's
gone oh it'll start back in a minute I
think yeah so yeah so I think like a lot
of people kind of noticed him working at
this restaurant because like I said
there were a lot of celebrities that
went there and a lot of producers and
stuff like that so they kind of noticed
like his over-the-top personality
because even then he was just kind of
like very and like I said I think he
kind of
cultivated that personality and like I
said I might be totally pulling this out
of my ass don't know him personally but
it seems like like a lot of comedians do
they kind of have you know issues you
know whatever it is with you know
insecurity or you know various other
things or like him being like um
overweight or whatever and you kind of
like
overcompensate so he his personality
just became just huge and like Larger
than Life but a lot of people like
remembered
that so he was he worked worked at this
restaurant for a while and was able to
save up I think about
$25,000 something like that because he
started getting really interested in
because what happened after he did the
starvation thing for two and a half
months and lost all the weight was the
doctor told him it's like look you're
going to die if you keep doing [__] like
this you really need to like it's good
that you lost all the weight but you
have to really do [__] the right way so
he started getting really interested in
Fitness and in eating healthy and stuff
like that and he decided that he wanted
to help other people that were in the
same situation as him like I said I
don't know if he
deliberately set out to kind of get into
the niche market of people that were not
being um kind of serviced by the fitness
industry at the time because you have to
think this was like late' 60s early' 7s
the fitness industry very focused on
people that were kind of already in
shape or at least um you know the stuff
they were selling is just kind of like
hey I'm super jacked you can look like
me if you buy this thing or buy my plan
or whatever yeah and it was all lies and
it was all lies so I don't know if he
deliberately placed himself in there or
if it was just him um just kind of like
well this was my experience and I'm
going to share this with other people I
kind of feel like it was more the lad
because it doesn't really seem like he
deliberately tried to mark it to a
particular
demographic but it whatever it was like
he's just kind of like well you know I'm
going to get more into fitness I'm going
to start eating healthy and like
actually exercising and stuff like that
because you know if I just keep trying
to starve myself of the weight yeah I
lost the weight but it's like super
unhealthy and it had all these bad um
side effects like all these
repercussions so he's like I'm going to
share my experience with other people
because there's probably lots of other
people out there that are having the
same issues as me so that was kind of
what he he wanted to do so he saved up
all this money from his Mator D job and
started opening up and opened up like a
fitness
center and his kind of goal was he's
like I want this to be just for regular
people or people who feel like they
can't go to a regular gym or regular
fitness center because they're too heavy
or they're intimidated or something like
that he's like I want this to be a place
where everybody can come and do the
stuff and it's not you know too
difficult and it's not it's not like
something they can't do um he's like he
seemed like he wanted to make it
approachable you know which it really
wasn't at the time cuz Fitness was kind
of Niche I feel like at this point you
know and we kind of talked about this on
when we talked about the um show about
like kind of the history of bodybuilding
and stuff because we did a show about
that and I kind of feel like for a long
time it's not Niche nowadays I don't
think I would call it like a subculture
it is kind of but it wasn't like Niche I
kind of feel like at this point it was
yeah
okay my dad was from Mississippi but he
and my mom hooked up she was Southern
too but they hooked up in California
after my dad got out of the
Navy this is in the 70s out in
California I think they got married like
68 or something I was born in 69 by the
time I was about 76 1976 I was about six
seven years old my dad got involved in
one of the first mainstream Fitness
[__] Sensations to happen that was
running
jogging yeah that was very that simple
that was very big that became like a big
thing before that Fitness was not a
thing yeah it wasn't really no that was
that was that was something weirdos did
something [__] weird freaks did
something weird freaks did called
bodybuilders they had a lot of good
bodybuilders but they were freaks back
in those people thought well [__] as big
as that dude is he must be
dumb their thinking
wasn't and that went on for a long time
even in the 70s
you had dudes thought that working out
and training was
cheating you're supposed to just be
strong and beat another dude's ass just
B just based on your masculinity or
something I guess you know I mean I'm
just so manly that I beat your ass you
know working out you work out well [__]
you worked out that's cheap you know
it's like that's that's kind of the
thing so Fitness was not a thing really
until the 70s and it started with this
is the in the mainstream and it started
with
jogging
it mus uh [__] what I'm going to say
bodybuilding and weightlifting never was
never mainstream it was always a niche
thing and uh the the closest it ever
became mainstream was the Golden Era of
the 70s and 80s would be Arnold
Schwarzenegger he made
bodybuilding a thing in the public eye
that it was that man heroes did that and
movie stars did that and that's where
all this MCU and [__] superhero
movies actually was built on the back of
the [__] that Arnold Schwarzenegger and
the action now everybody SBC everybody
yeah those dudes are all on gear on on
the mcui HMS too CGI and those costumes
but they're on GE to
um so yeah so you know that was the
world of that day yeah people knew about
know about people know more about it now
and have access to more information now
just through the internet than ever they
ever would have
had early Fitness especially
bodybuilding 50s and
60s that was almost a gay
thing the uh a lot of like I said it was
it was a very Niche subculture I feel
like those dudes and I would believe
Arnold also rumor has it I can't prove
it
allegedly a lot of those dudes were
built on the back of damn nude
photos they must be out there
somewhere but even in the 50s male
bodybuilders sold nude photos of
themselves yeah that was kind of like a
big um sideline for them yeah that's
where the money came from to buy their
gear and to pay I never [__] on anybody
for making money yeah in a way that
doesn't hurt other people we were
talking about that earlier today yeah
and that goes back to the 1800s with eug
Sandow who invented the [__] invented
Olympia work what you got he was 1800s
and you go look up eug everybody got to
make money eugin looked good you Eugen
get private shows for gentlemen yeah for
you know Eugen sold [__] basically
nudies yeah they might have had a f
which we like we're pretending like they
pretended back then that it's just like
that it wasn't a gay thing but it's like
everyone's you know it was like that
kind of yeah yeah but that's you know
well the main appreciators were were
dudes yeah of course you know straight
guy go man he looks great [__] I wish
I look like that some dudes were way
into that though they're like yeah I
kind of want that dude yeah you know
that's so I want to look like that dude
or I want that dude there there's that
there was always that dynamic in body
Spectrum yeah all the Spectrum yeah not
really that far apart when he not that
far apart really no absolutely not me it
was always I want to look like that dude
right you know but I totally understand
why gays like it well well Tom is an
aesthetic appreciated yeah I like I like
the human body the aesthetic a the
Perfection of the human body both female
bodies and male bodies yeah yeah and
[__] what they've done with
themselves I was like man it's [__]
awesome it's like
sculpting yeah within women I'm a little
more open to like variations like some
of some of fat girls [__] look great
but some of those extreme proportions
and you can't do that with muscle you
can only do that with fat that doesn't
work on a male figure it just doesn't
with with guys that's better lead lean
and
big V taper little waist like a wasp big
shoulders big arms big thighs great
Cavs this look you want to look like a
dude you don't want to fight you said I
ain't gonna fight that dude that's what
you that's what I want to look like you
know yeah yeah Zach says I just Googled
nudes of Arnold he's very averagely
endowed I I didn't know the nudes oh so
the nudes have
leaked it's the Internet it's the
internet okay if you've ever Tak a nude
picture of yourself ever someone it's
going be [__] is going to find yeah
those were probably Secret at one time
that was [__] he was selling out the
back door there is there are no secrets
anymore yeah which like I said I kind of
like that yeah I kind of like that it's
all right just lay it all out there yeah
you know what I mean man I got all kind
of news out there yeah but yeah videos
photos all kind of yeah all for sale
just sad no I mean some of it might be
free I don't really know I don't know
where it turns up you know where it
doesn't really matter but you know it's
all calling cards we got to make more
videos though because yeah new videos
are going to be coming CU we haven't
made like any new ones in a long time if
you're interested in the
videos we're on you can just go on uh
what's name mini vids mini vids m n y
mini vids one word let's go and 13 cam
spell it out t h i r 13 Cam and you
will'll come up yeah yeah there's
there's [__] out there not a lot but
some stuff like I said we got we got to
make some more stuff cuz yeah that was
our first that was our first look better
than I did in those that was our first
batch yeah and we wanted to do more
creative stuff like outside yeah we were
just talking about that today I'm like
yeah we need to do like some do some
outdoor [__] yeah I want to do some
outdoor [__] some public [__] is and
like I said we've been talking about
getting like a sex do to and like doing
some stuff with that like a realistic
one that be there's some gags we can do
with that we don't have to pay her
that's one which is nice yeah we don't
have to split money with it but yeah so
I kind of feel like he was maybe
arguably the first person whether this
was deliberate or not to open a gym or
like you know kind of like a whole
Fitness thing that was geared toward
people that were not already fit or
didn't want to go to regular gyms
because they're like oh I don't look
good enough and people are going to
judge me or whatever so I kind of feel
like he was the first person to kind of
tap into that and I think the cool thing
about it was that I don't like I said I
don't really think it was super super
deliberate I think he was just coming at
it from a point of view of like well I
used to be really obese he lost like 120
lbs something like that um and got
interested in Fitness and he's just like
well I'm interested in like reaching out
to other people that had the same
experience as him that were maybe um you
know obese when they were younger and
they got bullied and stuff so he knew
where they were coming from and he knew
how intimidating it was to get start
getting into fitness cuz other people
look at you be like you know what are
you doing or whatever so I kind of feel
like he was kind of instrumental in
doing that and he was maybe the first
person to do that whether it was
deliberately or not so he opens his uh
first Studio which actually it was first
called I think it was called the anatomy
Asylum was what I think they first
called it which is not a great name but
you know what I mean and I think at that
point like it also had a restaurant in
it which was kind of mostly focused on
salads cuz he wasn't just focused on
Fitness he was also focused on portion
control that was like uh another of his
big things like you know getting people
to change their eating habits and stuff
but it seems like he wasn't
real like I said it wasn't like he was
selling a diet or you know like Atkins
or whatever um he was just very focused
on eating like healthier options eating
smaller portions you know getting up off
the couch and moving around like
whatever it was you were doing so it was
like a lot more realistic I feel like so
he was kind of more into that so it did
have a restaurant for a while but I
guess like they kind of abandoned after
a bit and they were just kind of like
yeah we're just going to focus on the
exercise aspect of it so the place later
got renamed to slimmons which you know
that's a much better name Larry says he
loves our VDS so we got a fan out there
didn't okay yeah like I said I want to
do some better ones I want to do some
better ones um and we have more stuff
coming to like work with I have like so
many outfits I want to like try out for
yeah we got a lot of clothes got a lot
of got a lot of [__] props that are
coming yeah and um all kind of stuff on
Min vids you can uh contact and um
commission work for us we had a guy who
was we were going to do something for
for a mere like 50 we're going to do
something but it' be available to the
public cuz like I said we'll we'll make
custom videos too like if you're willing
to pay for a custom video we'll do like
well within reason we'll do like pretty
much I have calling your name out or
whatever we'll we'll [__] go reason
we'll go family style on will go
whatever like whatever you want to do
within reason there's some stuff I won't
do but you know what I mean there's some
stuff he won't do but you know we we can
we can hash that out Tammy's going
Peggy try to Peg me we talking about
that earlier you're trying to Peg me
already at the VA I'm
trying that you were saying you were
saying you said something very
interesting today that it's like and I'm
not going to say who you were talking
about but you were saying just like you
know know somebody that like you know
pegs their boyfriend yeah well we know
more than more than one person that does
that cuz it's not that unusual and um
Tom said something like well don't you
think of him any differently that's what
I asked her yesterday and I was and I
thought to myself I was like why would
that make it like CU to me I you
definitely would well yeah but like a
but dudes and women don't think the same
and I was like to me it's just not I
don't know it's not weird I don't have a
hang up about it so it's like I wouldn't
look at you any differently I don't I
don't really get like I would think that
like I get I would think I would think
that a woman would just go man you're a
[__] hoe you
know you're feminine as [__] if you let
me do that to you I think that you're
projecting I think you're projecting
yeah because that's what guy that's what
a guy would say right but that's not
what we think though I I wouldn't think
that yeah maybe other chicks do but I I
wouldn't think that that wouldn't even
have occurred to me unless you unless
you I think I think there's I think
there's a lot of women that would also
have a different opinion I mean maybe
well there are some women that there are
some women that would there are some
women that would never [__] with a dude
who had anything to do with another guy
but then there are other women that go
crazy over that they'll taret see that
absolutely does not bother me at all
they'll Target bisexual dudes they think
they're [__] hot as [__] but there
are other women that are exactly the
opposite if if you [__] around with
another dude then you're just off the
list they won't they won't even [__]
with
you yeah well like I said everybody
different everybody's different I am
absolutely not bothered by like if a
dude was bisexual or like yeah [__] I
think the the the average chick was like
[__] I can't trust this dude around men
yeah but it's normies yeah yeah well
that's what we're talking about that's
most
people I don't really I I don't go by I
don't go by Normie logic yeah it
honestly it's it literally does not buy
and actually I think it's kind of hot
you know what I mean I think it's kind
of hot I I don't really it's it doesn't
bother me in the slightest not at
all I mean I I get why maybe people like
oh now I can't trust him around anybody
but I don't know that that didn't really
occur to me you know I don't know I know
I'm weird
but I don't know all right so so yeah so
they open slimmons like I said slimmons
was there from I believe it opened in
1974 it was in Beverly Hills and didn't
close until 2016 and as far as I know
the whole time that it was
open Richard Simmons himself self taught
classes every week at least once a week
perhaps as many as three times a week
like I said that's [__] commitment
that is somebody that especially as time
went on as the 80s and 90s went on he
absolutely did not need to do that
because he was a
multi-millionaire by that point um but
he showed up and he would do [__] like
this is crazy so he had like regulars at
the class they were talking about this
on the podcast they're like one of the
regulars there was this lady who was
94 I think she said she was 94 like they
interviewed her on the podcast and she
had been going to slimmons like every
week for years and years and
years and she so she was like the right
she had like the um he's like there was
a hierarchy if you were like a regular
you got like in the first two rows you
know what I mean and then like newbies
had to kind of be in the back which like
I said that would happen naturally yeah
yeah yeah so it's like so her name was
Gigi and so it's like so Gigi had been
going there for like forever and it's
just kind of like and so people that
would go there regularly like if you
were older and like you didn't have a
car or something like that Richard
Simmons would pick you up in his car and
drive you to the class like if you
couldn't get there that day like you're
like hey man like my car broke down or I
can't drive anymore or something like
that he would come and get you and he's
like a huge multi-millionaire celebrity
he has huge house in Beverly it's
actually he's still there as far as I
know but it looked like
what DVD dragons say go dressed in your
bag costume when they give you your
prostate exam that [__] ain't goingon to
happen man I did the [__] research on
that [__] man [__] I saw the whole
prostate industry I went to the American
Cancer [__] in Institute and looked
at how they're doing they're trying
they're just making money off dudes
giving out [__] prostate massages
that's all that if I wanted that [__]
I'd go to rubb and tug or get have Jen
do it I'll massage your prostate cuz
what they do is they just [__] rub
that [__] come back in 6 months and
we'll rub it again then you come back
come back you got go to the rubbing tug
what's that you don't got to go to the
rubbing Tu I'll do it for yeah yeah yeah
J is all about that [__] you know
then they'll be like come back in six
months oh yeah you might have something
here um maybe we'll do a biops and oh
we'll see what it comes back oh okay no
that just's negative uh or yeah it's
slow acting just don't worry about it
you'll be okay it's growing so slow
you'll die something else before it
happens but in the meantime let's just
keep coming back and rubbing on this
thing every [__] six months they're
selling you prostate massages what
they're doing well I mean that's what
you're into they're perves anyway
they're per it's just a way of making
money because then they come back and
the [__] comes back in the biopsy oh
this is fast acting cancer here you're a
[__]
goner sorry we can if we cut it out
you're going to be impotent or
incontinent one of the two so which way
you want to go it says no I was going to
go home and take a fent all overdose man
[__] that [__] so no the prostate thing
and then it says right there in the
Cancer Institute that early detection of
it makes no difference in the outcome
makes no difference so no matter no
matter when they find it the outcome
will always be the same so [__] them
they're just just more
scams M Bowser said I wish I didn't get
here late I didn't know Richard Simmons
disappeared I didn't either until
someone recommended it and I started
researching this show
uh Jones Perkin said you you like the
beginning of the show go back and listen
to the beginning I mean you know we said
all kinds of cool [__] he said you guys
can talk about nothing that I'm
interested in and I still keep
listening this is actually pretty
interesting he was an interesting guy
yeah I thought so too well interesting
time like Mr 88 said uh you missed a lot
but nothing much about Richard Simmons
like we've talked about him a little bit
and then we kind of get off on like
[__] tangent well because his whole
thing and like I said we both grew up
during this time period his whole thing
about like the weight loss and the
fitness and everything like that like
we've both gone through like I've gone
through the whole thing about you know
weight loss and being bullied and stuff
like that so I kind of get that angle
and you kind of get like the fitness
angle so we have kind of like talked
about that yeah yeah it's related yeah
so it is kind of Rel trying to we're
just giv context we're just kind of like
justifying we're giv context we're
justifying the side a context for the
time too well yeah it was another era
right so like so what I'm saying is that
Richard Simmons even though he didn't
have to when was hugely famous and had
millions of millions of dollars he has a
massive House in Beverly Hills uh in the
Hollywood Hills which looks like uh the
house from Gone With the Wind actually
it's like this huge pool and it's just
like it's really nice um so he didn't
need the money but he still showed up
every single [__] week at slimmons
and taught those classes at 12 bucks a
pop 12 bucks that's all it ever was and
he never raised the prices he didn't
need the money yeah um so there was like
a whole subculture that kind of sprung
up around that place yeah well it sounds
like he's doing it for social reasons
yeah and well and the thing about him
that I thought was really interesting
and I you know what I get it because I'm
also an introvert I'm also kind of super
empathetic to the point where it's
probably like damaging like to your own
psyche at some point is that he um got
so he
he was like so
into making other people feel good
making other people happy that it's like
when it came time for himself he didn't
really like he would just kind of go and
like be a recluse in his house and he
said that he was a Reus a long time ago
like when because I saw some interviews
with him when he was young still like in
the 70s and 80s and he would basically
say outright in interviews yeah I'm just
a recluse I don't go out and party or
anything like that like I go and I do my
[__] like on the talk shows and I go and
teach my class and stuff and then I just
go home with my dogs and that's it like
he just spends a lot of time alone so he
and he said he was kind of lonely
actually um he never seemed to have like
a long-term relationship of any kind
other than with his housekeeper which
we'll get into in a
bit but he never really seemed I don't
know he really never seemed to establish
like any really deep personal con C with
anybody he never married he never like
other than his housekeeper he didn't
live with anybody like I said it was
just his housekeeper and his dogs pretty
much like his Dalmations he had eight of
them and so he seemed like a very lonely
person but he almost seemed to kind of
like it like I said he seemed very
introverted but in a way
that was because almost kind of like
paradoxical because he would just go out
and be like super larger than life you
know cuz that was kind of his whole
Persona well we got Zach in the audience
and fing he he might be able to give us
another
perspective but looking at Richard
Simmons I would say that [__]
Richard physically wouldn't have been
considered like a hot La gay
dude had he gotten into the [__] gay
club scene there they' have run through
him they'd run through his
money so I think he probably stayed away
from him because he kind of knew
that well and he probably had a lot of
um self-esteem issues from growing up
the way he did because I get that yeah
you know so he would like well if I go
to the club go hang out these other gay
guys they're just going to be after me
for my
money CU look man [__] La gay SC man
[__] those dudes are about looks you
well yeah and the thing about it was
that probably I mean even though he
looked like okay but it's just kind of
like it's La yeah for one thing uh it's
very superficial like generally so it's
just kind of like if you don't you show
up there it's you're going to be like
especially somebody with self-esteem
issues like he had like I'm just never
going to be good enough you're never
going to be good enough what Happ so why
bother he would get
bombarded but he'd get bombarded by gold
diggers right that's what would happen
and I feel like he was probably pretty
aware of that I would imagine because
he's a celebrity yeah and he has lots
and lots of money yeah and like I said I
don't begrudge him all that money
because he just kind of came from a
regular ass yeah family and he made that
and his gig was a fat girl gig I mean
it's not like we're talking about Elton
John because Elton John could probably
pull he could probably pull some dudes
because music has a different effect
that's true just you know what I'm
talking about yeah so I would think you
know El John could probably score
[__] B big looks don't matter as much
if you're like a really good musician if
you're like a rock star like you can
kind of be sort of ugly and still kind
of hot at the same time famous you're
famous you got all this money and uh and
you have emotional
power over people you know what I mean
over the fans yeah that's a whole other
level not quite the same thing that
wasn't that wasn't Richard Simmons gig
you know what I mean his target audience
was likeing straight women who were fat
they' have married him in a heartbeat oh
absolutely hell yeah absolutely hell
yeah but you know that wasn't his thing
well like I said he made them feel like
nobody had made them feel before like so
that was kind of and like I said I don't
think he was doing it in a sort of
calculated way or anything like that
that was just the kind of person that he
was yeah uh or is like he's still alive
as far as I know so I don't know why I
don't know why I'm talking about him in
the past so for all our gays out there
go ahead and drop in the comments do you
do you think do you think that Simmons
could pull I don't think Simmons could
pull I think that if he got into [__]
La scene a bunch of gold diggers had run
through him I mean La is real like I
said it's real superficial that's kind
of like you have to look like super
[__] I'm not saying that just like an
average looking person couldn't pull cuz
of course they could but but but it
depends on how good their game was yeah
I think yeah I generally in La like
everybody looks super good yeah so you
it's really hard to like compete right
in that era back then it's really hard
to compete yeah there was no internet
all the good look people had to go to
physical
locations nowadays you could do the you
could be good- looking on the internet
that's another thing that I kind of
respect about Richard Simmons because
it's like even though he's you know just
an average to okay looking dude yeah and
but just by the sheer will of his
personality and
his just his his Vibe like his whole
energy like his compassion everything
like that he almost kind of like I like
this is a weird thing to say but it's
like he almost willed himself to be like
super famous not even famous he's iconic
yeah I kind of feel like even people
that weren't alive back then still know
who the [__] that is which is crazy got
a new guest in there that says he's
seeing Zach in other live streams oh
really yeah is he cheating on us with
other live streams Z cheating Z you
cheating on me [__] that's it
I'm I'm [__] jealous oh I'm jealous
with my
man Larry said when we were talking
about
um sexual stuff before Larry said a
trainy sucked my [__] before I was drunk
what can I say well you know [__]
happens I wouldn't worry about it I
wouldn't worry about it either I would
worry about it's fine no one's upset
about it it's it's okay you were still
in the top position like I said [__]
happens we've we've been drunk Dove off
into that ass I'd be looking at you
differently I wouldn't what's the
difference I'm a man I'm a man I'm just
going to look at have weird hang kind of
stuff just gonna say men have weird
Hang-Ups about that kind of
stuff not saying women don't have some
Hang-Ups St but I'm just saying men have
like more hangups I feeling I'm not
going to say that bad but I'm just going
to say you're
gay you know I don't know man it's kind
of like it's kind of all over place at
least you were gay on that
night we have another new person at
least you were a you're a new person I
don't know how long you've been
listening but you're a new person in the
chat Billy lean hi from Ireland well hey
I wasn't expecting this as a topic for
your show I wasn't either actually but
somebody recommended it and it won in
the poll we do a poll on uh patreon and
all the YouTube members like we poll
people every week um says definitely not
the usual subject matter I love your
specs by the way thank you very much uh
yeah Tom bought me these yeah my glasses
better get you another pair of those
because those are damaged now yeah they
did get kind some [__] fingernail
polish fingernail glue got on them and
ate a hole a a dimple in it yeah
weirdest thing I've never seen it do
that I thought it was something stuck to
it no it made a hole Zach says he was on
Avalanche reviews stream I told him
about you guys oh really who's Avalanche
you I don't know I don't know that one I
might have seen it but I don't really
know I I've so many [__] things you
know what I mean but yeah so all right
so where was I yeah so yeah so he opens
up the thing like I said slimmons and he
went there like like I said 40 [__]
years the dude showed up and taught
classes in a different crazy outfit and
actually like other I was watching a
documentary earlier and like one of the
women was like yeah like he would come
up with crazy [__] like he would turn up
like sometimes with like [__] purple
wings or like one time he came up in a
dress made of sporks and it's just got
so he would like come up with like crazy
[__] like every single time and then it
was just kind of like exercise thing it
was like 90 minute class I think it was
90 minutes and it's just like so you'd
have your aerobics or whatever everybody
was like super jacked about it it was
super fun and then you'd have kind of
like the the whole thing and he's just
he would kind of bear his soul at the
end and kind of cry and other people
would bear their soul and kind of so it
was almost like a therapy session but
you were also getting like physical
exercise too which is kind of nice so a
lot of people would turn up like every
week like for years and
years so so he had that for a really
long time and it was like really
successful now because of this because
of his new approach I guess because he
was I guess like a you know getting into
an underserved Market yeah these are
people that wanted to get in shape that
didn't like their bodies but they didn't
they felt intimidated by the fitness
industry they didn't really want to go
to gyms because they felt like people
would laugh at them or whatever so they
found a place where they felt kind of
like accepted and and loved and like you
know and it was a good time like he's
like he always made it super fun so that
kind of caught the attention of the
media so I kind of feel like his big
thing he showed up do you remember the
show real people yeah long time ago he
turned up on that show like in the 70s
okay and I kind of feel like I don't
know if I want to say if that was like
his big break but I think that was like
his big media introduction because they
went to his gym and they're like hey
here's this crazy over-the-top guy with
these crazy outfits who's doing this and
like no one's really doing this and it
really kind of like struck a cord it
seemed like like with the
audience so um this kind of led to other
TV appearances like he was on a lot of
TV shows like all the talk shows yeah
but he was on uh game shows he was on
like [__] soap operas he was on all
kind of [__] like I said if you were not
around in the 70s 80s um the dude was
[__] everywhere he was on every
single talk show he was on it CU he was
a fun guest you know cuz he would come
on he would always have some kind of
crazy outfit on and he was always like
super over the top and like super caddy
and he was just like super funny so he
was like always really entertaining
guest so he would always get on he had a
real high pitch voice he was real
[__] well [__] you can go on on
YouTube Hey everybody we're going we're
going to get we're going to burn off
some of this fat today he's just like
that you know what I mean that and I
gave y all that impression okay out of
the bottom of my heart or the heart of
my bottom normally the only other
impression I got that I'll do every now
and then I had a comment on was [__]
they love my impression of [__]
Michael
Jackson oh yeah when we did show Michael
Jackson a few weeks ago Michael Jackson
yeah I tell you they just
ignorant sometimes a man like love the
show men and little boys just there's
nothing wrong with it we sleep in the
same bed for over a week
demonetized sleeping in the bed for a
whole month and it doesn't mean anything
yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful it's
just it's just people thinking dirty
it's ignorant it's
ignorant yeah but he was getting that
booty too well he tried to get that
booty I'm kind ofan but it hurt too much
so they were saying no yeah we talked
about that it just yeah I mean he was
smooth Micha Jackson was smooth smooth
the Smooth Criminal the Smooth
Criminal we talked about that at
L like I said I was willing to give them
benefit of the doubt I was like maybe
he's just kind of a weirdo and like but
the more I looked into it I was kind of
like Bo came forward I think it was
pretty much exactly what it looked like
yeah it is exactly what it looked like
allly said do you really think he is
still alive Richard Simmons um as far as
I know yes I think he is still alive
probably 7 just join now yeah I think
he's about 75 years old I think just
turned
75 earlier this year or late last year
uh perhaps they has dementia I don't
think it's dementia like we'll kind of
get into that later but when is the last
time anyone saw him the last time he was
seen in public as far as I know was
early
2014 but I think some people have like
seen him after that but there's not like
super like confirmation I don't know
we'll get into that but yeah so so yeah
so I kind of feel like that was kind of
when he got super popular when he was on
real people and people kind of saw his
thing like I said he's um I kind of
laughed because I was listening to that
uh there was a six episode podcast
called missing Richard Simmons which is
about it it's really good it's on Apple
podcast I listened to it earlier um and
the guy there it's uh Dan I can't
remember his last name chabowski or
something like that uh who was like a
friend of his who had gone to his
classes and stuff and he got concerned
when he disappeared so he decided to
make a kind of a documentary kind of
thing about it and he he was like um
Richard Simmons and his a less and I was
like yeah that's a good way of putting
he was a lot um he was very over the top
he was very screamy um but that was kind
of his whole shtick that was why he kept
getting invited back to that's why he
was on all the TV
shows so he's on all these game shows
and stuff like that now he eventually
attracts the attention of the makers of
the very famous soap opera general
hospital and they invited him to be on
the show and he actually played himself
on General Hospital yeah he's on there
one episode and I saw like a fragment of
it like earlier today and he's like I
said he's playing himself so he's like
these two girls and they want to lose
weight and he's just like trying to pump
them up and everything and after this
show this episode aired he got so much
fan mail that the makers of General
Hospital were like do you want to be a
recurring character and he ended up
being on that [__] show for like four
[__] years right like on General
Hospital because it resonated so much
with
people so um so yeah so he was on there
for a long time he did like I said he
did a couple of cooking shows he did one
called slim cooking and he did like a
talk show and [__] like that um so yeah
he and he was on like a bunch of he was
on SNL a bunch of times he was on chips
I think like he you know usually playing
himself because he was you know he's
such a larger than life character you
can't really play another character if
you're Richard zimmons he was in a bunch
of commercials [__] like that now here's
the weird thing so um oh another thing
too was that he was kind of he was on
the Howard Stern Show a lot yeah and the
two of them I kind of feel like they
were sort of kind of friends yeah um
outside of the show but back when Howard
was relevant yeah I mean I think that
here's the thing though and this happen
happened with David Letterman too
because he was on a lot of um he was on
David Letterman a lot
also Richard Simmons he you know he he
very much cultivated this
persona but he still had that very
insecure person at the heart of it so if
he perceived that you were like making
fun of him he would get like really
upset about it like David
Letterman um you know know I they did a
show and there was a thing where David
Letter where where Richard Simmons I
think he dressed up like in a turkey
costume and he was like trying to kiss
David Letterman like he was just trying
to be funny or whatever and David
Letterman sprayed him with a fire
extinguisher which
is not great and had Richard Simmons had
an Asma attack like a really bad asthma
attack um and so then after that like he
didn't talk to him for like six years
because it hadn't been a setup I mean
that is kind of [__] up like doing
that I'm just saying yeah he just letman
probably thought it was a good gag yeah
like I said and and like I said and I
get this I get where Richard Simmons is
coming from like he has this Persona
he's like super over the top and he's
just kind of um you know funny and
everything like that but when he
perceives that anyone's like making fun
of him he gets like real sensitive about
it which like I said I get that because
it comes it's comes from like insecurity
and stuff so I get that but so so if he
perceived anyone was making fun of him
cuz I even saw like on this documentary
I think it was the TMZ one that I was
watching they had Suzanne Summers on
there who was friends with him and she
said and she said she's like yeah he
sometimes thought that I was making fun
of him and he would get like really
upset about it she's like but I wasn't
though like some of the stuff that I was
saying so he was real sensitive to that
kind of stuff but like I said I you know
I get that so that was just kind of like
his personality you know so um so yeah
so there was that whole David Letterman
thing he did eventually go back on David
Letterman um and then I think there was
this he went back on there later and
then there was this situation where they
were trying to like cook something
together and like something exploded and
Richard Simmons like [__] freaked out
and like ran off as you would when
something exploded um but he didn't get
mad about that like he kind of compared
he's like oh my God it's like Michael
Jackson in the Pepsi commercial or
whatever which like I said I think we
talked about that Michael Jackson show
where his hairon of fire that was kind
of like a big thing back in the time but
so yeah and so okay so what happened was
that so he had been what I'm trying to
set up is that he was a
ubiquitous media presence the dude was
on all the talk shows he was on other TV
show he was [__] everywhere he like
there was videos there was like people
dressed up as him for Halloween it was
just like he was a cultural icon right
yeah like some people would make fun and
it was like a punchline and stuff like
that but it's just kind of like he was
super welln I remember even in Middle
School people were making fun of
[__] but people liked him though but
they would tease him yeah and he was
real sensitive to the teasing and I get
that but it's just kind of like um what
was funny about it is that he was an
oddball for the time this is supposed to
be a fitness show and he's not all that
fit in those days of Fitness show those
[__] were [__] jacked or
[__]
shredded but that's not what his Target
was so there was
some it took a while for the market to
get used to what he was doing you know
yeah I feel like he kind of really ahead
of his time to be honest with you he was
ahead of his time because not only did
he whether willingly or unwillingly like
um recognizing a gap in the market yeah
as then there's like a whole Market for
people that want to lose weight but are
intimidated by gyms and like don't want
to do uh you know the standard fitness
routines like you had like in the early
'70s and just want like just to look
like an average person you know what I
mean right now in the real world here in
the United States there's a there's a
bunch of gyms that tried that same
strategy it's called Planet Fitness well
later later but I think they kind of
like came off the back of Planet Fitness
is kind of like the modern day
interpretation of Richard Simmons but
there's a Planet Fitness are great jibs
they had a lot of [__] good equipment
in there they [__] everything looked
good they're painted well they have all
the machines you
need but they had a lot of stuff in
there that turned off into guys that
actually [__] were gy rats
um they would do stuff like have free
pizza night and [__] so you got people
there trying to [__] lose weight but
they're giving them free pizza it's like
well I'm at the gym I'm I'm eating pizza
so really but I'm at the gym there's all
kinds of Planet Fitness videos you had
people that were paying the membership
to go to Planet Fitness but then they
would go there to they were renewing
their [__] membership so they could
get the free pizza and [__] hang out
and just take up space in the gym and
pretend like they were like they were
working out there's videos of people
they don't know how to use the machines
they're not really working out fitness
doesn't care they're like they hey these
[__] are paying they just wanted the
20 yeah they don't care yeah no they do
have instructors there that'll teach you
how to use that but but those people a
lot of the ones that are taking videos
of you can see them on YouTube just look
up Planet Fitness YouTube just crazy
[__] and then they would have stuff on
the walls like no creatine as if
creatine is a [__] illegal drug
creatine is just a think powder you can
drink it's it's what's in meat it'll
help like protein supposed to like mimic
protein and then they're basically
they're going no steroids and all the
kind of [__] you know no muscle heads
and [__] well those dudes stop coming
but that would that was actually a lot
of that that was actually a lot of the
real Market if you have those guys
coming you kind of a real gym you know
so that I got invited to a [__] one
of the real gyms here it's called
Silverbacks Silverbacks to go to
Silverbacks you got to be on gear you
got to be on steroids but those dudes
are [__] huge but here's the thing
it's $125 a month to go to [__]
Silverbacks because it's a steroid
distribution center and you're joining
the [__] club and it's you can hang
out with all the [__] huge dudes and
the girls that hang out there's groupies
that hang out in there so it's a social
club a lot of
gyms that's when you're talking at that
level so it's just I ain't G to pay $125
to go to Silver packs I don't really
care that
much but in in in the defense of [__]
places like Planet Fitness and that
strategy of just trying to dumb it down
to the [__] lowest common
denominator Planet Fitness you can get
the membership and you that membership
card is good all over the United States
you go in there and well they're trying
to appeal to a wider audience like
people that wouldn't normally go to a
gym because they're intimidated the same
the same demographic that Richard
Simmons appealed to yeah there are pro
bodybuilders ifbb Pro bodybuilders that
have memberships at Planet Fitness
because they're on tour and they're
going places and they know they can find
one of those places and work out out and
they're cheap 20 bucks a
month so there's something to it yeah
but like I said there's something to his
kind of approach like an Everyman
approach yeah where you know you weren't
trying to get like super shredded or
jacked or anything like that you just
wanted to lose some weight lose some
weight and look like a normal person
without feeling like you weren't good
enough or somebody was going to yell at
you or something like that um very very
entry very entry F but it worked like I
said and a lot of those a lot of those
that that's a market yeah and a lot of
those and that was an underserved Market
yeah and like I said willingly or not he
really seemed to tap into that and I
don't think it was calculated on his
part he just seemed like a very
empathetic person and he had been
through it himself and so he just kind
of came at it from that point of view
this is what saved my life maybe this
will save other people as as well well
he he saw that that there was a lot of
people that would not enter the fitness
Market at all yeah so he wanted to
especially back then because it was a
lot more yeah it was stringent more more
it was it was more of a narrow bandwidth
you already had to look good to go to a
gym and that's I I guess he kind of
noticed that so he's just like [__]
okay there's got to be a very entry
level and there was a market there so
yeah and he helped people so yeah I mean
he hon people like I said I kind of feel
like um and I don't know what the exact
numbers are but considering that of all
the [__] that I watched and read and
stuff like that about him not a single
person had a bad word to say about him
they all said he was a lovely [__]
person um and that he would go to
events he I mean he always made himself
very available to his fans like I said
you would write him a letter you know
it's like you know I'm 300 lb and I want
want to lose this weight and I You're My
Last Hope and I need help and stuff like
that he would write back he would call
you every [__] week he went out of
his [__] way to help these people he
didn't know them really um and really
not a lot of people would do that yeah
you know so he was almost kind of like
like I was reading an article to say
it's like I know this is weird to say
but he's almost kind of like a saint
yeah because it's just like he was very
very giving of his time and attention
and he would just spend hours and hours
his time Danny Danny's talking about how
uh Home Gyms are better because just the
sanitation and germs and [__] yeah we
have a home gym here it's all free
weights it's it's pretty good but
there's certain things to be said about
big institutional type gyms because they
have machines that can really focus on
certain areas and those machines are
expensive you know especially things
working on your back uh you know rows
and [__] weird [__] lat exercises
and they have some machines that can
really [__] speed up development and
[__] Target areas where you're not
going to really get that done too well
in a home gym and it's faster you just
put how much you just pull the [__]
steak out and put it in what how much
weight you want and this and that free
weights man you got to unscrew [__] and
add weights add plates to it and screw
it all back together and gets old
man I'm thinking about getting a
membership up here what's the name of
that place CJ something what's the name
of that [__] place I can't remember
kind like a Planet Fitness yeah and it's
only it's like a weird like not a very
memorable name yeah it's like a fake
Planet Fitness and uh it's I've seen
people a lot of people going in and out
of there but it's only it's one of the
$20 a month places and I just want to go
in there because they have machines you
can go through those machines quickly
yeah you just fing and they they
probably have couples rates we probably
have fun going down there just go down
there in between your little jobs and
just work out in some of on some of
those weird machines and come back
in it's right there behind right there
behind uh Waffle House The Waffle House
no it's actually it was behind uh Burger
King okay no no not Burger King Wendy's
oh okay it's right there I thought there
was a Waffle House there no behind that
there's a it's it's it's down yeah you
could work at a gym and then go to
[__] Waffle House go to Waffle House
and just eat all that [__] when you're
on gear though and you're working out
you can pretty much eat we're going to
have to I told him I was like cuz we
were thinking about Waffle House the
other day and he's just kind of like is
there wa I'm like yeah there's one it's
it's probably
like 12 miles up the road I think I said
I think it's across from Lo like 12
miles up there see what do he want says
give me a half a dozen
eggs and I want five strips of bacon and
some hash browns [__] I want a big
waffle some toast with yeah that's that
I want a big waffle with like four or
five eggs on it yeah yeah maybe some
fried chicken yeah also some grits yeah
yeah some Bowl toast no grits suck at
Waffle House oh yeah they do WAFF the
Grits are like they don't really season
them no you got to put [__] in grits
otherwise it just kind of tastes like
wallpaper paste I make [__] badass
okay we gotta get back gotta get back to
the subject Tammy says you don't hear of
Jane Fonda calling anyone who bought her
exercise tapes well see I think that's
why like I said that was the big part of
Richard Simmons's appeal was that he
seemed to become personally invested in
every single person and I don't even
know how he had time to do that because
I'm sure that he received thousands of
letters every week from people that were
like hey I'm 300 lb or 400 lb or
something like can you please help me
and it's just like the fact that he
personally as far as I could determine
personally wrote back and called these
people and sometimes would go and visit
them
like that blows my [__] mind and
somebody that at that point had made so
much money from his sweating to the
oldies videos like I said just his first
swea to the oldies video I don't know if
you were in here when I said that his
first sweat into the oldies video he
grossed $200 million damn just from that
one and he made a bunch of other ones
and that whole deal thing that he did I
think it was deal or the cards that he
did that was like another 140 million
something like that so it's like so he
didn't need the money as ridiculous as
this topic is our [__] viewership is
going up well I it's a fascinating topic
yeah yeah they're going up yeah we're
not losing viewers well like I said it I
kind of feel like it's weird cuz
sometimes people suggest topics I'm like
really but then like when I start
researching I'm like oh wow this is
actually really interesting this is
actually really interesting well and
like the more I looked into like I said
I knew who Richard Simmons was like I
said it's impossible not everybody can
relate to this but yeah but he's like a
fascinating person because I found him a
fascinating person because he's a huge
celebrity like I said I wouldn't even
say celebrity he's like a cultural icon
right um just recognizable across
generations and the fact that somebody
like that like somebody
so I'm not like he he's like not he's
like the anti-celebrity a little bit you
know what I mean like yeah he's like
over the top and he has like a Persona
and everything like that but it's just
like the fact that he was so
approachable I think like he just did
regular [__] like he just was really and
seemed to genuinely care about like all
the people that WR and like I can't
really say that about a lot of other
celebrities yeah like yeah a lot of
celebrities will like hang out and like
yeah I'll sign autographs and stuff he a
soft-hearted guy but he yeah and in a
way
that's awesome like we need more people
like that but in a way I think that
[__] him up in the end because like I
said if you're that
empathetic you're going to take everyone
else's
problems and it's going to become a
burden on
you and I think that that was maybe
ultimately yeah and and I see that and I
can see how that would happen
so so what happened and like I said I
wasn't even aware of this until some
somebody informed me about this because
I don't really thought about you know
what I mean I don't I don't really keep
up with celebrity news or anything like
that but apparently what happened and I
think it
was um as far as I can recall I think it
was the day after Valentine's Day of
2014 so almost 10 years ago now so it
was February 15th
2014 and the people who always came to
Richard Simmons uh class in at slimmons
his gym in Beverly Hills he didn't show
up
now as you might imagine um the people
started becoming a little like concerned
because they're were like well he's
always here uh he's always on time he's
always you know very like I said
approachable he's always calling people
he's always texting people but it seemed
like in around February of that time he
had actually been to an event he was
actually I saw some uh footage of him
from kind of like a public appearance or
like a public event from January of that
year of like
2014 and he seemed normal like in the
interview he seemed like slightly more
downbeat than usual but like not
anything that was like alarming or
anything but the fact that this one day
in February in 2014 he just didn't show
up to teach his classes so a lot of his
students like well many of whom were
regulars they started to be come alarmed
they're like where did he go why is he
not
here and so they thought that was a
little bit weird and as time went
on um people started to get more and
more worried because it wasn't just a it
wasn't just a case of him not showing up
for like public appearances anymore
because another thing that he would do
that he was very well known for so you
know if you're in
La in Hollywood and they do uh you get
on the tour bus and they go around to
they're like hey this is Leonardo
DiCaprio's house or whatever the [__] so
it's like so they do these tour bus
things and they would always all of the
tour bus companies would drive by
Richard Simmons's house because they
said Richard Simmons whenever a tour bus
came by he loved that [__] like he would
wait at the
window then when the tour bus came by he
would come out his house and talk to
everybody in the the tour bus you know
what I mean and he would be like hey how
you doing it's like how's you know who
are you like what's your name and he
would like socialize with everybody on
the tour he loved it and he even said
like he loved like socializing with all
the people so much so that there was
like some footage and I saw this on a
documentary earlier he came out his
house when a tour bus came by and he was
talking to people on the tour bus and a
dude drove by like he was kind of like
Oh yay and like he kind of fell backward
like that and a dude was going by in his
car and ran over his foot and I think
like broke the bones in his foot and it
was bleeding and everything damn and
like the guy stopped and he like got out
and Richard Simmons was such a [__]
trooper that he was just kind of like no
it's fine and he kept talking to the
people on the bus he had to go to the
[__] hospital later because his
[__] foot was broken and [__] but he
was like talking to the people on the
bus and they um they talked to some on
that podcast that I was listening to
they talked to like some tour bus
drivers and stuff and they said oh my
God we would always drive by Richard
Simmons's house because he would always
come out like he was our only like
guaranteed celebrity sighting he loved
it like he would always come out and he
would interact with everybody on the bus
and they [__] loved it like he would
just come out and put on a show and [__]
so the fact that somebody like that who
was so well known in the area so it
would just disappear without telling
anybody was very unusual because they
said it it wasn't just a case of like
him not showing up to his class which
was weird enough in itself but he
stopped doing the tour bus thing like
they never saw him anymore he stopped
contact he stopped um calling all of the
people that he had called before he
stopped calling his friends he stopped
calling his family like his brother
Lenny who who still lives in New Orleans
he said well I still see him every now
and then but it's like he I don't know
why he disappeared I don't know like
even his brother doesn't know he's like
I guess that's his decision but whatever
like he didn't really know the reason
and he was a little weirded out by it
it's did he physically change did he
look different see that okay so no one's
entirely sure so a couple of years go by
and everyone is just kind of like what
the [__] happened to like Richard
Simmons like he's not showing up his
classes anymore like I think somebody
else took them over um the place stayed
open for two more years after his
disappearance but in
2016 it finally closed um and they had
like kind of a big thing at the end and
Richard supposedly sent a message like
on social media it's like oh I didn't
really want to come there and say
goodbye and blahy blah um but he didn't
show up like his publicist showed up it
makes me wonder did he gain a bunch of
weight um okay okay that I think not no
but something else might have happened
so here are the theories about it so
some of the theories that were swirling
around kind of one of the main theories
that was swirling around was that he
okay so he had this housekeeper like I
said he never um you know married or
seemed like he was in any kind of like
long-term relationship or anything yes
there have been a lot of speculations uh
that he was gay he's never admitted that
I imagine he probably is but like I said
it's you know it's none of my business
or whatever one of the things that he
said when he's asked about it was that I
he said and this is a paraphrase but
this is pretty much what he said he said
I don't have a lot to offer one person
but I have a lot to offer for many
people he seemed like he was kind of
like I said an introvert kind of a loner
um he liked his alone time like when he
wasn't
on because as much as the Persona of
Richard Simmons like the screamy
over-the toop thing with the crazy
outfits and everything I think that was
him to an extent but I also think it was
you know an act to a large extent also
well it's his stage Persona sure um so I
kind of feel like his real person and he
actually kind of said this in not so
many words but he kind of implied he's
like look I'm you know I'm a Loner I'm a
you know he's kind of an introverted
person so you know he just likes to kind
of go to his house and hole up and not
you know like I said he's an introverted
person you go out you do all this stuff
for other people and then it drains you
so you have to kind of go back and be by
yourself and recharge so I get
that so he would kind of go back to his
house um like I said he really loved his
dogs at one point he had eight
Dalmatians um and his housekeeper whose
name was Teresa now
Teresa um lived with him in his house
for more than 30 years she worked for
him for more than 30 years now they the
relationship between them um I you know
I I don't think it was sexual or
anything like that but he did say that
it was something like she was almost
they were almost like a married couple
in the sense that they'd been a together
for so long and they did so much for
like he bought her a Mercedes he bought
her a house um you know he he took care
of her is what I'm saying and she took
care of him in turn it seemed
like now after he disappeared in 2014 or
disappeared from the public eye there
seemed to be some
speculation that
Teresa was controlling him
somehow um he okay so Richard Simmons
had a for had an assistant who was a
Brazilian guy his name was I think was
Morrow and he was also his masseuse and
they were like really good friends for
like a really long time now Morrow says
that he would come over to the house and
that Teresa really really did not like
him for whatever reason I don't really
know why and that at some point prior
like right around 2014 Teresa told him
to get out the house and never come back
and Morrow said allegedly that when he
asked Richard Simmons is Teresa like
controlling you or is she running the
[__] Richard Simmons said
yes I don't know if this is true this
could be just something that Morrow was
saying I listened there was like a
little bit of an interview with him on
one of the podcast I was listening to I
will note too that Morrow wrote a book
well I don't even know if I call it a
book because I think it was only 50
pages but it was called what was it
called King rich and the evil witch I
think was what it was called it was like
a fairy tale right but it was very
obviously about Richard Simmons and her
about Teresa
now um so
Morrow's
allegation is that Teresa is controlling
Richard Simmons through black magic okay
like to do
what she wants and that her end game is
to like be like to get all his [__] like
when he dies or whatever
okay so that's kind of his that's where
he's coming from with it now santoria
yeah or something like that that's kind
of what he's that's how he's coming in
and I'm not okay I think he does
actually believe that like just from
listening to him talk um he doesn't seem
like he's trying to scam or nothing like
that she's Mexican or Brazilian she's
Mexican okay then not Santa R he's
Brazilian she's Mexican
okay um but from from what I could
determine like everyone else who knew
him like knew Richard Simmons and knew
her because like I said she's worked for
him for 30 OD years yeah and he compares
her to like a wife like she lives in his
house you know what I mean and has and
does everything for him and she does and
he does [__] for her too like he cooks
for her and buys her cars and [__] like
that yeah buddies yeah so I don't
believe it's sexual though from yeah it
and most people said it probably is not
yeah but most people said she is not
that kind of person like she would never
do anything like that but there was
enough suspicion about it that okay so
Morrow I can't remember what year this
was it might have been 2016 or 2017 he
called the
LAPD and asked them to do like an elder
abuse like a welfare check yeah because
he thoughts like something nefarious was
going on which like I said is not weird
because the guy that did the podcast Dan
he was a friend of Richards like so much
so like he started going to his class
and like became friendly he'd been to
dinner at his house and [__] like that
so he was like buddies and he knew where
his house was so he's like they at some
point they built a fence around the
house which hadn't been done
before but and you couldn't really get
in so he's like so he tried to go to the
house and they recorded it like for the
podcast
and Teresa would not let anybody in so a
lot of people started thinking that she
was like the gatekeeper and she was like
not letting anybody see him for whatever
reason and people started thinking it
was for like nefarious reasons you know
what I mean yeah so and I don't know so
like so so the
dude you know it Teresa and the and
Morrow did not like each other I get
that I don't know know how much stock I
want to place in his I it does sound
like he believes it that she is
controlling him somehow and people got
weirded out because when that [__]
started coming out about that because
the podcast I think came out in
2017 so when that podcast came out
people started like worrying about it
and they're just like well maybe she is
like controlling it or something like
that so what better so what year was it
where he started to pull away from his
2014 he did well just pulling away it he
disappeared disappeared at 2004 how old
was he during that time um probably 60
something well he's 75 now yeah so that
was he was so he was in his 60s 60s yeah
so he just okay cuz that was like 9
years ago that's pretty old
60s and he had made it like I said he
made it a public appearance in January
of 2014 like at some kind of I think it
was like a charity event or something
there was nothing unusual up up right up
until he disappeared not really um they
said the only weird things that had
happened um were that you know he seemed
like a little more when he was
interviewed and I saw the footage from
it um from like a month before he
disappeared or something like he was at
a public event like I like I said it was
some kind of charity event or some kind
of big social thing and he seemed pretty
normal um like he seemed slightly more
downbeat than us but not anything like
alarming or nothing now some people
people had said that prior to him
disappearing that he had posted on
because he had like you know social
media and he had like a website look or
or um you know thing where people would
comment like on the boards or whatever
and like that he almost sounded like cuz
some of them thought that he sounded
like
suicidal so they got kind of worried
like I said when they couldn't hear like
when they didn't hear from him anymore
so a lot of people were kind of like
alarmed that maybe he was thinking about
taking his own life or something because
a lot of people that knew him well knew
that you know this you know over-the-top
like joyful Persona that he put out was
not exactly what he was really like um
that he struggled with depression and
that he had other things going on so
some people were worried that he was
maybe thinking about taking his own life
so that was another thing that caused
people concern especially when he fell
off the grid like that because like I
said it wasn't just that he stopped
showing up in public he stopped
contacting every body like even his
closest friends like they would text him
like hey man you know where are you or
what's going on and he wouldn't answer
which was very unusual because he was
usually very
connected so uh so you understandably
like people got really
upset so so the cops so so Morrow called
in a welfare check like an he called it
an elder abuse check you know what I
mean like go in there and check and we
haven't heard from him in a while and
we're like afraid that she's controlling
him
now the cop that went
there claimed that he went there and
talked to Richard Simmons like at the
house for like an hour hour and a half
something like that and that Richard
Simmons seemed fine and that he did not
seem under any duress um he seemed quite
healthy quite fit um and that nothing
nefarious appeared to be going on but a
lot of people didn't really buy that
just because like I said you have to
think this is a dude that's been like
so visible yeah he gave no explanation
why he's not calling anybody back right
and see like I said if he had just right
if he had just like like just ducked out
a private life I don't think anyone
would have blamed like or public life I
don't think anyone blamed him cuz look
that's a lot of burden to put on a
person but your personal friends and
[__] but just like your friends and your
family and stuff like that because like
I said his brother they interviewed his
brother on the podcast his brother Lenny
his brother Lenny said well I saw him at
Christmas like he we we went to his
house at Christmas or something like
that and he seemed okay but it's like
but even his brother didn't know why he
just like stopped talking to
everybody now speculation okay so the
main so the main thing the wildest
theory was that the housekeeper was
controlling him and when that um
allegation started to get out like in
200 or 2016 or
2017 someone it did sound like Richard
Simmons called The Today Show like when
it was on no visual but you know called
his voice yeah and said you know all
this stuff about my housekeeper she's
lovely like she's been with me all this
time it's like it's tot I'm totally fine
you know I just wanted to get out of the
spotlight for I just want to do some
stuff for me and blah blah you know
don't worry about me yada y got but the
the fact that one he wouldn't go on
video and that it was just his voice
people got even more suspicious because
they're like what if she's holding a gun
to his head or well like what if he's
under duress of some kind because people
here's the thing people I and I know
that like if you just want to disappear
if you want to just do like a gretag
Garbo or something like that like that's
she disappeared well she didn't but
she's retired she her her famous quote
was I've want to be alone you know what
I mean so so people say he did a Garbo
and that is your prerogative you a
person you don't want to talk to people
anymore that's entirely up to you you're
an adult but I think that people were
upset because he was just so he was so
much a part of so many people's lives
that they kind of felt I don't know if I
want to go so far as to say betrayed but
they felt like look he was like so much
in my like he was helping me like he was
almost like a therapist like he called
me every week and like we talked all the
time and then suddenly he's not doing
that and he didn't explain why I think
people felt like he had kind of so I
kind of feel like it felt like a
betrayal to them a little bit especially
ones that were like really close with
him and stuff and the guy that did the
podcast who was a fairly close friend of
his he said he kind of felt like that
too he's like look I get that everybody
has a right to just like [__] check
out like they don't owe me anything
obviously I don't own that person but
the fact that they just kind of
disappeared with no
explanation is a little bit troubling
and he's like and I'd like to think that
if I did some [__] like that and I was
having some issues and I was having a
time and I just said [__] this I'm going
to go away and like not he's like I'd
like to think that people would care
enough about me to check that I was okay
so he was kind of trying to
balance maybe you know it whether
Richard Simmons wanted his privacy and
just didn't want to [__] with it anymore
which like I said is totally his
prerogative um with people who loved him
actually being genuinely concerned about
his welfare you know maybe he's
depressed maybe he was suicidal maybe he
needs help and we need to reach out to
him to do that and the fact that they
can't is very upsetting for them so you
really kind of have to like balance both
of things you know what I'm saying so
like I said even though Morrow the
assistant/ masseuse he seemed convinced
that Teresa the housekeeper was somehow
controlling Richard Simmons either
through he thought it was through
witchcraft but you know what I mean um
but it could have been like like I said
through force or other ways and some
other people thought that too because
it's like well maybe like I said maybe
maybe he's making these statements under
Jass the another thing that was
suspicious was that he still has like
all his social media
accounts and every now and then then
there would still be posts on there but
some of the posts seemed like they
weren't posted by him and like sometimes
there'd be photos or videos posted but
they were old you know what I mean like
he was like oh I posted this photo blah
blah like with this thing on it but the
photo was like four years old or
something like that because it had
already been posted so I don't really
know if he was doing that or if other
people were doing that and then I think
in 2016 2017 or maybe it was actually
later than that but they actually
started reposting ing a lot of his old
um you know sweating with the oldies and
all that stuff kind of videos cuz they
said oh well during the pandemic we know
everybody like wanted to see his stuff
for comfort and we know he's not around
anymore so it's just kind of like here's
all this old stuff that we're posting
and yay the people are still enjoying it
and stuff but people also thought that
was suspicious because it's was like
well there's no new footage of him you
know so people kind of thought that was
also sort of fishy by the way Mike
Bowser yeah that's David June oh is it
really oh
okay
that's right I forgot I forgot yeah he
messaged me he says it's me oh okay yeah
but yeah so that was kind of the main
thing I don't know if I buy that um she
does seem from everything that I've read
about Teresa she does seem
very I think the word that uh some
people used was
Gruff um but the cops went there to do a
welfare check and they said that he was
fine and they said they interviewed them
both in separate rooms in T like some
[__] was going on and they didn't seem
to think anything was sketchy was going
on that was the first time some kind of
relationship happen yeah maybe I'm not
really sure I wouldn't say sexual
relationship there's some kind of
friendship thing that he just yeah I
mean like I said she worked for him for
decades um and they seem like and she's
the only person that lives there her and
the dogs um he doesn't have a partner he
doesn't have kids or nothing like that
so could be that could be that Simmons
just said [__] it I I don't want want to
do with anybody else I'm done maybe it's
something like that which like I said is
totally understandable like I get it I
don't want to talk to anybody else I
want to just [__] forget all that
because if they got people that just
walk away from their lives they never
seen again probably committed suicide
you don't [__] know I mean Jesus
Christ if anybody has the right to do
that he does yeah because look at he
spent 40 [__] years of his life yeah
just giving giving giving giving like to
other people and it could be kind of
something like suicide but don't
actually kill yourself you just sit up
in your house amongst all that [__]
wealth eat and watch [__] and just
become a recluse just might be yeah and
like I said he did seem to have those
kind of reclusive Tendencies before
because I saw an interview with him when
it was young yeah and he said that he
was very reclusive that he wasn't really
into like partying or anything he was
just kind of like hanging out in his
house all the time so um so yeah so
after the um missing Richard Simmons
podcast came out which is actually
really good you can listen to it on
Apple podcast I listened to it early
it's like six six episodes so it's like
three hours something like that um after
that came out like um Richard Simmons
called The Today Show and said no no I'm
fine um you know nothing's wrong blahy
blah but he didn't explain like anything
he just said I'm fine I'm not
missing um so like I said they did the
LAPD did visit his house in uh spring of
2017 and said he's fine he's just doing
what he wants to do he's doing his
business like leave him alone now he was
hospitalized a couple of times in this
time period um one time was for quote
unquote severe indigestion not sure what
that was about the other time I think
was for quote unquote erratic Behavior I
don't know what that's about either but
the thing about it was that whenever he
went um he would always have all these
people around him and they put a blanket
like all the way over him like all you
could see was like his shoes so he
didn't like want to be seen I
guess
now then in early I believe it was 2017
early 2017 the [__] National Inquirer
because you know how [__] classy they
are they come out with this big front
page thing that Richard Simmons
disappeared because he's transitioning
into a woman and now he wants to be
called Fiona and there was like a really
bad Photoshop of Richard Simmons like
laying on a gurnie or something like
with women's hair or whatever that's a
good idea though I I got to say that
which that's a good story that's right
in the inquir house inqu that's good for
inquire that's a good story so they put
this like right on the front nobody
takes inquir seriously by the way I mean
I would hope not the
sun it's just you it's kind of a gag
newspaper yeah I mean I'm sure there are
some dumb asses that do take it
seriously
but probably like more dumb asses than I
want to think but man but yeah so they
put that on the front page um now
according to the TMZ documentary that I
saw like a friend of his actually was
able to call him up and said um hey saw
The Inquirer about you and richardon was
like yeah and he's like um so he didn't
really think it was true but he's like
so are you becoming a woman he's like no
obviously he's like yeah I didn't think
so and so what happened with that
was that Richard Simmons actually he
didn't come out of hiding or anything
but he did file a lawsuit against the
inquire for uh liel yeah now got mad he
got mad over that well yeah well I you
know I can understand that but the thing
about it so it goes to he didn't show up
in court or anything but it goes to
court and the judge threw it out or
actually he made Richard Simmons
pay like the court cost and stuff like
for the inquir
his cu the judge's argument which I kind
of agree with but I kind of don't the
judge said well being accused of being
transgender it's not is not bad so it's
not like he's like I don't want to
validate people's prejudices against
transgender people by like legalizing it
in a sense which I get that and that is
kind of an admirable stance but then
like people that are actually
transgender are like what are you
talking about like you know it is kind
of because the whole argument that
Richard Simmons uh lawsuit was making
was that well you're opening me up to
ridicule and hatred and stuff like that
um the judge was trying to argue well
being transgender isn't inherently bad
so he's like yeah I understand that
people do you know uh do hate those
people and that does like open you up to
ridicule but not enough that you should
win a lawsuit against it for being
accused of that because it's not bad
inherently so I get that but like the
transgender Community was like yeah but
we do kind of get [__] with so you
know maybe you should have but I don't
know but like Richard Simmons did
actually have to kind of pay like
National so he wasn't like happy about
that I'm not really sure how I fall on
that because it just it seems like a
shitty I don't know this kind of and
this is obviously not to the same extent
but like every now and then like in the
YouTube comments I also get accused of
being a man for for whatever reason I
got another one the other day um yester
or yesterday yeah two days ago it's
probably based on your
comments I can't no well I don't even
remember what video it was on okay I
think it was one that I did by myself
but um but yeah so I do get that every
now what did you say I don't remember I
have I'll show you tomorrow I don't
remember it is kind of funny well I just
I usually just ignore it because I'm
just kind of like okay whatever lame
person well you got you you got to your
your voice and they don't realize you're
51 they I think they expect you to be
like like [__] 21 or 31 or something
that's part of but here here's the
thing America and the West [__] you
know North America I don't think Europe
so much they're having like [__]
[__]
shock I grew up I grew up I don't
understand why people are just so like
get the [__] over it Jesus Christ why
are people so worried about it I don't
get it I grew up I grew up in Brazil all
right [__] back in the 80s I'm just
open like whatever whatever man and S
Paulo man s Paulo was [__] known for
the [__] best [__] transexuals in
the goddamn world we had when I was
there the reigning supermodel her name
was herberto closi all right and she was
transgender you can just look her up
she's still
good-looking um but she was a
supermodel if you were in the clubs in s
Paulo and a and a girl was giving you
some
action trying to come your way you she's
a little bit too aggressive but she was
hot as
[__] you started to immediately suspect
that she was transgender cuz really they
were in those days they were [__]
better on the average they were a lot
better looking than the
average uh what do you call them [__]
biological woman just they still got him
today man [__] look up Bruna
Butterfly you'll see what I'm talking
about you see what I'm talking about I
just I don't get like people are so
[__] narrow bandwidth man it's just
kind of like a dude can take [__]
hormones and [__] uh uh test and and
[__] steroids and work out and become
hyper masculine more of a man than
biologically possible
okay a male can do the same thing with
female hormones knowing what they're
doing they just become more F and yeah
there's surgeries involved and stuff to
get the [__] bottom of the jaw right
and this and that it also depends on
when they do this in Brazil they were
doing this clandestinely
because there it was an it was an anarco
tyranny you can buy whatever drug you
wanted you could get whatever you
wanted the laws didn't matter if you had
money so most of those girls never went
through male puberty they were females
by 13 14 taking female hormones so they
never went through them there was no
skeletal issues is it healthy I don't
know they seem to live long enough but
you have to keep up with that that's
well and I think they I mean they're
aware of what they have to do they you
know so it's just kind I don't know it's
just it's weird like Tammy makes the
point they were lying about him yeah and
that's the thing I don't think it was a
case of like I I understand like the I
agree with the judge saying it's like
well being transgender isn't inherently
bad so it's just like calling you that
isn't insulting you necessarily but they
were lying about him because he wasn't
actually transitioning so it's just kind
of like I don't know that's kind of like
a legal gray area I guess I mean it's
still kind of liable if they're like
like making [__] up about you though
right the weird thing about I think but
I think that you have to prove that if
to prove liable because it's in the U us
I think the laws are more stringent and
well at least in the UK but in the US to
prove liable you not only have to prove
like they people can lie about you all
day long like nobody cares but um you
have to prove that if even like if they
lied about or what they said about you
like damaged your reputation enough that
you weren't you couldn't make money or
like you had some kind of like like [__]
happen to your like your wife left you
or whatever the [__] like you have to
prove some kind of like concrete thing
that happened to you like as a result of
the lie that they told about you so it
can't just be oh they lied about me
because that happens all day
long you have to prove some kind of like
concrete uh you know uh result that
happened because of the lie that they
told about you well next time they come
at you with the Trans things just send
them your [__] mini vids and just say
[__] watch a video and see make sure
you know [__] you know make some
money off of them those are those are
[__] saps anyway I think this shit's
funny it is it's just it's odd fun it's
just like I said I'm not offended it's
just odd that I keep getting
that I'm like it's just like is this
some weird offand way of you like
wanting to see like a photo of like not
me not having a dick the videos are out
there cuz I don't videos are out there
like I said there's videos out there
videos out there if you really want to
know slamming the hell out of it it's
all good you got better ones coming you
know yeah I really don't have a dick and
never have never have had one well you
could go back in time like from [__]
uh two or three years ago and her voice
didn't sound like that uh but like I
said this is that's temporary once
certain things are done you she can come
on she's nowhere near where it be where
and like I said the thing about my voice
like I I know we bring it up a lot but
honestly I didn't really I'm not saying
I didn't notice it CU I did yeah but it
didn't bother me until people started
bringing it up well you brought it up
too no people no the reason I brought it
up was because other people started
bringing it up and then I was like oh I
guess that's a thing if you look at all
your top fitness girls their [__]
voices are [__] rougher than hers I
mean I don't mind my voice actually but
bakar Nava's voice is like twice as
rough as that and vakar you would never
confuse her for a [__] man you know
she looks like a [__] leopard she
doesn't look like a human almost you
know she's [__] looks like a damn
cartoon character she looks like
something out of a superhero
novel but she's gonna have a rough voice
that's just what it's going to do to you
yeah brce said if I got accused of being
transgender I honestly wouldn't care I
don't really care either I just think
it's like weird well I and and I don't
think it's weird because I'm being
accused of transgender I'm I think it's
weird because other people would care
yeah that's why I think it's weird like
and that you would care enough to
comment on the video of someone you
don't even know some dudes like why
would you take the time that's very very
strange to
me why would you care that much I found
in the [__] enhanced Fitness scene uh
there a lot of the audience is very
insecure males yeah clearly they're
little balls of estrogen all right and
compared to you yeah you would be a Man
compared to them that that's how yeah
they'll beat your [__] ass yeah
that's how low low their testosterone
levels are I'll beat your [__] ass
and then I'll shame you about your like
lack of knowledge about horror movies
some of these younger guys you look at
them and it doesn't look like they went
through puberty properly and you're like
and they talk and it sound to me it
sounds like a woman you know which when
I was on Trend was disgusting you know
to see dudes like that I wanted to kill
them and rape
them yeah that was a whole other thing
we've talked [__] yeah Trend makes you
[__] crazy all right and it was only
towards really weak men you just wanted
them gone you wanted to just Stomp Them
into [__] jelly you know which is
it's a very mind altering [__]
hormone do not take Trend yeah we've
said that before yeah do not take Trend
Bryce says I always get accused of being
straight M Bowser says I don't know
Jenny's voice sounds the same it's like
I constantly sisten to mammouth Mountain
pter guys to go to sleep like I did the
audio book like several years back and
it's pretty similar yeah I didn't really
think it was that different like I said
I didn't really it didn't occur to me
until people started bringing it up yeah
in comments and like in person like a
friend of ours yeah said something about
that girl
there has other issues she brought that
up I know you're talking about yeah you
know what I'm talking about yeah she and
then it just kind of made me feel I was
like what well she wanted to combat
weight all right and uh when it came
down to injecting things she started to
go like well I I don't know if I want to
do that and then she goes there's got to
be bad side effects somewhere and she
goes her Jenny's voice did change and I
said yeah but if she didn't do that
she'd probably be fat like
you did you really say that no but
that's what I was thinking oh [__]
without that she would be fat like you
[__] because
yeah because once a woman gets Beyond a
certain age the hormones just aren't
there to [__] processed food I'm not
bothered I mean to be honest I've never
been the girliest of girls ever sincey
ever since I don't know if I'd go that
far cuz I I kind of feel like tomboy is
more like oh I'm going to go play
baseball and [__] that I don't like
sport or like that but I was always into
kind of like boy [__] I was always into
like horror movies and Science and [__]
like that which that was all the good
thing sadly is kind of considered boy
stuff yeah that's all the good thing
though because uh [__] I had a lot
more in common with you and look I tell
you one thing is that Jen dealing with
Jen she's a woman she has some women
female
idiosyncrasies but a lot of her is like
dealing with the dude which is a good
thing because you can reason with her
and and like hyper feminine women you
can't reason with them they're just well
I can't reason with them either yeah she
can't reason with them she knows exactly
I can't I can't hang with super girly
girls yeah super girly girls are just
they get on my [__] nerves well and
like super dudely dudes get on my
[__] nerves also I don't really like
people that are like one extreme or the
other in that sense you know what I mean
yeah sometimes the super doodly dudes
like you're talking about aren't all
that doodly when you get down to the
bottom of it well that's why I can't
hang with them because it's all yeah
it's covering for insecurities and I
can't really when I was talking about
earlier talking about hormones and
hypermasculinity
a lot of these dudes that are on this
[__] you looking are [__] huge right
those dudes cry at the movies they're
very hormonal and [__] sensitive that's
okay they'll attack you because you hurt
their feelings uh it's because [__]
there's there's a lot of hormones going
on in there and uh nice guys they're
they're actually nice they're not but I
I I I have a different symp athetic
abilities with them because I know what
they're taking you know I would you know
what I would rather a dude that saw like
a sad movie yeah like a dog got killed
or something which don't do that in
movies and that dude cried yeah yeah and
then he owned it yeah don't pretend you
didn't cry that's [__] sad well when
you're taking when you're taking a lot
of gear that's a human reaction when
you're taking a lot of gear don't be
ashamed of that taking a lot of gear
you're going to have estrogenic
reactions and progesteron actions
and high levels of progesterone aren't
really normal in guys that's more normal
don't pretend you don't feel [__] right
that's make it kind of make you kind of
sensitive but see I like that yeah yeah
I don't like people that are like overly
s well nobody likes that I don't I don't
like girls that are overly sensitive I
don't like dudes that are overly
sensitive yeah but I don't like people
that pretend they don't feel anything
either yeah cuz I kind of feel like
that's a dude thing it's just like oh
that movie wasn't scary or that wasn't
sad or whatever it's just like [__] that
I I don't and like I said feel emotions
yeah emotions are human it's it's fine
yeah you know what I mean like don't go
like crazy with it yeah yeah what I was
saying you know Jim Bros are uh
emotional that's that's okay honestly
and and I'm going to say as much as I
never want you to take Tren ever [__]
again seriously don't ever do that no
it's not worth it there was one thing I
did kind of like you call it simpy but
it's I did kind of like that you it
almost kind of like opened you up to
feeling emotions more like a woman would
feel I guess if you want to put it that
way well it's everything at once well
you became more empathetic toward
because when I explained to you it's
like cuz you explained oh I'm feeling
like this and I was like oh you know
women feel like that most of the time
you know what I mean and the fact that
you were able
to you're like oh you understood it I
think that kind of like widened your
bandwidth so yeah because I found you
much easier to deal with after that
after you went off that [__] yeah never
again thank you very much Bryce what did
he say uh he gave us $10 thank you very
much I listened to an old movie review
you guys did burnt offerings oh my God I
love that [__] movie and the book is
great too if you've never read the book
uh Robert morasco wrot the book please
read it your voice didn't sound
different to me your accent sounded more
like uh the Hodge twins through love the
show just tuned in yeah I honestly I
don't and Tammy said I didn't really
notice until I watch your old shows yeah
like every now and then I don't usually
watch our old shows but every now and
then like I'll hear like old shows like
yeah it was slightly higher but it's
like I don't know I'm not bothered yeah
it's just it's weird to me that yeah the
Hodge twins that's a good
observation um if you don't know the
Hodge twins are they're two ex- Marine
twins they're they're ex well they're ex
body exfitness guys and The
Comedians and they're from
Alabama and their accent is very
delta Mississippi Delta sound in
Louisiana excuse
me Mississippi and Alabama sound
similar they're mixed guys they're
they're black guys they would be
considered black in the
South but my dad and all of his friends
sound exactly like that if you and
that's the way people in the Deep South
Sound um doesn't really matter their
color if you were to hear my dad on the
phone or those guys you wouldn't be able
to know who was wellc
it's just a lot of a lot of black isms
are more like southernisms more than
anything else they just kind of spread
out everywhere that is true and so but
where where it came from was Mississippi
and
Alabama and uh a lot of the a lot of it
actually you can trace it back to
[__]
Scotland archaic Scotland and Ireland
and Northern which is weird to think
about really yeah the diction that we
use a lot of the ter technology that we
use actually comes from Scotland 1600s
in the middle of [__] Clan Warfare
you know thousands of years of [__]
Mutual murder between families and
that's a lot that's really kind of what
the South sprang from even in the old
days in the 1800s it was more like
pre-industrial it was more kind of like
feudal Japan than it was the North or
America South is very interesting
especially those two states Mississippi
Alabama
Louisiana Florida Panhandle also about
the same thing AKA Alabama South yeah
Kentucky and Tennessee we're almost kind
of refined or the redneck Riviera they
also call it that Kentucky and Tennessee
were considered like refined and
civilized and Virginia that was compared
to Mississippi and
Alabama but good people good people just
a different way of doing things well you
know but yeah so there was that so there
was a whole lawsuit like I said Richard
Simmons I guess he kind of lost it
because even though technically as Tammy
said they did lie about him because he
wasn't
transitioning um the judge like I said
didn't want to validate the prejudices
by saying that that was a bad thing
which like I said is kind of like I said
I I agree with that but I don't agree
with making Richard Simmons pay the
[__] court cost for the national
inquire cuz [__] that they should have
just thrown it out is what they should
have done if they were going to go that
route but yeah no it wasn't like Sony
Bean in the cannibal family South had
food we didn't have to cannibalize
people I mean I've never eaten a person
no South had a lot of food that you know
of yeah South was Paradise Tom's
probably eaten a person no I haven't
eaten anybody but the not yet i' had to
be real desperate I'd have to be real
desperate or real mad or real mad yeah
I'd have to really despise
you yeah I could think of some people
that I'd be mad enough at to eat sure
and it would have to be outside the
realm of Law and Order we you'd have to
be I'd have to be in the apocalypse
because I wouldn't want to be held
accountable for
that yeah if there's a zombie apocalypse
oh I'm absolutely people I I don't have
a I don't have a problemin requirements
man you like those dudes down and turn
Tom's even after the zombie apocalypse
Tom is going to keep working out so if
he can't get protein one way he's going
to get it somehow it's going to be like
Terminus Walking Dead he's going to say
he's going to have a grill and
everything yeah but um I don't blame me
I'd probably do the same you know what I
mean but like I said you got to be real
[__] I dress it up so it wouldn't
look human or anything and debone
everything and make nice fet fets just
get some like [__] fire ass me or
something it doesn't look like a person
deer dress as deer yeah it's fine it's
fine like I said you'd have to be a real
I'm not going to do that to nice people
I'll I'll just do that to [__] so
you know what I mean unless I unless I
get real hungry but yeah so um so we
sued the inquire unfortunately he lost
even though like I said I kind of agree
with the judge's reasoning on that but I
don't agree that Richard Simmons should
have had to P pay the court cost for the
inquir because that's kind of shitty but
you know I see where he's coming from
but I don't know if I get it now there
was another lawsuit
filed in June of 2018
and he apparently sued like I said he
didn't show up in court or anything but
he sued a private investigator because
by this point he'd been missing this was
2018 so he'd been missing for four years
and people were starting to get curious
about like where he was and the fact
that like I said he had previously been
so visible and he had like all these
friends that were worried about him and
so some people were hiring private
investigators or having the cop go over
and stuff like that so this private
investigator
allegedly put a tracking device um on a
car that Richard Simmons uh supposedly
used and so he sued him uh for that now
I think that this well at least as far
as Richard Simmons had alleged this
investigator had maybe been hired by a
magazine I think it was in touch weekly
um to put this thing on his car like to
see where he was going and stuff um so
they actually kind of like he actually
ended up filing a criminal
complaint um but I guess they let the
[__] go forward I don't really know how
that one ended up but there's that whole
thing so the thing about it like nobody
his closest friends his family
everything like that didn't really hear
from him much
after 2014 he completely fell off the
grid by all accounts he was still in his
house so in a sense he wasn't like
missing that's why I put like
disappeared in you know uh quotes or
bunny rabbit ears if you prefer the
Eddie as our
terminology but he really wasn't seen
outside anymore and he wasn't like
contacting
anybody now TMZ did a documentary about
it
it in 2022 it's on Hulu if you want to
watch it um I watched it earlier this
morning now their allegation they did
kind of get into the whole you know
maybe his housekeeper is holding him
hostage or you know or he's
transitioning or whatever and they kind
of like dismissed those they thought
what the deal was was that here's one
thing now T according to TMZ I don't
know if this is absolutely true or not
because I I think the TMZ documentary
was the only place that I heard this but
Richard Simmons apparently allegedly was
born with a birth defect in the sense
that he didn't have what was it he
didn't have like all the bones in his
feet or something so I don't know so he
had something like wrong with the bones
in his feet or whatever like and it's a
birth defect so he's had it for like a
long
time so because of this like he's always
had problems with his knees and a lot of
his students students that went to
slimmons said the same thing that he was
always having problems with his knees
now he had apparently had a knee
replacement on one of his knees I
believe it was his right one and I don't
remember what year it was but it was
like a few years back and um so that had
kind of uh you know sort of healed up
and stuff but he really really hated
surgery but the thing about it was that
the other knee also needed surgery and
he really really didn't want to do it
and at this point he was like walking
with a cane allegedly this is what some
people have been
saying so the fact that he couldn't
really walk all that well anymore cu the
doctors were saying well hey if you
don't get this other knee replacement
you might not be able to exercise
anymore um and you might not be able to
walk anymore and he was getting upset
about that um and there was also like
about a few weeks to a month before he
disappeared his last dog because like
like I said he had eight Dalmations his
last dog Hattie who was 17 years old at
the time passed
away um and that was pretty much I mean
they were like the the dogs were like
his family you know what I mean which
you know I get that we have cats and
they're like our children also so the
fact that every time one of them died
like he just was inconsolable about it
and the fact that this was his last
one um a lot of people thought that that
was a Factor as well and actually the
dude that did the podcast he said that
was the last email he got from Richard
Simmons was when Haddie
died um he sent him an email it said you
know I'm sorry to inform like had he
passed away like I need some time or
something like that and that was the
last time you ever heard from him like
back in
2014 so some people have said well maybe
that was contributing as well um and
some people have looked back and said
you know he was kind of talking about
maybe bowing out prior to that like some
kind of cryptic things that he said
prior to that that maybe he was just
kind of like going to duck out or
whatever um they did keep slimmons open
for two years after he disappeared with
other people filling in for his classes
and he they said it was weird because
they kept putting up new signs like
there'd be a sign and it would be like
you know Richard's knee is [__] up and
it's like he can't be like he'll be back
next month and it's like but they kept
replacing it and he never show up you
know what I mean so finally in 2016 they
announced they were closing it and a lot
of people were like upset about it so a
bunch of people like turned up for the
last class and they were kind of like oh
do you think Richard's going to show up
or whatever but he didn't like his
publicist showed up it was like oh you
know Richard's fine he didn't want to be
here today because he doesn't really
like goodbyes like he'll get all upset
and everything and so he never showed up
and that was the thing too like I said
he still kept there was still [__] going
on on social media and he did post
something about that like oh I don't
want to come because you know I'll you
know my I'll my eyes will get all red
and I'll get all upset about I don't
like goodbyes and blahy blah but it's
just kind of like I don't know some
people thought that it didn't really
sound like him or something and like I
said a lot of the stuff that was posted
on his social media was old stuff like
there were pictures that were like
several years old or videos that were
like really old so people started
getting concerned about it but as far as
anyone knows like no one's really seen
him now there has been some allegations
that he have been that he's been going
out like going out for walks or going to
the beach or something like that but
maybe in some kind of Disguise where
nobody recognizes him because there have
been there was a dude on the I think it
was on the TMZ documentary who was um I
don't know like he worked for one of the
tabloids or whatever and it's like look
like our whole job is getting pictures
of celebrities when they don't want
celebrities you know pictures taken of
them so it's like Richard Simmons is
like he's the [__] master of hiding
because we have not been able to get a
picture of this [__] for years
and years and years and that is
unprecedented it's like cuz we get
pictures of like all kind of
[__] that don't want pictures
taken of them but it's like so if he is
disguising himself or something like
that he's like a master of [__]
disguise because we're not able to get
anything on him if he's going out and
about he must really be disguising if
self really well because they haven't
been able to CU everybody knows where he
lives like I said everybody knows his
house they drive past his house on the
[__] tour bus and everything like
that it's very well known where he lives
his house there's pictures of it like
all over the Internet you can find it so
and he's still in there as far as
anybody knows um some people have
speculated that maybe he's dead and
nobody wants to wants him to know but
the thing about it is that what they
were speculating on the TMZ show they
said what probably happened is that
because of his knee
issues um that he might not be able to
exercise anymore he might not be able to
you know he's in his mid 70s now and
maybe he didn't want everybody to see
him as like a feeble old man and he
wanted people to remember him the way he
was and so
maybe um he's just decided that he's
going to Go full cuz the only time he's
been out like the one time he went out
cuz he had to go to the hospital for
some kind of issue that he had like he
had a blanket like over his whole body
except all you could see was his shoes
like his tennis shoes and so they're
like well maybe he's not fat like you
can tell he's not fat and the cops that
went there cuz they've done like I think
two welfare checks on him yeah cuz
people were worried and they said when
they went there it's like he looks fine
like he looks healthy like he looks he's
still thin he's not fat or nothing they
said he grew a beard but that's about it
that's the same thing that uh Betty pige
did Betty P won't allow any last time
we've heard from her I think she might
be dead now she wouldn't allow any
photographs of her she would just record
her voice because she wanted people to
remember the way she looked the way she
looked back in the old days which like I
said if you're known for right your
looks or a particular look yeah I can
see that and evidently she was
hideous in the 60s yeah she was
unrecognizable
that's kind of sad
yeah
well I don't know all the details I
heard that we had to do a show about her
I heard she had a pretty rough life we
should do a show about Betty pige she's
actually a fascinating person one of the
first real kind of mainstream in a
certain way porn stars I got PE even
though I don't think technically
anything she did was porn it wasn't like
nowadays it's very Z yeah just nude and
BDSM
stuff was but by back then that was porn
um it was just legal porn that could be
sold but I don't know what's true about
Betty some of the stuff I heard might
have been
Legends but uh Jen could probably dig it
up um I once heard that she was real
um uh secretive because she was in a
interracial
relationship back in the
50s uh but I don't know if that's true
or not uh Jen could probably dig it dig
it up but I know that she was
uh she liked her job though she
loved being a basically a fetish pinup
model did she had fun doing
it there was a lot of old forgotten
girls from that from those days some of
those girls were just [__] just
genetic phenomes man phenomenal
genetics [__] great [__] physiques
and uh most of them are strippers though
but uh they the the the old school
American Farmland would push out some
girls that were just [__] incredible
man likeing uh nowadays you you'd need
plastic surgery to replicate it but it
was all [__]
natural thing is is the way Betty
actually looked in photographs and in
real life is not the way she's drawn
she's redrawn a lot being
very kind of voluptuous but that's not
how she well she looked very regular
very girl next door and I think she was
a beup appeal yeah she was a be cup
though but she's constantly being
redrawn as like [__] Double D or E
they give her like way bigger tits and a
way bigger she actually right but she
was like a fascinating person right she
seemed like a nice person I always
thought but they had some strippers from
her that had that
build you can dig them up uh x x videos
has most of them just look up vintage
retro [__] you know big boobs
whatever you you'll see them they
[__] I can't remember their names off
hand but there was there was a lot of
them what is she doing I don't know what
are you doing poke oh she's up in the
chair I see her little butt but see okay
so the thing about I think the thing
that's causing all of the I don't know
if I'd call it controversy but all of
the kind of situation about the Richard
Simmons thing is the question
of how
much does Richard
Simmons
owe to
his not just his fans but his family and
his friends and stuff like that because
like I said it would be something else
if he just kind of like just cut off the
fans said you know I don't have the
energy to like like right back to
thousands of people every like I think
everyone would understand that but the
fact that he cut off everyone like even
his friends and stuff and so they were a
little I don't know if I want to say
offended but they were a little confused
because it's like hey this was like a
really close friend of mine and now he's
not answering my phone calls or
answering my texts and that would be a
little upsetting because you don't know
what's going on with them on the other
hand um this is a man who spent Decades
of his life um
um essentially like living for other
people like helping other
people um and with that how much
obligation comes with that is kind of
like the the main question and I think
that that's why people are
so concerned about his disappearance in
particular just because he was so um
visible in people's lives and he was so
much a part of people's lives and then
suddenly he's not a part of people's
lives just just he just cut himself off
from most human contact like very
suddenly without telling anyone ahead of
time and I think that people rightly or
wrongly felt um like I said I don't
betrayed might be too strong a word but
you would kind of feel like that I mean
you know what I'm saying I just kind of
feel like that and the guy on the
podcast made this analogy he said if I
had been to like if I had gone to a
therapist for example for 30 years and
you know yeah I was paying him but I
felt like we had established a rapport
and like I had told him all this
personal [__] about myself and I'd been
to his house and he'd been to my house
and we were kind of friends and
everything like that and then he
suddenly just ghosted me he's like I
kind of feel like I would be owed
something a little bit he's like I don't
know if that's legit or not um so I
don't know I think that's kind of why
people are
so wrapped up in this whole uh in The
Disappearance
because somebody like Richard
Simmons just cutting everyone off
suddenly seems very odd so I can
understand why people were concerned
that something sinister was going on
something nefarious was going on maybe
he's being held against his will or
something like that it's hard to do that
it's hard to hold somebody against their
will for a long period of time not
physical and I don't necessarily think
he was but I do I do get why people
might think that because it is unusual
unusual for somebody like him now you
can do it with mental an in mental
entrapment kind of like the way
scientologists will entrap other
Scientologist where they won't leave the
cult because of religious beliefs and
[__] but that's hard to do I think
that'd be hard to do with somebody like
Richard Simmons to ENT trap somebody
into some kind of a web where to me it
just sounds like dude doesn't give a
[__] just wants to [__] be a recuse
what it s like which like I said maybe
he just reached his saturation Point
yeah which is is perfectly within his
rights because Jesus Christ I mean he
certainly did a lot more for the world
than most people now said that I thought
Betty pige became a born again Christian
she did yeah yeah I've heard so many
things I don't know exactly what's true
I think Jen might need to dig it up
maybe we'll do a show on her I think did
I heard that one also but I also heard
an interview with somebody who's
supposedly her talk about how she wanted
to be remembered the way she was and
that she had a great time doing that and
that she didn't that she she thought uh
she was basically saying she had no
problem with nudity and didn't know why
people cared about it that it was just
something that was fun I don't really
understand why people have an issue with
it either but like I said you know this
is coming from us
we we do that kind of [__] too yeah so
it's it's it's just fun for us yeah I'm
not really bothered we didn't really do
it for the money and I don't really
understand why anybody would be bothered
like I said either watch it or don't
it's just kind of like I'm not bothered
about it Tammy said it would be like you
two just stop doing the show with no
warning we would all be worried about
you guys that's what I'm saying and
that's like to you know to a lesser
extent and I kind of think about that
too it may have not have seemed that way
to Simmons though maybe not it might
have seemed like to him that he handed
the business over and he wanted to step
out of the Limelight and let it run like
a franchise or something he could just
become like Colonel Sanders where just a
pitcher he's a pitcher on the bucket a
[__] chicken you don't see that dude
anymore maybe like something like maybe
and I get maybe his justification was
look if I come out and make a big
[__] to-do about oh I'm retiring like
everyone would freak out and it' be like
this big [__] thing and maybe he just
didn't want to deal with it yeah cuz I
didn't know that any of this happen
which like I said I I can understand
that like I understand you know I'm an
introvert myself so coming from a fellow
introvert like I understand you don't
want a big [__] fuss made about you
you don't want to be the center of
attention like you don't like I get that
so he's just kind of like look I'm just
going to very quietly I'm not going to
tell anybody I'm just going to be just
Homer Simpson backing into the bushes
he's just going to do
that and not say anything to anybody
which like I said kind of seems shitty
to the people closest to him cuz they're
like dude what the [__] cuz like I said
his brother didn't even know like he
still sees him I guess but he doesn't he
didn't tell him why he did it although
black magic is a cool story I do kind of
like that story like wouldn't it be and
I don't want to like cast dispersions on
Teresa because I'm sure she's a lovely
person but it is kind of like funny yeah
that that I don't believe that's like
black magic isn't real obviously but um
it is kind of like a funny yeah it's a
funny um thing to think about that this
woman who's known him for 30 odd years
is suddenly using black magic to likey
and I feel like she doesn't have to he
already bought her a Mercedes he already
bought her a house I'm sure she's
probably getting all his [__] after he
dies because that's his housekeeper but
it's also like his friend and his
roommate um they've lived together for
more than 30 years uh and he compared it
to a marriage yeah so I don't really see
any reason why she would need to [__]
him over this stage um I feel like if
she was going to [__] him over she would
have done it a long time ago um and
everyone that I saw interviews with that
knew her well said she wouldn't do that
like she's just not that kind of person
and I don't really see any reason to
doubt them so and like I said I'm not
[__] on the dude that made those CLA
maybe he does believe that I don't
really know maybe he doesn't know
Richard as well as she does or I don't
really know what the situation is there
um the two of them don't like each other
that's for sure yeah she didn't like him
and didn't like him being over there but
that or at least as far as I could
determine but you know it seems like a
little and the [__] does happen I I get
it like when people get older and a
little bit more feeble or whatever yeah
people will take advantage but I don't
think that's what's going on but I also
on the other hand I also
don't um I don't question why people
would uh uh would wouldn't like go there
and would like ask about that because
people are worried about him like I said
it's kind of like Tammy saying it's like
if we suddenly didn't stream and didn't
have a message about anything like
people would wonder where the [__] we
went like obviously it's not to the same
extent as Richard Simmons because he had
millions of he has millions millions of
people like maybe we'd have like a few
dozen people being like hey what are you
guys dead or what the [__] you know what
I mean but it's the same kind of thing
just like on a much smaller scale this
dude came from the era of [__] early
cable TV and malls all right
and his [__] was in malls everybody knew
this [__] he was a fixture all
right you didn't have much to choose
from I knew who Richard Simmons was I
didn't really want to know who Richard
Simmons was [__] everywhere you see
this [__] you couldn't avoid him you
couldn't avoid it it was and at that
time when you were my age at that time
that [__] was extremely uncool you were
trying to [__] avoid that [__] all
right but uh no he had a little Empire
going and uh an empire built on fat
women you know but they needed him and
like I said it's not you know when you
say it like that it almost sounds like
exploitative but I don't he wasn't it
was he wasn't coming at it like that
which like I said in a way like that's
what kind of makes him cooler because he
seems like such an unlikely celebrity
yeah because he seems like he was coming
at it from a genuine place of look I was
a fat kid I was bullied I lost all this
weight in a really unhealthy way but
then I got in into more health and I
want to help other people to achieve the
same [__] that I achieved and that
seemed to be his only motive he didn't
really seem to have any ulterior motives
and the thing about him that was cool
was that he was very Earnest you don't
really see that a lot and it was
realistic goals he that too and I think
that was a big help he wasn't talking
about getting shredded or be
taking
2050b fat girl and turn her turning her
into a supermodel that's not or you know
clayboy bunny yeah I like I don't think
he ever made those CLS but there were
other Fitness and diet programs that
would infer that based upon the photos
that they were showing made them sucky
they would show some fat girl and
[__] terrible clothes without any
makeup on and then you say and in 90
days and then they show this [__]
fitness model like obviously completed
like you're going to become that in 90
days get the [__] out of here you are
absolutely just by a diet and exercise
no no that's not going to happen it's
going to take a lot of pharmacological
[__] Aid well and even if not like it
would take you like years and years and
years of work to look like that yeah a
girl that weighs that five years at the
gym lifting on
gear yeah yeah you could become you
could become like that now would you
become like her exactly no this your
skin may not recover so there's going to
be certain things there that being obese
causes damage some of it's irreversible
it does yeah so it would take Sur
depending on how long depend on how long
it depend on what it was depends on your
genetics some people just don't snap
back that well but it could be fixed but
you're going to have to go under the
knife that's the thing and I think a lot
of people forget that you know if you're
drastically drastically overweight yeah
even if you're younger like and it's
harder when you're older
like if you lose a bunch of weight
that's good but you're going to have
like a lot of skin hanging yeah and that
you have to cut it off there's not any
other way around it and there are some
female porn Superstars that have had
that
done they've had skin removed and
everything they can see I can know what
they took the procedures they had and
everything and they still they look good
but they had to pay they had to go
through that work yeah yeah I mean you
got to get it done that's just kind of
like and well and that's another thing
too is that um you know people see
models and actors and things like that I
think it's probably less prevalent
nowadays but you know back in the old
days you would see people in movies and
in magazines and stuff and be like oh I
can look like that but it's like they
don't understand that it's like that's a
lot of surgery yeah um that's super
restrictive diets that's super
restrictive exercise plans that's super
I mean you really have to work to look
like that yeah um and you have to get
surgery to look like that and you have
to take things to look like that like
most normal people cannot look like that
yeah you know what was the
transformation again I missed the
beginning was what are you talking about
you said most normal people could not
look like what but what was the starting
point well no like um like actors and
you know models and stuff like that well
a lot of them are always in pretty good
shape uh yeah and I'm not saying like
genetics obviously plays a part like but
that's just the starting point right the
hardest is is to take somebody that
didn't have great
genetics is very overweight and then you
try to move them into the model realm
it's possible it happens yeah but it's
going to it's not by natural means no of
course not no so especially if you've
been that way for a
while yeah and the longer that you're
yeah overweight the worse it's going to
be like when if you lose weight later
like I said it's always good to lose
weight but the the longer that you have
that much weight on you it's just going
to it [__] your body up like in a lot
of ways and you're GNA have to like get
a lot of skin cut off Bryce says lipo is
is common for actually I think that's
even kind of uh P now I'm not sure they
do that I mean they do but I think
there's other procedures nowadays but I
think like all kinds of surgeries are
very common yeah it's a mixture of
everything but uh if you think they're
not [__] taking anabolic steroids and
[__] hormones you're [__] tripping
hell yeah well and I mean we have a
friend I'm not going to I'm not going to
say what his name is but we have a
friend who lost he had gastric bypass
yeah um cuz he was uh I don't remember
how much he weighed but he was pretty
overweight so he had Gast or bypass and
he lost a lot of weight couple hundred
PB couple hundred I think it was 200 lb
yeah um and he looked great but he was
like he was talking about I mean we just
saw him in clo obviously so he's just
like yeah all this like skin hanging
yeah So eventually you're going to have
to the skin is probably not going
anywhere I hate to tell you so you're
going to have to get all of that cut off
yeah he was big for a long time most of
his most of his life he became
unrecognizable it won yeah was not going
to come back unless you're super super
young and even then yeah um and he
wasn't on anything no so he wasn't on
anything to increase collagen production
or anything so
yeah no you're just GNA have to [__]
cut a lot of that
off well like I said if you if you watch
any of this reality shows like my 600 lb
life or anything like that that's what I
tell you he like yeah it's cool to like
lose all this weight and now we're going
to have to like cut all of this skin off
you yeah um people don't really think
about that you know your skin is not
just going
to fit back up it's used to being big so
it's just going to hang there it's just
going to hang there
which that's like the big that's the
biggest argument for like not getting
super super heavy when you're younger
but I know some people are more
genetically predisposed but just saying
that's that's going to have
repercussions like all throughout your
whole life but like I said I don't know
I never saw
like Richard Simmons he seemed like like
I said he seemed um he wasn't ripped or
anything but he just seemed like an
average looking dude
You
Know Rich was very average yeah but I
think I he was ex you know but like I
said I think that that was his appeal he
didn't look super ripped he didn't look
super jacked he wasn't selling you any
promises that he couldn't keep and I
think people related to that and he had
been there he had been really fat you
know what I mean he knew what it was
like to lose all that weight and to go
through all that stuff so he had been in
the same place that a lot of the people
that he was approaching were in so they
could relate to him because they knew
that he was coming at it from that same
you know from that same mindset you know
what I'm
saying uh let's see what are they
talking about
um my Bowser said Christ I got six hours
till I wake up y' are bad influences
what sorry he said he said I got six
hours till I wake up y'all are bad
influences oh okay yeah yeah cuz it's
almost midnight did you know that yeah
it is that yeah [__] I got to put
battery down there on the charger I got
to take off oh yeah [__] you I'm kind of
hungry so we we pretty much covered him
then right I mean pretty much like I
said I think I covered all the stuff as
okay the official story is that he's
just decided to become a recluse yeah he
had some knee surgery he doesn't want to
get the other knee surgery he doesn't
want to see people he doesn't want
people to see see him walking around
like an old man yeah and so he's like
I'm just bowing out okay it's plausible
that was kind of like what the official
story is people are still like wondering
if the cuz the housekeeper still living
there yeah and the dude on the podcast
like went to the house and the and the
housekeeper was like came to the gate
and was like no you're not coming in
damn so yall got like five hours of
Richard
Simmons well I don't know if it was a
whole five hours of Richard Simmons cuz
we were talking about a bunch a bunch of
other [__] too but a bunch of other [__]
work or you're on a [__] long haul
[__] Trucking rig truck or rig trying
to go somewhere you got five hours
knocked off you're on the
airplane I mean I would hope so yeah
Tyler said I love y'all oh we love you
too let me go uh let me go check the
motor yeah Bryce said uh I hope he's
doing well I hope he does too because
like I said um he just seems like a
really really nice man and we really
need more people like that in the world
you know um all the stuff I read him I'm
like man he just seems like a a lovely
person nobody ever had a bad word to say
about him everyone just thought he was
an angel on Earth so I kind of hope he's
doing good too and like I said if he
just wants to like [__] sit in his
house and go in his upstairs because he
has a gym in his house and you know go
in his upstairs gym or swim in his pool
or just hang out with his housekeeper or
whatever [__] more power to him man
you know what I mean he doesn't owe
anybody [__] um I do get that people are
concerned I would be concerned if he was
my uh friend also like I want to know he
was okay but you know he has every right
to just kind of disappear I get
it but you know I just hope he's all
right too so if you're watching this
Richard which you might be because it's
YouTube you
know I hope I hope you're doing okay I
just hope you're doing okay that's all
um M Bowser said good show y'all love
you Tom anden love you chat we love you
too we love all you guys now uh so what
is it it's Wednesday so we'll be back
for the Friday Night Show which of
course is the Sidetrack show which this
kind of was too every show is Sidetrack
show you know what I mean let's be
honest um but you know Friday night at
least we have we we don't have the
excuse of having a topic to like talk
about we just talk about whatever but
yeah so yeah so hopefully you guys can
come for the Friday Night Show hopefully
you guys are having a good November uh
and not too sad about Halloween being
over cuz I'm really sad about it but you
know at least it's getting closer to
Thanksgiving which is also a good
holiday but yeah so we'll see you guys
again on Friday night thank you guys for
stopping by thanks for your super chats
and we will see you guys again on Friday
good night